rudolph giuliani playwright arthur
miller musician peter gabriel and
authors don delillo and e.l doctorow
ah
[Music]
hello
hello
hi
my name is michael linton and i'm the
chairman of the penguin group the
publishers of this book and on behalf of
all the sponsoring organizations i'd
like to welcome you to this event
in support of wei jinxing
this is an unusual publishing event
we normally gather here
in the library to celebrate writers
achievements
to meet them and hear them talk about
their work and their own voices
that won't happen tonight
because the writer we honor is sitting
in a prison cell he can't join us and he
has never seen a copy of his own work
therefore we have asked a group of
people including some of this country's
most important writers to stand in for
way
to write to read you in his words and to
talk with you about his life his
accomplishments and to ask you to help
him get his freedom
we're grateful to paul leclerc and the
new york public library for providing us
with this wonderful room for this event
and for all of the hard work done by the
sponsoring organizations who have worked
with us on creating this unique evening
and now i'd like to introduce the emcee
for this event
author and journalist katie martin is
the chairman of the committee to protect
journalists and currently hosts america
in the world a week a weekly half-hour
broadcast on international affairs from
national public radio
she's the author of four books including
wallenberg a biography of raul
wallenberg the pope conspiracy and most
recently a death in jerusalem the
assassination by extremists of the first
middle east peacemaker
cotty martin
[Music]
thank you michael good evening ladies
and gentlemen friends of waging shen
and thank you for the honor of being
part of this extraordinary gathering
in his cell
behind the thick walls of beijing's
prison number one
waging shen is among the freest men on
earth
that is why he's such a threat to
china's leaders
as his letters make very plain he is
beyond their reach
waging shang practices what is sometimes
known as the as if policy in the human
rights community way behaves as if it
were obvious
that china needs democratic freedoms as
if
laws are meant to protect individuals
not to be used by the powerful to
silence them
decades ago
solzhenitsyn and havel
forced us to confront the darkest side
of the soviet empire we were outraged
and we
mobilized on the eve of the millennium
it is time again for our outrage
we are here this evening
because they have silenced
we are here to demonstrate that as long
as way is their prisoner
we will not be silent
our first speaker is rarely silent in
the face of human rights abuses
arthur miller
the renowned playwright pulitzer
prize-winning author of 16 plays
including death of a salesman in the
crucible
has also written two novels
several collections of repertage and a
memoir
mr miller
[Applause]
[Music]
i was told to be brief and i'm going to
be brief
the chinese government
has decided
in its wisdom
to draw the soul out of a man
and then to try to jam it back into him
with totally different opinions and
views of himself
and the world
having failed to accomplish this
extraordinary feat
with a sentence of 18 years
they slapped him with another sentence
of 17 years
if he won't accept a new soul
the solution is to murder
the murderer
and the one he was born with
by depriving him of proper food and
medical care
and that is what they have been doing
i have worked in china as a director of
death of a salesman
and i learned to respect and value
greatly
my friendships with chinese people
i'm convinced that for most of them by
far
this horrifying treatment of this man
is a travesty of the revolution
and a denial of the norms of civilized
society
waging sheng's agony is the agony of
every man and woman
who understands that to be human
is to be free to speak one's thoughts
whether such protests as this
can make beijing
can move in beijing
it is vital that the man's incalculable
courage
not be greeted
by indifference
i believe waging shang speaks for all of
us
in his insistence at the risk of his
life
that truth is not a trivial
disposable
dispensable thing
in our most unheroic of times
a hero
has risen again
thank you
[Music]
thank you arthur miller
peter gabriel is almost as well known as
a human rights campaigner as he is a
musician
gabriel was the founder of the band
genesis and over the last 20 years he's
pursued a solo career in music he's
all the while retained an active role in
the human rights field and has worked
closely with amnesty international in
championing human rights and organized
many benefits around the world peter
will be the first of several people who
will read some of the letters of waging
shang available to us in english because
of the quite remarkable translation by
christina torgeson peter
[Applause]
[Applause]
in your country
you say human rights conditions are the
consequences
of cultural traditions the social system
and historical changes
did you think that in other countries
they just fell out of the sky
your internal affairs
will bear no interference
but do you think other countries welcome
your interference in their internal
affairs
all this goes to show that the theory of
different standards
does not hold water because you have no
way of proving that your laws and
policies are of a reasonable standard
while those of others are not
in order to prove that yours are
reasonable you would have to cite more
objective standards
we can also see that although the
safeguarding of human rights and basic
freedoms depends on legislation and
policy enforcement on the part of
sovereign states
human rights themselves
have objective standards that cannot be
modified by legislation
and cannot be changed by the will of any
government
human rights issues pertain to how a
government protects and respects the
rights of its individual citizens
not how reasonable the government
is in its actions
these issues have to do with how to
protect the relatively weak rights of
individuals
under the relatively strong organs of
power
they are common objective standards
which apply to all governments and all
individuals and no one is entitled to
special standards
like objective existence and objective
laws they are objective truths
that was why russo called them natural
rights
these natural rights are not protected
by heaven as your bootlegging hack
propagandists try to argue
but our rights with which every person
is born
they are things that we fight for as a
matter of course and we don't need to be
taught by hostile countries and hostile
forces to do so
they are the natural laws and the rights
of life
just like eating or having sex
in other words they are instinctive
and that is why they're called natural
it is a vulnerable sophistry to try and
argue that people can do without food
because there are some people who have
nothing to eat
or the people can do without sex because
there are widows and bachelors around
it is similarly abominable to argue that
people do not need human rights because
they are able to adapt to an animal-like
existence or that there is no such thing
as objective human rights standards
simply because dictatorial slave
societies still exist
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you very much peter
liu xing is the chairman of the human
rights in china a leading pro-democracy
activist since the democracy wall
movement of 1978-1979
he too was a prisoner in china for more
than ten years
for the crime
uh if crime it is of publishing the
transcript of waging sheng's
1979 trial
he wrote the preface to the current
edition the courage to stand alone
he will speak in chinese and his remarks
will be translated by professor perry
link of princeton university
[Music]
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen
i am very happy to see the publication
of waging chung's prison writings
and am further elated to observe such a
conscientious meeting to promote the
book
there can be no doubt that wei jin chang
himself who suffers in prison as we
speak would also feel comfort and
renewed strength if he could observe
these events
mr robert bernstein mr xiao chiang mis
christina torgesen and i among several
others have produced this book with the
aim of offering to the world a more
complete and realistic understanding of
who waging chung is
unless something changes way is going to
be spending more than 30 years of his
life in prison
the chinese government's stated reason
for persisting in its cruel punishment
of way
is that he is a criminal who is harmful
to society
but now with the publication of waze
prison writings any reader of normal
intelligence and conscience will be able
to stand back and ponder the question
who really are the criminals
[Applause]
[Music]
democracy wall in 1979. democracy wall
was the first open organized and
principled pro-democracy movement in
communist china
it helped to bring china's economic
reformers to power and influence later
political movements as well
i am honored that my fate has been
intertwined with that of way
we shared work at democracy wall
each of us listened to court verdicts in
which one item of evidence against us
was association with the other
and then we served parallel
parallel prison sentences
now i am in exile half a world away
while he remains
in a squalid prison but each of us still
does whatever he can to support the
efforts of the other
my experience with wei jinxiang has
allowed me to know him well others know
him for his incisive political thought
his sense of responsibility towards
society and history his unbending
courage in the face of long prison
sentences and all of this is important
to know but i also know a more personal
side a warm and direct sincerity
a simple clarity on questions of justice
and a reflexive sympathy for the weak
and the dispossessed
weijinshang is a major figure in china's
democracy movement and many people want
to and should
know more about this personal side
direct contact contact
remains impossible but the publication
of his prison letters
foreign
foreign
meaning to china's democracy movement
has been inseparable from the
persecution that he has suffered in 1979
his first heavy print prison sentence
resulted from his claim that deng
xiaoping's four modernizations were
doomed unless a fifth democracy were
added
but dung who relied on popular support
during his climb to power preferred to
rule as a dictator after reaching the
top
the results of dung's dictatorship
are plainly visible in today's china
where uncontrollable corruption in
government has led to outrage and deep
cynicism in the public
this picture vindicates wei jing chung's
early warning human rights and
democratic government are indeed
necessary for china's modernization
wei's second heavy prison sentence came
in 1995 when
after the chinese government had briefly
released him in an attempt to win the
right to host the olympic games
wei emerged from prison undaunted and
undiminished still speaking out for
democracy and human rights
to china's democrats who were just then
re-emerging after the shock of the 1989
massacres
wayswords brought new courage to china's
dictators they brought renewed fear
foreign
the effects of ways persecution have
rippled far beyond his particular case
after his first conviction in 1979 the
chinese government rounded up democracy
advocates throughout china sentenced
them in secret and sent them into prison
labor camps
after his second conviction in 1995
another large group of dissidents
including
one by one were picked up and sent to
prison or to labor camps
both of these repressions caused
as the first and most conspicuous victim
to be seen as a symbol for the whole
such an effect is moreover part of the
intention of the chinese government
whose aim in persecuting dissidents is
not just to curtail the activity of a
few people but to intimidate the broader
democracy movement that has struggled
along now for nearly 20 years despite
constant pressure intermedia
intermittent battering and even massacre
the persecution of
and other dissidents shows as clearly as
anything can that china lacks the
freedoms of thought speech and assembly
that are promised in the country's
constitution
foreign
the persecution of way and other
dissidents is also an index of the world
community's regard for human rights
way's second prison sentence in 1995
drew even less international protest
than did his first in nineteen seventy
nine
this weak response
is part of the conservative and
recumbent posture that the international
community has taken toward human rights
in recent times
some of the world's strongest
democracies have surrendered to the
chinese government's policy of moving
human rights out of the arena of action
and into mere dialogue
where the exchange of words is supposed
to soften chinese dictators on questions
of human rights
the actual result of this policy has
been that each side pronounces its own
words while the chinese government's
suppression of human rights continues
and the despicable treatment of shang
and other dissidents achieves a kind of
acceptance
physical disease has become chiang's
most recent adversary yet he is denied
even diagnostic medical care
foreign
hui foreign and other dissidents speak
for the rights and the dignity of all
chinese people to persecute these
dissidents is to repress the rights and
the dignity of all
before the international community
abandons its concern for human rights in
china it should remember that one in
every five people in the world is
chinese
if the rights of so many are not
important enough in themselves then we
should consider what it means for world
peace and security when the government
of such a large country shows brazen
disregard for values and standards that
the world generally shares
the international community and
especially america must not allow the
chinese government's bravado and its
threats about withholding purchase
orders
to lead to attenuation or even
abandonment of concern and support for
dissidents like
to do so is to give up on helping 1.2
billion people to build a faith in world
values and standards
we who have worked on weijinjung's book
fervently hope that it will revive the
world's respect sympathy and support for
way and other chinese dissidents and
will dispel the present mood of
indifference toward their painful
circumstances and fate
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you gentlemen
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you gentlemen
[Applause]
[Music]
i would now like to invite the mayor of
the city of new york to join us on the
podium mayor giuliani please
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you very much
i'm very proud to be here
today in support of
way jingjong's
unique courage and personal
commitment to freedom and democracy
new york city is
the most diverse
city in the world the most international
city in the world
in the city of new york we speak over
200 different languages or dialects of
languages
and every known
group of one kind or another from all
parts of the world is represented here
and i think this is a city that
understands diversity
probably more than most and prizes it
for nearly two decades the chinese
government has tried to silence mr way
for being one of the foremost champions
of democratic reform
all he's asking for
are things that we take for granted
political freedom economic freedom the
ability to express your opinions about
the things you feel strongly about and
the ability to have the kind of economic
freedom that every new yorker
for a long time has assumed is just an
ordinary part of a decent life
for that mr way has spent
most of his adult life in prisons and
labor camps
oftentimes enduring years of solitary
confinement
while being denied
the fundamentals of life food medical
attention
material to read or material with which
to write
these intolerable conditions would have
broken
most men or women
but mr way steadfast commitment to the
principles of freedom endures and that
unites us to him
his powerful message has a special
significance
to the people of a country america
which is built
at its best on the fundamental ideal
that freedom and democracy
are the ultimate for all of us the
ability to express ourselves the way we
want to practice our religion in the way
that we want to and to stand for the
political positions that we feel are the
best
throughout our history the very process
of public debate and often discourse
have shaped the direction of america
it hasn't always been a straight line
to democracy
but most of the times it has been in
america
and i believe that new york city has
been throughout the last 200 years at
the core of that it's the center of the
publishing industry
and the well from which many of the
ideas that have shaped america and the
world have ultimately come
diverse open and vibrant debate
is something that we prize in the city
of new york
because we not only permit ideas we
encourage them
under an impressive form of government
which is very very hard for new york is
even to imagine
opinions are stifled differences are
rendered suspect and the status quo is
maintained at any cost
under that kind of system the burden is
left
to the courageous few to speak for the
many
and oftentimes the courageous few
unfortunately have to sacrifice beyond
almost human comprehension
it's all of our responsibilities
to support mr way in his fight for
democracy
and in that respect mr way's book
the courage to stand alone should be
read by everyone both children and
adults
it tells us a lot about china but it
also tells us a lot about the
fundamentals of what we stand for also
as article 19 of the international
declaration of human rights reminds us
everyone has the right
to freedom of opinions and expression
this right includes freedom to hold
opinions without interference
and to seek and receive and import
information and ideas through any media
regardless of frontiers
whenever that right is cut off in any
part of the world
then that right is diminished for all of
us
mr way's crime
so-called crime has robbed him of his
adulthood
he's been called to answer by the
chinese leadership
because he is seeking for his people
what is fundamental for all of us and in
doing that we've been robbed of our
rights also
he speaks to the dignity of humans
and the freedoms of that information and
knowledge bring something that in this
building i think
probably we understand best
the power and the importance of
information and the ability to access it
and be able to consider it with a free
mind and a free will
we must stand shoulder to shoulder with
mr way
so that others will understand
the great courage that he has
to stand alone
and perhaps
that will inspire others to stand with
him the way you have
it's no longer enough that mr way be the
lone voice of dissent in beijing
if we don't stand up together
as you're doing today
we risk a culture of acceptance
pervading the public consciousness which
eventually will erode the democratic
principles that we all cherish
i want to congratulate
viking i want to congratulate all of you
that are here
and i want to offer the support and
the encouragement of the people of new
york city thank you very much
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you very much mr mayor
rose styron is a poet and a human rights
activist
her most recent work of poetry is called
by vineyard light and was published by
rizzoli in 1995 rose can you join us up
here and read some of ways letters thank
you
[Applause]
[Music]
i'm going to read something that's a
little lighter
and a little more personal it's from two
personal letters that way has written to
his
siblings
and i like these letters particularly
because they bring to life
his life in prison they're vivid and
quirky and full of small human concerns
just the way letters from
by political prisoners hovel mich
breitenbach and so many others are and
that's why we remember them
this is
1981.
dear ling ling tatau and shanshan hello
everyone i was very happy to receive
taotao's letter
since i don't have any books to read
i'll write to you for fun
besides it doesn't take too much of your
energy to read a letter and it helps me
to relieve some of my boredom
did you receive a letter i wrote on
november 1st
i can only mail out one a month
tau tau
you wrote the wrong character for a word
throughout your letter
maybe this has something to do with the
fact that you didn't go to middle school
you also miswrote the phrase just the
opposite and turned the length of a day
into the width of a day
these mistakes all break the rules of
common language usage you must take care
in the future to avoid showing your
ignorance in public
it's hard to avoid sometimes
but try not to do it too often
actually even the so-called writers who
fill the pages of the people's daily
display their ignorance quite frequently
just as they go on shaking their heads
and declaring that kids today just don't
have any culture
the strange thing is that as of yet no
one has called them arrogant
which can probably be explained by the
word old
in our country being old is a cover for
doing all matter of bad things
even some really despicable ones
taotao and his wife say i am arrogant
but i'm not convinced
people often call me arrogant but it's
usually just when they can't come up
with any better response to me
whether intentionally or not they always
seem to forget
one thing
i can talk to people from all walks of
life whether gentlemen and ladies of the
high level cadre stratum or old peasants
from so deep in the mountain valleys
that you can barely understand a word
they're saying
no one has ever had misgivings about
talking with me because of my arrogance
once in a while someone will admonish me
for being a bit pompous
but it's usually because what i'm saying
violates their common sense of things
this has helped me to understand why
illusion said
what a blessing it would be if there
were more people with such personal
arrogance
and what a disaster if there were more
people arrogant only in the conformity
of their patriotism
if a society or even one person is to
progress then one must abandon some of
what is considered common sense
and explore new things that have never
been understood before
in short one must pursue the strange and
unknown
for if a nation stifles the unknown by
relying only on the common sense of
being arrogant in the conformity of
patriotism
then it is destined to lag behind in
human progress
this rule applies to individuals as well
sometimes i think that the reason people
are wiser than monkeys has a lot to do
with the fact that they are more curious
and their force of habit is less
ingrained
monkeys for the same reason are wiser
than other animals and are categorized
as primates
the swan however who floats so proudly
along never dating to pay any attention
to others has such a strong sense of
habit that even if several of its flock
are killed in a place it will still go
back there
if such a strong sense of habit was not
outweighed by the swan's ability to
reproduce
then i'm afraid swans would have been
extinct long ago
thus the type of arrogance that is truly
intolerable is pride of habit and a
tenacious defense of common sense
without sensitive reaction to new things
just as tatau's teacher once said my
reactions are quick
and this further shows
that to call me arrogant is incorrect
one of the greatest strengths possessed
by all of the children in our family is
our ability to react quickly and
cleverly to things
we're good at adapting to new situations
and accepting all kinds of unfamiliar
things
please don't assume that the stubborn
arrogant impression i've given you is
caused by the four white walls enclosing
me so oppressively
i still feel that i'm quite an optimist
and could adapt easily to semi-tropical
beauty
or at least in my own imagination
and here he is writing the same three
siblings his brother and two sisters
four years later
dear lingling tatau and chanchan hello i
received your letter as well as the
books and tape recorder i'm very happy
but in my excessive happiness i regret
only that you didn't also mail along a
few cassettes
so that i could enjoy some music
there is no radio or television here and
it's been a long time since i've heard
any music
aside from the cry of the wind and the
cooing of the rabbits when they're in
heat
there aren't any other sounds to enjoy
if you send an english tape definitely
include the study material to go with it
i've never studied english before and i
don't have any textbooks or dictionaries
handy so i'll have to wait for you to
send me everything i need
send the plug and the microphone for
this tape recorder along as well and
another adapter
we have electricity in the evenings from
a generator at the reservoir here on the
farm
and before too long the prison will be
connected with the northwest electricity
network and the electricity here will be
stabilized i'll be able to listen to
music as well as study english and it
will be a lot cheaper than using
batteries but don't send along any
serious political music i'd prefer some
relaxing classical favorites like
schubert mozart or strauss
there are some good popular songs too
like the music from the movie heroic use
for example which are very beautiful
on the train here i heard some new
version of chinese folk songs and tunes
jazzed up with a modern flavor that were
also very good xiumin ying's series of
folk songs made a deep impression on me
clouds playing with the moon and a
chicken in one hand a duck in the other
are especially rich
even though she's broken with a
traditional way of singing and added a
western style twist
they're enjoyable to listen to i don't
know why but i like western classical
music all kinds of modern styles and
even folk songs and opera from all over
but i can't take that self-proclaimed
serious stuff
to categorize music as serious or not is
pure nonsense
in a society without standards of
quality art 2 will be misrepresented
this is why true art belongs to the
people
thanks
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you rose
robert bernstein
is a giant figure in the world of
publishing and in human rights and i
very much doubt that either this event
or the courage to stand alone would have
been possible without bob bernstein
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
let me just add to that that bob was the
chairman and president of random house
from 1966 to 1990 and has been the
chairman and founder of human rights
watch since the early 1970s and serves
also on human rights in china's board
he's also wei jinx agent and friend bob
can you step up please
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
before i begin i want to take this
opportunity to thank wendy wolfe who was
ways editor at viking
and paul slovak
[Applause]
paul slovak viking penguins vp of
publicity who both
[Applause]
who both understood from the very
beginning
what is at stake with the publishing of
this book
friends
we are here today
excuse me
ostensibly to mark the publication of a
book
i've been a publisher since 1946
and have been to many such events
but this is the first one i've been to
in over 50 years that is not a
celebration
before my own remarks which are short i
would like to read you a letter that
i've just received
it's not from way who is no longer
permitted to write or receive letters
it's from another author
botslap havel
may 9th
dear friends
i am sorry to be unable to attend the
gathering where you will present the
letters from prison by wei jing shan
a chinese human rights champion who
spent years in prison before and is now
serving under harsh conditions another
long prison sentence for his political
beliefs
i have spoken out in defense of waging
xiang a number of times already
believing that his courage deserves
recognition i nominated him for the
nobel prize
the chinese and more generally the asian
civilization
the environment that forms the
background of wei jishang's fate
is one of the roots an inseparable
components of the global civilization
i have a profound esteem for the legacy
of asia's culture philosophy and thought
that remains a source of inspiration for
the world today
these ancient traditions are however
distorted in certain asian countries
through the application of totalitarian
practices
and the distorted version
is then presented as a specific quality
of the asian circumstance
many countries in asia as well as on
other continents share a commitment to
individual human rights and to the
advancement of democracy
the stand taken by these nations
and the struggle of people-like way
for the human rights cause demonstrate
that human freedom cannot be divided by
national frontiers or unacceptable
interpretations of local traditions or
conditions
when i express my solidarity
with those who engage in non-violent
action on behalf of human dignity and
democracy anywhere in the world
and face persecution because of their
love for freedom with people like wei
jing shang whose letters from prison are
now presented to the world public
i do not encroach
upon a no trespassing zone
regarding internal affairs
i simply do my dodie duty
sincerely yours botslop hobble
[Music]
we are here today to do our duty we're
here today because the author of this
extraordinary book is of course in
prison
we're here to make sure that by the
actions and reactions of everyone in
this room and everyone who hears our
words and ways
the publication of waves pigeon letters
will secure his freedom before the
conditions of his imprisonment succeed
in silencing him for good
i met wei in beijing on january 29 1944
during the brief six month period over
the last 18 years that he was not behind
bars
despite profound medical problems for
which he was taking 12 different
medicines he was joyful and upbeat
attacking the future with the same
energy and enthusiasm and optimism you
read in his letters today
he wanted to talk about the book he
planned to write
about his ideas for the future of china
i had to prod him to talk about the last
14 and a half years spent mostly in
solitary
in a whole day of talk he spoke only a
few sentences about his suffering
always remember he said the chinese can
torture you without laying a hand on you
the litany of his life-threatening
diseases is long and horrifying
his family in china told us in their
most recent messages about two months
ago
that he was dejected and in low spirits
a problem with his spine makes it
impossible for him to raise his head
and he's had no medical examination
since february 1996
these letters you read therefore may be
his last
john shattuck who's here with us tonight
knows all too well
how complicated the relationship between
washington and beijing is
but what i ask for now is not
complicated it's very very simple
president clinton must delay any summit
meeting with chinese president yang zee
min until way is released from prison
and allowed to express himself safely
[Applause]
and we in this room need to utilize all
our collective resources
to make it clear to james e min and bill
clinton that that's what we want
we're sitting in one of the most
important buildings in our country a
library
where written ideas are carefully stored
and freely available to all
i thank paul leclair and the library
board for making this space
with its awesome power available
take a moment as we sit here to think
about where way is sitting
a man who suffers in isolation is being
given a voice today a book
that book will be available forever here
in a free library
a library incidentally that the chinese
refused to enter last fall for a meeting
with president clinton because a hand
bill from tiananmen square was on
display
as part of an exhibition on freedom of
expression
let us work to see that this book the
courage to stand alone
will cry out and help to save waging
shang's voice and of course his life
and that this gathering marks another
step in the battle to permit millions of
chinese to speak freely thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you bob
the following short film waging sheng a
voice for chinese democracy is based on
an interview carried out by trudy styler
for her documentary moving the mountain
it was directed by michael aptid it was
shot in beijing in 1993 not long after
waze release
and just three months before his
re-arrest
the interview took place in extremely
difficult circumstances way was under
constant surveillance the interview
footage was graciously provided this
evening by trudy styler
and the film was edited by joe caltrera
of picture business and co-produced by
christina torgesen
the translator of ways book
they asked me if i had any conditions
my only condition was that they not send
me overseas
overseas and i'd rather stay in prison
because i've always felt
china's problems
[Music]
when i first joined the regard it was
earliest regard
people were very naive listen quite a
jubilee
quickly led them in his own direction
he incorporated them into his own power
struggle
very hard for everyone
so we began searching for the reasons
why
we started reading casually
the risk questions
about mao zedong and democracy
but it had already started
[Music]
afterwards i went to the countryside i
stayed there for two years
that was when i saw the true
consequences of the party's agricultural
policy
what i learned there increased my
understanding of the problems
you heard others talking about how
brutal life was there but it was always
second hand
only when you saw it with your own eyes
did you realize that many people had
starved to death during the hardships of
the
[Music]
1960s but it greatly advanced my
understanding of the true nature of the
communist system
my thinking underwent a fundamental
transformation
i stopped believing in marxism
altogether
[Music]
was very difficult
everyone in my unit was from the
countryside
being together with them
i really came to understand chinese
society better
during the cultural revolution people's
illusions about the communist party were
destroyed
[Music]
it taught everyone a lesson
the party
including muslim himself said one thing
but its actions was something else
entirely
[Music]
ten years after the cultural revolution
ended
the democracy war movement began
no other method can do something
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the democracy war movement took place at
the universities as well when democracy
war was suppressed
it retreated back into the campuses
and spread throughout the country not
just in beijing
it was all over the country
when i was first captured i was alone
i knew that other political dissidents
were going through the same thing
the way they treated the political
prisoners were the worst
people it was even worse
than ordinary criminals
they wouldn't let you go outside for the
whole year
they just kept you inside of the
documents
but they didn't check your condition
they didn't give you any treatment
in reality it was more difficult to
endure than torture
[Music]
there is a saying in chinese climb to
the seas and they will bloom
[Music]
i was extremely worried
the communist party
[Music]
i'm so unclear i was afraid they might
open fire on students
i guess very
[Music]
so i wrote letters to the country's
leaders reminding them not to do
anything foolish
what effect did it have
none at all
darn it yeah of course they wouldn't
show them opening fire on tv but i guess
they had
when they broadcasted no shots had been
fired it was like admitting they had
been
when they said not a single person had
died it meant that many people had died
not just one or two
[Music]
chinese people are not beasts of burden
they're just like other people
they want democracy they want human
rights they also want to live freely
[Music]
most importantly the 1989 movement was
an expression of democracy
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
the pressure from the communist party
had been so great
that many people were afraid to speak
out publicly
when the truth was expressed
everyone really woke up
they realized that there were many
others who thought just like them
sacrifices have a price
they have to be worth it
in 1979 it was worth it
even if they had executed me it would
still have been worth it
in the future i would do the same
[Music]
no
i don't have any requests at all
if you had even the slightest regret you
wouldn't be able to hold on to your
ideas
it will be very difficult to hold on for
14 years
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
john shattuck is assistant secretary of
state for democracy human rights and
labor
and formerly executive director of the
american civil liberties union and vice
president of harvard university mr
shattuck has won a number of awards for
his contributions to civil liberties
and human rights
mr shattuck was also i believe the last
person or among the last people to see
weigh a free man john can you come up
here please
[Music]
[Music]
well i'm deeply honored to
[Music]
have the opportunity to speak to you
after the
voice of wei jing chang
whose voice
almost sounded as if it was across the
table which is one way in which i heard
that voice
secretary albright has asked me to
convey to you a special message
about the importance
of both this event but much more
importantly the man
on whose behalf we are all standing in
here tonight
she wants you to know and i quote
i paid tribute
to the courage and tenacity
demonstrated by weijing chung
at enormous personal cost
in support of the principles of the
universal declaration of human rights
many
support
these principles
few have paid a greater price for their
support than wei zhing chang
weijing has written with eloquence
about the central importance to our time
not only in china but all over the world
of the ongoing struggle for democracy in
human rights
it's a struggle with many victories
it's a struggle with many defeats
but it's a struggle that will go on
until it is won
he wrote the people should have
democracy when they call for democracy
they are demanding nothing more
than that which is inherently
theirs
with those words in 1979
weijinsu was then an electrician at the
beijing zoo
stunned china's leadership and
electrified
china's intellectuals
the clarity the simplicity
the moral force and the personal courage
of his message
resonates upon the world's conscience
two decades later
it is true that much has changed in
china since wei began writing and
speaking about democracy and human
rights
china's economy has undergone enormous
change
and many of its citizens enjoy a higher
standard of living
undeniably
many also enjoy a higher degree of new
personal freedom
chinese today are making choices about
employment
place of residence and the education of
their children that were simply not
available to them two decades ago
but
and this is why we are all here tonight
it is equally undeniable
that other essential and even more
fundamental changes have not taken place
in 1997 all public dissent against the
party and the government of china
is effectively silenced by intimidation
exile
the imposition of prison terms
administrative detention
and house arrest
as the state department stated in our
most recent human rights report today
quote no dissidents are active in china
close quote
the stirring words of weijing xiang
about democracy and human rights
19 years after they are were first
spoken
are still grounds for arrest and
incarceration
and for way these stirring words are the
only reason
why he is still in prison
those who share ways deep love for china
but who disagree with those in power
still do not have the freedom to speak
their minds or publish their views
this is true despite the passage of
legislation designed to rationalize
china's legal system and provide
transparency and accountability
despite a new prison law a lawyer's law
amendments to the criminal procedure law
and the criminal law
chinese law is as way has said still too
often a legal weapon
that anyone in power can wield against
his enemies
china's legal reform effort is welcome
new laws hold promise that the treatment
of ordinary chinese and the legal system
will improve substantially and
systematically
and systematically
while the current reforms are an
important step forward they are deeply
flawed by loopholes that make it
possible for chinese leaders to deny
fundamental due process to anyone
charged with political crimes
for those who dare to speak their mind
and dissent
there is no rule of law
but only rule by law
for those who dissent law is a sword to
cut them down
not a shield to protect them
the rule of law has emerged as a touch
tone touchstone in our discussions with
the chinese government
as china assumes an increasingly
prominent role on the world stage
it is vitally important that its legal
development move a pace with its
economic development
the rule of law will ultimately redown
to the benefit of all the people of
china conversely
a law that does not protect all equally
and does not apply to all equally is a
law only in name and is a mask for
injustice and arbitrary rule
this is the central
fact
in way's book and one that he makes so
powerfully over and over again
and it bears repeating here
again and again
a chinese dissident who recently came to
washington expressed a desire to see the
watergate
passing out up an opportunity to
take in some of washington's more
traditional tourist sites
asked by a somewhat perplexed host
why watergate
it certainly wasn't for the architecture
he expressed amazement
that a president of the united states
could ever have obeyed the order of an
independent judiciary
and he told his host that watergate
symbolized what was most important about
america
the rule of law
the principle that no
man woman no citizen
and above all no leader is above the law
like andrei sakharov
weijinshang combines his precision of
language and commitment with his moral
passion and deep humility
as you know i was privileged to meet
with him
at his request in 1994
and i can personally attest
that he is one of those rare individuals
whose vision and bravery
show all those who work for human rights
what it is
that ultimately
we are all working for
the united states government will
continue in the months ahead
multilaterally bilaterally and in a
variety of programs to keep faith with
wei and will all the men women and
children of china whose human dignity
compels respect for their basic human
rights and for democracy
which is as wei himself has said
nothing more than that which is
inherently theirs
we will continue to press the chinese
government for weijing chung's release
from prison
as we have done repeatedly in recent
months
and at the highest levels of our
government and china's government
we will press for the release of all
those incarcerated for peaceful
expression of their political social and
religious beliefs
we will stress the importance of and
look for new ways to promote the rule of
law in china
this emerging global power
and in doing so we will keep faith with
way
and pay homage to his indomitable spirit
and his courage to speak out
and to stand alone
by standing alone
he has taught us the most important
lesson
he's taught us all why we must now now
stand with him and stand fast
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you very much john
don delillo is the author of 10 novels
his 11th underworld will be published
this fall
he's a national book award and penn
faulkner award winner and a member of
the american academy of arts and letters
mr dilillo
[Music]
last month there was a man
in a cage in soho
a performance artist russian
impersonating a dog
he patted about on hands and knees
naked except for a thick collar
and he growled occasionally took water
from a bowl
and sniffed at his rubber lamb chop
it's possible that you've never really
thought about dogs until you've seen a
man seriously engaged in believing he's
a dog
the cage had a small barred slot where
visitors to the gallery could get down
on all fours
as a number of people were inclined to
do
in order to talk to the dog
or whimper as some did
or show the dog snapshots of their own
dogs speaking to him slowly and clearly
either because he was a foreigner
or because he was a dog
in kafka's story a hunger artist
a man lives in a small cage for 40 days
and nights without eating
people pay admission to watch him starve
to gawk at his bony arms and bare grips
the man has a manager and the manager
has placed a 40-day limit
on the hunger artist performance
not because the artist may die of
starvation after this time
but because the manager has calculated
that his figure represents the far edge
of the public's fickle interest
in china
a writer lives in a small enclosure a
barge room perhaps
or a dark hole with a slot for food we
can imagine that the writer has made and
shaped his own fate
he has a name
waging
and a history outside the charges and
documents assembled by the state
and maybe he has an art outside the
strict limits of the written word
in this sense
his high blood pressure and arthritis
and depression
his dizzy spells and rotting gums
may be seen a strong
symptoms
of the artist's enduring effort to
realize his role
a writer in opposition to the state
in the culture
ours
that tries to absorb and neutralize
every threat to consumer consciousness
the sight of a man living as a dog
offers a sense of the splendid latitudes
of free expression
and places a small incisive shock
in the midst of all those soho apparel
shops and restaurants
but it also suggests the grim idea that
the performance artist
liberated from soviet state control
hair cropped and clothing discarded
may be carrying his own culture's primal
wish
for order
and repression
the chinese writer's art is to be still
not silent but still
the writer's classic condition
to be alone in a room
has been cruelly extended here
way is a still figure
working out his fate in a confined space
refusing to eat at times
living for long periods on a teaspoon of
sugar a day
and whirling around this stillness there
is something continuous and ponderous
and vast
the perennial frenzy of the state
a real dog entered the gallery
a boxer
well trained
and the performance artist began to bark
he developed a strong sharp bark
edged with warning
when an art critic entered his cage
in sweden
the performance artist bit him
the total state wants to drain all
conviction from the writer
it wants to absorb the dissident writer
in the west every writer is absorbed
turned into breakfast food or canned
laughter
but the more total the state
the more vivid the dissident artist
the artist is so vivid and singular so
unassimilated into the state machine
that the state must find a way to make
him disappear
in fact the hunger artist in kafka
believes he can fast for more than 40
days
he has taken his art to extreme limits
it is the tragedy of his life that he
isn't allowed to stay hungry
that he is forced to come out of his
cage and eat
in a public ceremony
with band music and attending physicians
the chinese writer is treated by police
doctors
his cell is so cold that frost forms on
the door
he suffers chest pains and can't sleep
the doctors address his symptoms in a
traditional manner
by deciding they are faked
the writer stops eating again
a hunger strike is a free act undictated
by the authorities and way starves
himself to protest local conditions of
course
and to grow ever more still as well
the still fixed center of that whirling
frenzy
when the hunger artist dies
they decide to put an animal in his cage
a strong young creature equipped with
sharp pointed teeth
that can rip meat clean off a bone
people come to watch the animal eat an
audience in far greater numbers than the
hunger artist could ever command
the deeper they can seal him the more
remote the cell the smaller the cell
the colder and stonier the walls of the
cell
the more vivid and living is the writer
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Applause]
thank you don
david henry huang is a playwright
screenwriter and librettist his plays
include the tony award-winning m
butterfly the dance and the railroad and
fob
david will read from the letters of way
[Music]
i've chosen to read from a letter dated
june 15 1991
addressed to dear chiang zaming and li
peng
human rights have become a popular topic
of conversation lately and even the
party line on the issue seems to have
softened somewhat
it is declared that it intends to study
human rights
theories and questions in order to deal
with the peaceful evolution of hostile
forces and so on these very words prove
that the basic theories of the communist
party as they currently exist do not
cover the issue of human rights and the
people are no more than tools for
production and struggle within its
theoretical framework
tools naturally do not have any rights
all they have is the right to be
submissive and to be used
when peaceful evolution of hostile
forces comes into the picture and the
tools are no longer as docile and useful
then it becomes necessary to find out
what to do to make them docile once
again
at least this is the stand and attitude
revealed in your party's newspaper
as for the many proclamations you have
made during international diplomatic
occasions based on experience and your
party's own views they cannot be taken
at face value
you may consider my views to be the
futile and worthless thoughts of a
heretic
after all i am a former tool whom you
now regard as no longer docile and a
leading distance who has been falsely
branded as part of the human rights
vanguard
but i have never been incited or
instigated by quote human rights
diplomacy employed by hostile countries
or hostile forces unquote and have not
been influenced by theories of modern
human rights in the west
the only information on human rights
that i have access to comes from your
party's own publications
one thing i do know for sure however is
that your party unyieldingly holds the
same view of human rights that the nazis
did which helps to explain why you gnash
your teeth at the mere mention of human
rights and are so eager to get rid of
them
the tibet problem since the founding of
the people's republic for example did
not stem from the quote ambitions of
imperialist forces unquote and human
rights diplomacy
it is true that serious human rights
problems and even racial discrimination
have occurred in that region during the
past 40 years an imperialist aggression
did indeed take place several decades
ago but this all happened before human
rights diplomacy came onto the scene
the imperialists had left india long
before and besides what ambitions would
they have for tibet a region which they
never even colonized in the first place
the root causes of the problems in tibet
are all internal and lie particularly in
the theories and practices of your party
do not call the crow black when you
yourself are blacker neither the
existence of south african racists nor
the klu klux klan nor feudal serfdom in
old tibet gives you the right to ignore
human rights or proves that you have a
good human rights record
but what is the use of saying all this
nonsense anyway let us take a serious
look at human rights theories and
practices how they stand in relation to
socialism and in particular why marxist
societies often turn out to be political
structures that do not respect human
rights
these questions are matters of primary
importance for modern china
they may seem very far removed from us
but actually they are very close to whom
they might appear as merely abstract
concepts but they are in fact very
concrete
the lack of human rights is the
principal cause for many of the concrete
problems confronting chinese society
[Music]
david thank you
betty baulord's books include spring
moon legacies and the middle heart she
also covered the 1989 pro-democracy
demonstrations on tiananmen square for
cbs betty
[Applause]
[Music]
balor the courage to stand alone recalls
a true story from my days in china
i knew of a man who smoked four or five
packs of cigarettes
ever since his rehabilitation
but to no avail had his wife
his mother his doctors pleaded with him
to stop smoking
then one day he received a letter from
his son begging him to do so
immediately he stubbed out his cigarette
vowing it would be his last
he explained
like other men
i fathered a son
unlike other sons
mine returned to me
the gift of life
not just once
but faithfully
every day
anything my son asks i must grant
the son
had been barely seven years old when the
father was suddenly imprisoned in his
own office
there for years and years and years the
man remained alone
not knowing why he was a prisoner when
whether he would ever be freed what was
happening in the world what had happened
to all those he cherished
many a long night the prisoner pondered
ending it all
only one certainty stopped him
every day at dawn
summer winter spring and fall
he could peer through a crack in the
boarded up window
and see
a snippet of color
a tiny vermilion kite
in the sky
sometimes it hovered at eye level
sometimes it soared into the heavens
sometimes
it was barely visible
the familiar sight never failed
to inspire hope
for the prisoner knew
that someone was sending him a message
someone on the outside
waited faithfully
someone cared
and so the father held on to life
as tightly as he had once taught his
small son
to hold onto the tether of his
kite waging sun flies the vermillion
kite of hope
hope for china where every chinese
enjoys respect
and dignity
hope for a world
where everyone
embraces
everyone's uniqueness
and our common
humanity
[Music]
thank you betty
a programming note because of time
constraints uh we have had to shorten uh
the remainder of the speakers we will
include everyone but they have all
promised to keep their remarks to as
close to a minute as they can manage
so don't despair
george black is research and editorial
director of the lawyers committee for
human rights he's also co-author of the
book black hands of beijing lives of
defiance in china's democracy movement
george
[Music]
[Applause]
i'll take my instructions at their word
and be very brief i'm going to read a
very short extract from a letter one of
the many that wei jing shang has
addressed over the years to deng
xiaoping
he seemed to be caught in a kind of
mutual antagonism i think it was mutual
i think both men were equally obsessed
with each other this is a letter
talking about his own family and talking
about dung's family and then talking
about the metaphorical family of china
as dung's larger family
dear don xiao ping
i've written to you so many times now
that i'm probably beginning to get on
your nerves and you're wondering why
can't this guy just sit in prison
quietly
this appears to be a real problem
but it's not entirely my fault
i'm very capable of staying quiet but if
people don't allow me to be then i can
also be very unquiet
this makes me no different from most
people in our country
when we're living in times of relative
peace and tranquility we're the quietest
people on earth
but if we are oppressed beyond reason
then as the history books show we can be
the most unquiet
and the most imbued with revolutionary
zeal of all peoples
my endless letters and my constant
badgering are in the tradition of when
officials oppress the people rebel
it's time to make a fresh start your
family's internal and external affairs
are facing all kinds of problems and
they're all due to your old-style
patriarchal manner you ask of other
things that you refuse to do yourself
you prohibit others from interfering in
your internal affairs but you persist in
having the absolute authority to
interfere in the affairs of the ordinary
people in other words you meddle in
their human rights i don't think for a
moment contemporary society will accept
such behavior quietly
furthermore when people censor denounce
or advise you or even curtail their
relations with you they are doing so out
of concern for your family they've yet
to resort to legal or more forceful
means to do so
what personal internal affairs of yours
are they actually interfering in
i wish you good health
i hope that you will go on living so
that one day we can finally meet
up until now i haven't had the chance to
greet my dear old friend and have a
heart-to-heart chat with him
please don't disappoint me
an old person like yourself should
really take an early retirement and let
the younger generation look after things
look after yourself waiting shun
[Music]
thank you george
william f schultz has been executive
director of amnesty international usa
since march of 1994
an ordained unitarian universalist
minister he came to amnesty after
serving for eight years as president of
the unitarian universalist association
of congregations bill
[Applause]
[Music]
why did the lord agree to save sodom for
the sake of ten righteous men
surely ten is not enough
surely any city ought to be able to
produce more than ten
but what is so special about ten why not
nine or five or two or even one it may
be very difficult to find even one
righteous man as difficult as the old
chinese saying you can stand on a
hillside with your mouth wide open for a
long time
before a roast duck flies in
but be it ten or only one there is a
sense
in which it takes only a handful of
righteous people to redeem a community
or a generation and that is this if even
one person
if even one rises above the
predilections of the time
then it is possible for anyone to do so
only five years after jefferson had
defended slavery
garrison railed against it
while heidegger pimped for the nazis
bonhoeffer went to prison
and while weijing shang wrote his
letters deng xiaoping slaughtered
children neither the temper of their
times nor the context for their
activities can excuse jefferson
heidegger or dung in the face of the
existence of garrison bonhoeffer and way
god asked for ten righteous men for he
knew that even a handful of those who
cry shame in the face of perfidy or find
beauty in a trail of dust can save a
city or a people
but a prophet without an audience
can be mistaken for a maniac
and so the publication of ways letters
rescues him from the calumny of madness
but it also offers the rest of us in
sodom no further excuses for our opacity
and here i do not mean the chinese
i mean every american who trades in
blood
or sleeps through anguish
i
[Applause]
[Music]
i mean every western official
who marks time
while beijing sings
many centuries ago a chinese philosopher
described the ideal state this way
it will be a place he wrote in which
children are free to play games
the middle aged to grumble at taxes
and old people
to find fault with everything
today we call this democracy
it is not waging shane
who is out of step with his heritage
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you william schultz
el doctoro's novels include ragtime
the waterworks
billy bathgate and world's fair
he has won the national book critics
award twice and the national book award
and pen and pen faulkner award for
fiction edgar
[Applause]
[Music]
in my opinion what hope we behave for
way comes not from any expectation
of pressure on the part of this
administration
his way himself has pointed out
is it really likely that americans would
abandon an opportunity to make money
just to protect the human rights of
those they've befriended
is it really likely he asked that the
american people's determination
of right and wrong could ever influence
the judgment of the us government
and quote
now our hope for wage in china arises
only from our contemplation of the lives
of
nelson mandela and however
and
other among other notables in this
century who've
projected from the hideous prison
ordeals of their lives the substantive
ideals of the freedom
from which their compatriots could
compose a sense of themselves
way is sanctified by such precedence as
crime
isn't having insisted on some breathing
room for his people with the passage of
each new day
of his isolation and his torture the
vision of a democratic society
operating under true rule of law
revolves resolves with greater and
greater clarity in the minds of china's
young
it's inevitable even if they don't know
who he is or what is happening to him
because
such moral force is only broadcast and
magnified
by the silencing of his voice
and his confinement in a cell that is
modeled on the idea of a coffin
there are challenges to an occasion such
as this
are we wrong
to claim this man as a great chinese
patriot
do we make claims for wagin chung that
our unwarranted interference in the
internal affairs of china a country we
don't understand and cannot appreciate
you must categorically reject that
argument
in the past half century the idea of
human rights has been conceptualized
transnationally
is an idea with a currency among all
nations
not only those practicing
one form or another of democracy
is an idea of necessarily universal
application
that is beyond erasure it's fixed
eternal
and unalterable development in human
consciousness
therefore the imprisonment and torture
of a man for having opinions and
expressing them the punishment of such a
man for such an activity
anywhere in the world
is a planetary crime
it is no less tolerable to us if it's
our if it's our neighbor or a man or
woman across the world it means this
idea of the essential
universal human right that if a chinese
government that claims authority over a
billion people
cannot endure the speech and criticism
of one man
then it can have no real legitimacy
it means that if the chinese authorities
cannot afford to let one citizen speak
up and test his ideas against their own
then whatever their party affiliation or
ideology they have no moral basis
for rule
now we can be easily mocked
on this occasion there surely being no
country including our own that does not
undermine the concept of human rights
chinese leaders are quick to point out
our own insufficiencies
they are contemptuous of our moralizing
on the one hand
and are going for the money on the other
i propose therefore as a private person
to exempt myself
from such hypocrisies as i've
participated in
the only way i can
lately there have been some there's been
some literary commerce between the
united states and chinese writers and
chinese publishers
a few of my books have been published
were being published
uh in china some without benefit of
contract more recently under the
conventions of international copyright
i'm under no illusion that the gesture
i'm proposing is anything more than that
it will hardly have the impact save the
private the chinese government of its
most favored nation status as a trading
partner
but until wei jinxiang is released in
some decency comes
to ameliorate the general outrage of
tiananmen square
if given the opportunity i will deny
any chinese publisher
rights to my work in china
i respectfully ask my colleagues here
today and in fact
the entire american literary community
to
consider the same admittedly gesture of
recourse
it's no more than a private thing really
of no great consequence
in chinese american relations but we may
have the satisfaction at least that we
have done more
than the american government or the
major american corporations to express
our solidarity
with waging shang thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you edgar doctorow
liu binyan was a prominent writer
dissident and journalist in china who
has been prosec persecuted
for many years
for his criticism of the communist party
he came to the united states in 1988 and
is currently editor of the magazine
china focus liu
[Music]
solitude
usually accompanies the pioneers
but within chance of solitude exceeds
that of the others
the chinese communist regime has
successfully placed him in absolute
isolation
as his verdict was decided by the
parliament leader then shopping any
dissemination of true information
about him is strictly taboo
many chinese were told that he is a
criminal
even vast majority of the students
participants participated in the
entertainment democracy movement
in 1989 had not heard
about waiting
but
ironically
it is precisely the policy of the
chinese communist regime that made wei
jinxian walk out of solitude
in 1979 when wijin cheng first lost his
freedom
not many workers would think that ways
arrest
had anything to do with their interests
yet today
the more than half of the workers
instead own factories lost their job
or are not paid their regular salary
or pension
they finally realized
that without democracy their livelihood
are already injured party
they began to seek for answers to the
numerous wives in the house in their
minds and became the most zealous
listeners of
in foreign language
yesterday
the radio free asia had already
broadcasted
the news about the publication with
rejections book and today's event
i'm sure
the thousands of listeners of radio free
asia
and likewise the listeners are voice of
american the bbc and the french
international broadcasting we learned
the truth about
through the news of the publication
of this book
therefore
i want to thank the viking penguin and
all those who have made the publication
of this book possible thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
andrew nathan is professor of political
science at columbia university and
chairman of the advisory committee of
human rights watch asia he's the author
of chinese democracy china's crisis and
with robert s ross the great wall and
the empty city
china search for security
he also wrote the forward to the courage
to stand alone andy where are you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
after we wrote his letters
he came out of prison and that's when
this wonderful photograph was taken you
can see a man who
cares about his own mind
he had about six months of freedom and
then he disappeared
the chinese government
denied knowing anything about his
whereabouts but then after about 20
months they
found him and put him on trial
they charged him with publishing some of
these prison letters
in hong kong with meeting foreigners
like bob bernstein
with putting money in the bank
with helping other dissidents
and with planning an art exhibition
and put him on trial and i'd like to
read to you the last
couple of paragraphs of his defense you
can imagine
the conditions under which he composed
these paragraphs
if the government that makes these
accusations is one that respects human
rights and defends democracy
then demands that it further promote
human rights and democracy
and criticisms of existing evils can
only help to further consolidate and
perfect that government
instead of subverting it
since the nature of such a government is
in harmony with the movement for human
rights and democracy
the interactions between the two would
produce
the same or similar effects
none would subvert the other
a government that can be subverted by a
movement of human rights and democracy
can only be a government
that does not respect human rights or
promote democracy a government of feudal
fascist dictatorship
i don't think the prosecutor who's
bringing this suit
is representing such a government
because according to our constitution
and laws the people are the owner of
this nation and the government is merely
an agent of the people
the government must respect the
sovereignty of the people
the individual freedoms and political
rights of each citizen including the
right of the people to know the right to
criticize and supervise the government
even to replace the government
if the government abolishes or
suppresses such democratic rights then
it becomes an illegal government and
loses its legitimacy which is based on
the chinese constitution
therefore if the charges brought by the
indictment against the human rights and
democracy movement are valid then the
government it represents is not a legal
chinese government and the charges it
brings are illegal
whatever the nature of the government
that brings the charges
actions to promote human rights and
democracy and to expose and fight
against the enemies of democracy and
human rights do not constitute a crime
and certainly do not constitute the
crime of conspiracy to subvert the
government
now i'd like to introduce the last
speaker xiao qiang
who's the
executive director of human rights in
china he
interrupted a
very promising career as a scientist
after
june 1989 to take on an extremely
arduous
task
as the leader of that
organization which in a sense is
the major organization that has brought
us together today
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
thank you for everyone to be here
tonight
i truly
wish
we jinxing
is here with us
we are here
for a book his book called courage to
stand alone but also we're here to tell
the world we do is not alone we are all
with him
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we share his suffering we fight for his
freedom
it's actually we're fighting for our own
freedom
let me anchor wai jing chung
within a few sentences
o wei jing chung was in prison for and
he symbolized is this message
that chinese people deserve human rights
we want human rights we demand human
rights
[Applause]
[Music]
waiting also pointed out 20 years ago
it's continued to be true that china
need
democracy and human rights
these
values are not some luxuries for chinese
people it's a necessity for today's
china's development
and also
we share with sweden to the vision
that human rights and democracy
is china's only future
they don't come out automatically they
don't come out without price
but it's people like waiting
like everyone
in this world in their own country
fighting for it we pay our price but we
are fighting for this vision
this vision
that one day
everyone in china men and women can
speak up speak out their mind in private
and in public place without fear
this vision
that in china each citizen can be equal
in front of impartial law which written
as human rights is an underlying
principle and every chinese can
participate in those decisions which
affect their own lives
it's for china but it's also for the
world that we live that all people can
live with dignity thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen
ladies and gentlemen you have been a
wonderful supportive patient audience
and in closing let me just remind all of
ways friends that his is not a hopeless
cause when public consensus pushed the
white house and congress to act
vigorously early in the clinton
administration beijing freed a great
number of political prisoners including
wei himself
this evening should end our indifference
and washington's irresolution
waze country may be strong but as long
as way is a prisoner china cannot call
itself free
thank you all for your enormous
contribution
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
now a look at a visit by the c-span
school bus to the home of william
faulkner
thousand resources at your fingertips
just visit
cspan.org your online resource for
[Music]
politics now american perspectives
continues with a tribute to the reverend
william sloan coffin the civil rights
activist turned 75 in may the group
protestants for the common good
organized a dinner in his honor in
chicago
speakers include andrew young and
playwright arthur miller
reverend coffin wraps up this one hour
40-minute event with remarks
[Laughter]
what a wonderful evening this is studs
turkle said a few minutes ago that every
liberal worth a damn in chicago is here
tonight
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
and arnita boswell who gave our welcome
asked me to say a word that she had
intended to say
but her introduction was so
eloquent i can't believe she left
anything out
but she said as she looked around the
room we should remind ourselves tonight
how far we have come and we have
[Music]
and i want to say a word of special
recognition
because this is a birthday celebration
and it's a celebration in so many ways
as people who have not seen each other
for decades have come together tonight
but it's a special family time for the
coffin family and three tables of the
coffins are here let's recognize the
coffin we all stand up
let's say the coffin family
those pictures on your table we have
reproduced which
are
pictures of milestones in bill's life
and a part of
the wonderful celebration that we make
tonight
you can take those pictures home
you can work out the system at your
table
tell you i really hate to give these
away
if you want to pay something for them
we'll be glad to take the money
the pictures of bill and dr king you
cannot take those are copyrighted
but all the others you can take
and
figure out the oldest or the youngest or
the one who has come the farthest or the
most beautiful person or whatever at
your table and uh
but since i'm a methodist we cannot
raffle those off
something about civil disobedience uh
right
we are
as an organization protestants for the
common good
so incredibly blessed
and you have learned from your program
book and from
many other sources tonight what we are
about
and we are a very blessed organization
in having as our executive director
alexander sharp
al came to us after serving as
vice president of the university of
chicago and giving up a
magnificent career to go back to the
university of chicago divinity school to
earn a masters of divinity
and then he came to work for us as the
executive director and he is absolutely
tireless
innovative he is a man of great great
courage and skill and it is my pleasure
to present to you
the
executive director of protestants for
the common good and a student of bill
coffins at yale university alexander
sharpe
[Music]
well i only have one problem as
executive director
what in heaven's name are we going to do
for an encorp
and i think the answer is there is no
encore to bill coffin
we're so delighted to have us all here
tonight and the spirit is just uh
extraordinary and one of the remarkable
moments in uh putting this uh event
together this tribute to bill together
was about three weeks ago when he got
the invitation which we're proud of and
he said al he called he said al the
invitation is terrific he said this
whole thing may come off well bill what
do you think we were doing in january
february march uh april but it has come
off and it's uh uh of course uh due to
uh the person that we honor we did feel
that we were faced a little bit at the
beginning with a planning dilemma i mean
here's protestants for the common good
we're in chicago gene's put us
throughout the midwest but in fact we're
really in chicago and we're an illinois
based organization and here's bill
coffin who's a
national figure an international figure
and the question of course as we worked
on this was how was all of this going to
come together and again the answer is in
the person of bill coffin which is why
we're all here tonight
and all of you have said it in so many
ways but i really want to say again
how wonderful it was to put this
occasion together because of the
outpouring of gratitude for the fact
that it's happening i uh i had a nice
moment in the fall and marion wright
edelman had a terrific moment when she
was given the reinhold niebuhr award at
elmhurst college
and i was out there and used the chance
as opportunistic executive directors do
to hawk our event six months later
didn't get too much chance to talk to
marian but we did talk very briefly and
with a look in her face that i haven't
seen
very often on anybody's face she said
thank you for doing this and that is
universally what people feel here
tonight
[Music]
now you you so many of you gotten to
know mary shasma uh our terrific
executive director of protestants for
the common good mary's walking through
the door probably trying to get out of
sight right now she's in the back of the
room uh she made a comment that she
probably won't remember making she said
doing an event for bill coffin will be a
no-brainer well of course it is in the
sense that we've all been talking about
it we're all here in such uh such spirit
tonight but in fact any event
requires an extraordinary amount of hard
work and i had the fun part i went to
visit bill and randy in vermont and was
able to pick up some of the pictures
that you've seen went to new york and
visited with
lewis and jane gropp and others from
riverside and from union
but mary really did the hard work she
started by negotiating with the with the
hotel which is i see the excellent
service we're getting tonight maybe
wasn't as hard as it is with most hotels
but she did all that work
[Music]
she did the budget she did the program
she did the invitation uh and we owe so
much to mary and to our communications
director rob whitener uh and to joe
pettit our director of education and
outreach and summer samuels and many
others and i hope we can give them all a
round of applause
now
organization helps but organizations
require
funding support a euphemism for money
uh and so many of you have been so
generous but there are two that i'm uh
really three that i want to recognize in
a very special way just because they
haven't been recognized
these are folks
who have supported us at the very
beginning and any of you who have
started a new organization know what it
means to have that initial support you
pray for it you die for it and we've
gotten it from john beard
and from a man i've come to be so fond
of whom i met through gene winkler
west weeding and i want to spa say thank
you also to my friend ralph muller
who has been of course very generous but
he's also he held a home run a home
fundraiser for us he's listened to my
spiel about four or five times the last
time he fell asleep but no hard feelings
ralph
and we're very grateful to you
[Music]
now the organizational ties between
protestants for the common good and bill
coffin uh run very deep and my
esteem co-chair has preempted one
introduction i wanted to make
of our founder don benedict uh and if
any uh uh one person can be considered a
founder of this organization it would
surely uh be don
and we're so grateful to him
and he was
he was so appropriate in referring to
bill lovell uh bill lovell was
the tie to bill and don benedict and to
bill level go back to
the early 50s when don started an
experimental storefront church called
the east harlem protestant parish and
bill was an intern
in that first year and that tie i think
really
as i say runs very deep bill lovell uh
was with don in those years at union
theological seminary
and uh with protestants for the common
good
received the innocent salary of zero as
he worked for an entire year helping us
get underway
as important as the organizational
connections are
the ties between protestants for the
common good and bill coffin runs so
deeply on the issues that bill has
fought for all of his life and
protestants for the common good takes on
now
in our efforts
to achieve certain things in illinois
and beyond and bill knows how much i
appreciate his words and i'm going to
show those connections by
quoting a couple of things that bill has
said in the area of welfare and poverty
bill has said
that what the religious right persists
at ignoring
is that self-help is important
but self-help alone cannot solve the
problems of the poor
and protestants for the common good
since this very beginning has fought for
daycare for educational programs for job
training
we have put forward a bill which passed
last year which i
commend to peter edelman
because he's been such an outstanding
critic of welfare reform and this peter
is a bill that requires called know your
opportunities that requires the illinois
department of human services to put in
writing every six months the programs
and benefits that are available to
people who are applying to welfare or
who are on welfare and i think that can
be a model for other states
we fought for an earned income tax
credit in illinois joining with many
other groups and have had a modest
success this year a platform to build in
the future a bill which says the people
who work 40 hours a week ought to have
their wages supplemented so they're no
longer working below the poverty level
in the area of campaign finance reform
bill has said that money is always
talked but now it virtually shouts and a
phrase i especially like
in fact the power of organized money
may well exceed the power of organized
people
and protestants for the common good
helped with other groups to pass the
first significant welfare our campaign
finance reform bill in illinois two
years ago
it used to be that when we brought that
subject to campaign finance reform to
churches people's eyes we glaze over
that's no longer true and in this past
year little notice but very important a
bill
calling for the public financing of the
election of constitutional officers in
illinois
passed the house and we're very proud of
that
[Applause]
[Music]
in another area criminal justice i want
to acknowledge
calvin morris who's a co-convener of the
justice coalition of greater chicago
and jane ramsey who is with him
paul jakes of the
chain in the back
paul jakes of the
christian council on urban affairs we're
grateful for their presence and this is
an area that where we're active
but more important than any one issue is
what bill has taught us about the
relation of faith and politics he's
taught us that in cases of economic
oppression and human misery god is not
neutral god does care about politics and
that's the message of protestants for
the common good
we have over a thousand members in
illinois
we have over 40 individuals in churches
that know our programs and bring them
forward and promote our programs of
advocacy
and we're grateful for their support and
we're grateful for what bill has taught
us on this broader question
and on a personal level
let me simply say
that
more than any other individual
bill coffin
has had
an impact on what i try to do and what i
the way i try to live my life and there
are others here tonight
they're going to say that in much
greater detail they're going to describe
their experiences with bill
and so i simply want to close with one
phrase which i heard bill say in
relation to another great man
god bless you bill
you've sure blessed us
[Applause]
i forgot my most important task
which is to introduce our master of
ceremonies
an individual who's well described in
your program
he first knew bill as a classmate at the
yale divinity school the rest is history
you've seen a picture of them in the
freedom rise together
john mcguire
[Applause]
[Music]
i believe that ralph waldo emerson knew
bill coffin
see what you think
when he was asked what constitutes
success emerson replied
to laugh often and much
to win the respect of intelligent people
and the affection of the young
to earn the appreciation of honest
critics and endure the betrayal of false
friends
to appreciate beauty
to find the best in others
to leave the world a bit better whether
by garden patch or redeem social
condition
to know even one life better yet many
has breathed easier
because you lived
that said emerson is success
i'm sure he had coffin in mind
bill and his life of significant
contention have been characterized
variously
prophetic
luminous
powerful
as one person put it a pilot light that
over and over again ignites whole
furnaces
it's as if as a boy
bill had embraced on his heart
that celebrated remark of franklin
roosevelt carved forever on those stones
comprising the monumental fdr memorial
in washington
in these days of difficulty said the
president
we americans must and shall choose
the path of social
justice the path of faith
the path of hope
and the path of love toward fellow man
so before we begin tonight's tributes
bill we have a little surprise for you
a message from flesh of your flesh blood
of your blood
let the videos roll
i'm sorry i can't be with you but i'll
do my best to make a tape wrong tape
actually i want to reveal tonight that
arthur miller and bill kaufman are half
brothers it's never been known
until this moment but
actually we even had a closer relation
than arthur miller whom you will hear
from later and i would like that tape
please my dears to play
can we do it
so
there you all sit in chicago which is
where i should be but i had to perform
on this boat for a bunch of tourists
today and tomorrow
and the tourists are probably all from
chicago go figure
so i'm putting together this amateur
that's the key word amateur video
so
it'll fill the absence of my not being
there and it breaks my heart to not be
there
now this is a message for my father it's
a fairly private message but since
private to my father is pretty public
anyway you all can listen him to
and
it'll give him a lot of moral support
because he's gonna need it because this
is
the talk
from his son
[Music]
it was long ago
but i can still remember
one afternoon
you've told me for years how you live in
fear of getting the talk from your
children about you as a father
and for years i've told you it would
never happen that you had nothing to
worry about
and for years you've refused to believe
me okay
you win
you usually do
and for good reason
so let's start at the beginning
as a parent you were very unusual and
not really all that present for me as a
child
okay
now we got that out of the way
you feel better
now let me tell you something
as a child
you were the only father i had
you still are for that matter
and i don't remember ever walking around
wondering why you couldn't be more like
joe schmoe's father
besides
you were home every weekend i knew right
where you were you were sitting in your
study friday night to sunday morning
writing your sermon
every weekend
and i knew it was important too
i could tell by the look on your face
every time you came out to tell us to be
quiet especially that third time in a
row and i had to convince you that amy's
leg really was broken
yeah well
never mind that
your parenting skills were readily
available to anyone and everyone who
should so be in need
one only had to be in the congregation
to feel the love emanating from every
word
and as a child
when i did go to church
i got my fix with everyone else
but i was special
because you were my father
and that was enough for me
i always knew you were there
you just had to parent on a global scale
and i just had to learn to share
not a bad education
[Music]
you have to know that i admired
everything you were doing
even if i didn't really understand it
all i knew that it meant a lot to many
people and that made me feel really
proud
but you have no idea what an impact it
made and continues to make
when you got divorced that the three of
us stayed with you
now how often was that done in the late
sixties
for whatever the reasons that decision
was made
it made a lasting impression on this
eight-year-old boy
and no
you were not really capable of handling
the three of us
hell not too many people were
but it's not about capability is it
what you lacked an ability was
overpowered by your intentions
and it's about intentions
and yours were always very clear
you love your children
for me as a parent now
i'm still learning from you
yes there are things i don't really want
to replicate
but the overwhelming love and passion
you put into your life
and the convictions you relentlessly
pursue
are inspiring to a first-time father
like myself
i don't have to imitate your style
but i've got passion and love that my
little girl can feel right down to her
little toes
because you taught me how important it
is to feel loved
the most powerful thing i've ever heard
you say is framed on the wall in my
studio
it is not because we have value that we
are loved
but because we are loved that we have
value
what greater gift could a father teach
his son than to love
it may have taken me a while and i'm no
expert
but i think i'm catching on
i admit it's a great honor to be a
presenter tonight among all these
distinguished guests
and it breaks my heart not to be there
in person
i know i can say amen to all that's
being said about you tonight
[Music]
no
troubled
dreams will
cross my mind
and as my little girl would say
it feels me very better
knowing amy alex and i
are the only ones who can say
that's my father
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
son david coffin
a couple of years ago i did a primitive
matrix that added up the number of years
that bill and marion and andrew and i
had known each other
by taking first one of us and
calculating the number of years that he
or she had been a mate of the other
three
and then taking the second and the other
three and on and on the grand total came
to
to the wincing disbelief of coffin
edelman young and myself
474 years
now you add the length of our respective
friendships with joe huff coral weiss
and arthur miller and the numbers over
700 years it's a rich mosaic of
friendship from which to mine this
evening's tributes to bill
while i've known joe huff the longest of
all we met when we were both 16.
my friendship with bill goes back 45
years when we were yale divinity
classmates
where at least twice weekly i was
desperately hanging on the back of his
careening bmw motorcycle
consoled again and again along with my
wife billy by impromptu concerts
one-man shows of schuman leader in the
living room of his mother's new haven
home
a groomsman in his wedding
a freedom riding cellmate in my native
montgomery
a colleague in arms and countless
crusades i'm pleased beyond telling by
tonight's assignment
as mc for this bill coffin birthday
party
chapter 7 of marion wright edelman's
latest book lanterns a memoir of my
mentors
is entitled
william sloane coffin jr malcolm x
and getting ready for mississippi
it chronicles marion's yale law school
years
meeting the university chaplain who's
destined later to perform a wedding
ceremony for her husband peter and
herself 1968
who will become her cherished friend and
counselor
and in whose home she lived with his
family during her years as a law student
we all associate marion as well we
should
with the children's defense fund which
she founded and has led for the last 26
years
here's snippets of citations i've done
for marion over the years
missionary for a brighter future for the
world's young people
provider of possibility to the hopeless
and the bread of promise to those who
hunger
steadfast devotion
unceasing commitment
mother
for us all
my adored friend of now just over 40
years marion wright edelman
[Applause]
god was shown up showing off
when he created bill coffin
he gave him a whole lot of gifts
which he has used to give so much
to all of us
he gave him a great gift of music
not only could you play the clarinet i
never heard a lot
but he got to play the guitar
which i did get to hear a lot in the
piano and then he gave him a great voice
and a song
which he could carry on in english and
in russian and in french and god knows
how many other languages because god
also gave him a gift
with languages
god gave him a gift of spirit
and conviction
which was in home which was honed and
enriched by some of the great spirits
and theologians of our time including
reinhold and richard nebor and paul
tilik and abraham joshua heschel and
uncle henry sloane coffin whom i wish i
had gotten a chance to meet
uncle sid levitt
he was invited by president griswold
to become yale's conscience at 33
only two years out of seminary where he
then began his ministry of an
uncomfortable gospel
which he actually had the nerve to try
to practice and later got labeled
in mr griswold's word says yale's own
phone terrible
after he went on a freedom rider peter
ride and i got to tell you the one thing
i've never forgiven bill coffin for is
his sexism and not taking me when i
begged on the freedom ride to alabama
and he took a black law student mail
instead
but at any rate
too dangerous dear it was out of very
gentlemanly love but i've never forgiven
him
he's working on it but god gave bill
a great talent
for moral outrage backed by courageous
witness
you are my witnesses said the lord and
he has been a witness on many of the
great causes in our time where there was
not enough jews at yale
whether it was civil rights and the
freedom rides whether it was stopping
the vietnam war
whether it was heading sane and speaking
out against a crazy world that is
imprisoned by
nuclear and conventional weapons
he has been there whether speaking out
against physical poverty and the richest
nation on earth
or about spiritual poverty
for those who have so much who share too
little
god gave him a great gift for growth and
for learning
in his own words and his wonderful
memoir he says i was an elitist who came
to question moral such principles i was
a combative young spirit who espoused
non-violence
i was a boy with a gift
for music and language who became a
preacher
and that gift for growth has been one
that has inspired me
all of my life
god gave him a great gift a struggle
and a gift
of resiliency
life has not always been a crystal stair
for bill coffin in langston hughes's
wonderful words but he has navigated his
losses and his hard times
with great grace
and with great
faith
god also gave bill a great gift of
hospitality
and friendship
he took me in
to his home and to his family with his
wonderful children
at yale which still relegated women to a
segregated dorm on temple street
and we all know about bill's great gift
for strategic mischief
he used me
as a black woman to integrate
with women the yale usher board of patel
chapel he knew that nobody would dare be
against me as a woman because they'd be
afraid of being charged with being
anti-black and so it was done very
quietly and i appreciate
that
finally
god gave him a great gift of stewardship
for the earth and for its people and i
would like to end with his own wonderful
words which he wrote in his memoir which
again i recommend that we read and
reread
and he said the world very simply is not
ours
at best we're guests
and what a great guest in god's world
bill is
what a charming and disarming and
zestful guest and friend
what a useful guest in god's quest for
social justice and compassion
what a privilege and gift it is
to share this time and space with you in
god's world
and i wish you the happiest of birthdays
and many
many more to a very much loved friend
and mentor thank you for just being
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
since andrew young's birthday is in
march and mine in august i always
introduce him as my older brother by
five months
another colleague and soul mate for more
than four decades
he's the former three-term united states
congressman united states ambassador to
the united nations
two-term mayor of atlanta co-chairman of
the centennial olympic games
colleague of martin luther king jr and
he wrote to people worldwide who yearn
and struggle for justice
since i make a practice of providing
honorary degrees for closest friends
wherever i go
wesleyan old westbury claremont
i've had occasion to characterize andrew
at one place or another as an
entrepreneur of the human spirit
luminously committed to the
establishment of a better fairer life
for all
and now i add godfather the best i can
imagine
to our oldest grandson his namesake
andrew john turner
only a few days ago andy learned that he
had to undergo just yesterday
a piece of post-prostate surgery a
plumbing repair he said and remind him
only that
but he's with us tonight by tape andrew
young
good gracious alive
bill coffin 75 years old
that means
[Music]
us young radicals are getting old
remember when we were the
young hotshots in the church the
visionaries that were against
segregation and i must confess you were
ahead of me you went to jail long before
i did
uh and
i want to thank you for your vision for
your leadership
uh down through the years for almost
three-fourths of a century
but
i also want to remind you
that the lord didn't call moses
until he was 80.
and i'm sure there were young folk
around men
but
god is not through with you yet not
through with any of us yet
and
i think
that the things that happened in the 60s
with the civil rights movement and the
protest against the war in vietnam and
the
beginnings of conversations about gender
equity uh and and your constant
prophetic and clarion call to remember
the least of these god's children
we should know what we're doing now
and we should be ready to continue to
change the world in the 21st century and
so in wishing you a happy birthday
i also
extend to you
the invitation and the challenge
uh to continuing leadership in the next
century
god has blessed us far beyond our
deserving
but
to them to whom much has been given
of them will much be required
you have lived up to that challenge all
these many years
and
i'm sure
the best is yet to come
god bless you and have a wonderful happy
birthday
[Applause]
[Music]
three terms spring to mind when you
think of joe huff
theological
education race
manager par excellence
an ethicist by practice and training at
yale
he's been the long time dean of both the
claremont school of theology and the
vanderbilt university divinity school
race in america has been the subtext and
often the explicit substance throughout
his work
from the days and watts in the 60s he
was the first white trusted in after the
riots
to this very day
he's acknowledged by his peers as
perhaps the country's preeminent
seminary administrator
and the board of theology union
theological seminary in new york
recognized all three of these
characteristics
in naming joe last year as its president
where his talents all of his special
gifts
are being tested
and daily displayed
heidi and joe are summer neighbors of
the coffins
but joe has promised not to tell stories
of those vermont nights tonight and
instead walk the high road
in his toast to bill it's hard for him
but let's see if he can do it president
joe
[Applause]
[Music]
i hope that was recorded
those are the nicest things john mcguire
ever said about me
i'm very pleased to be here tonight bill
i must say that when i arrived at yale
my first experience of you at battelle
chapel was a deep disappointment
having come from danville virginia with
the ku klux klan and the john birch
society close on my tail
and hoping for a vision of some new
leadership in the south i saw you and i
said to my
one of my friends who'd come with me
from the southern baptist down in the
south
you know it's a shame that fell as a
liberal because he could have been a
real good billy graham
when i think of bill coffin
images come to my mind
images that imprinted indelibly on my
memory
the pictures of him on the freedom rides
the image of bill standing on the steps
of the capitol burning draft cards
both protesting gross
evil and injustice in our society
in that sense
bill kaufman preached by image and
preached by example more than most any
other protestant leader in the united
states
john asked me to talk about bill as a
preacher and i think i have to begin
there
because bill has been the preacher to
the nation
in many respects he's been the moral
conscience of this nation
and he's done that effectively both with
his life his actions and his preaching
i want to rehearse some of the themes
that i've seen in his
sermons
and in his speeches just a
few the main theme in all of bill's
preaching and in his public speaking has
been the centrality of love
in the teachings of the christian
tradition love he says is the core value
of the christian life love is our
business when we don't love we're out of
business
it's better not to live
than not to love
person through his his many sermons has
been a deep deep spirituality and he
describes it as spirituality is living
the ordinary life in extraordinary ways
it is a life filled with wonder
no one he says scoffs at the stars nor
do we sneer at the sunsets
and we should never forget
that the tree of life and the tree of
knowledge are deeply rooted
in the very soil of mystery
he's been a pungent critic of the
academic world he once said by and large
the academic world is tolerant
but it tends to be passivity
tolerance and passivity are a dangerous
combination together
they allow us to tolerate the
intolerable
and to ignore the power of anger in the
work of love
for if you lower your anger at the
structures of power you lower your love
for the virtues
before the victims of power excuse me
on religious certainty
something bills struggle with and we all
do
there are those who prefer certainty to
truth he said
those in the church who put the purity
of dogma ahead of the integrity of love
and what a distortion of the gospel it
is
to have limited sympathies and unlimited
certainties when the very reverse to
have limited certainties and unlimited
sympathies is not only more tolerant
but far more christians
on biblical interpretation it's
absolutely right he said to love and
learn from this from the books of the
bible but it's wrong to fear their every
word for not everything biblical is
christ-like
on american leadership he says
the united states does not have to lead
the world it first has to join it
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
then he muses with greater humility it
can play
a wiser leadership role nations
are at their best
when they claim
their god-given kinship with all
humanity
offering prayers of thanks
that there's more mercy in god
than there is sin in us
and finally on caring
if we unite freedom and virtue by caring
ceaselessly for one another
than our democracy
presently
static
will once again feel the advance of hope
in this century we americans have
created a world for some of us
i think it's time in the next century
to create a world finally for all of us
what characterized coffrin's
uh preaching characterizes pastoral
leadership
any of you who have known him as a close
friend
know that he is one of those public
speakers
rare and deep
who is an incredible listener as well
bill hears and cares about the pain of
individuals
he will spend hours with an individual
in deep trouble
in order to see them through
but bill never saw his attention to
individuals
in pain and suffering
separate from his care
where those who in a larger social world
suffer from all of the repression
prejudice hatred and poverty that to him
is so offensive
for him caring like love is a seamless
web
that attunes itself and attends to the
particular person as well as
to the anonymous victim of injustice
charity he said is always
back on the far side
and on the near side of justice
love moves us from what is here and what
is far and back again
caring is reaching out to persons and
speaking out against injustice
and bill the pastoral
and the prophetic were joined together
with a passion of one who has a love
affair with god
and with the world
to love god is to love god's world and
god's people
christian piety and the struggle for
justice flow from the same fountain
the waters of compassion
that forever stir
and refresh bill coffin's soul
i counted the privilege to have known
this man
i counted the privilege to have him as a
friend
and to have had him as my pastor
bill as preacher and pastor
you have been an exemplar for all of us
who aspire to love and care for god in
the world
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
cora weiss and bill teamed up in the 60s
for the first time
determined to end the war in vietnam
they targeted recruitment centers they
counseled and supported draft resistors
they marched in washington and seemed
like everywhere else
at one time or another
they visited hanoi
bringing home three american prisoners
of war
china
tashkent
old russia
people still marble as the tabloids put
it at a jew serving as pastor of
riverside church in new york which in
fact cora did as founder director of the
riverside church disarmament program to
reverse the arms race during 1977
to 1988 the decade of bill's senior
pastorate there
they continued as a team during bill's
stint as president of sane freeze and
continue this day
as partners in the struggle for peace
if ever war is abolished
organizations like the hague appeal for
peace which she heads
led by people like coral weiss
will make it happen
but come to think of it though there's
no one like coral weiss an american
original coral weiss
[Music]
i didn't recognize a word he said
thank you dear bill
thank you for being for doing for
teaching for preaching
for 35 years of friendship for working
together drinking together marching
together for marrying our kids
for randy and amy and alex and david and
jessica and will
and for catherine and ned and vi
and margot too
thank you for being part of our family
dear bill
this is not a eulogy but a very
premature sneak preview is not a bad
idea
nor are the garlands of gracias and the
outpouring of praise
tonight meant to put an end
to your outrage at outrageous racism
homophobia poverty in the land of plenty
and militarism and weapons production
at the expense of human security
this is a real conspiracy not like the
trumped-up one that took you to court
this is meant to fire you up to continue
to be the truth-teller
ever mindful of mark twain's admonition
that truth is the most valuable thing we
have so let's economize with it
but your generosity
knows no economy
and if i may borrow one of your own
quotes bill
you get
at the truth the ancient rabbis had in
mind the truth we would all rather deny
but must confront
for our personal salvation
and the world's survival
we're here to tell you to continue to
educate us
what we americans don't know will kill
us
as it has already lots of other people
you said
we're here to say to continue to inspire
us
peace needs to be understood as a
pastoral issue not a prophetic one
disarmament and development those
inseparable twins should head the
world's agenda your words continue to
lead us
become humble before the poor and bold
on their behalf
continue to work for the abolition of
war you said
and continue to be hooked on hope
about which woody guthrie sang
all a human being is anyway is a hoping
machine
now i was going to tell a few very funny
stories about
working and traveling with bill and
sometimes randy
but there's a six-minute rule so you'll
have to catch me afterwards
it was exactly five years ago this week
when you and randy found refuge in our
home
evening after evening after you spent
the daytime fasting for the abolition of
nuclear weapons at the united nations
and you issued a statement it's our
position that you cannot have it both
ways either the nuclear nations
relinquish their right to possess
nuclear weapons
or any nation can claim that right and
more and more of them will
either the world becomes nuclear free
or the whole planet becomes a nuclear
porcupine
that was at the 1995 review meeting of
the nuclear non-proliferation treaty
npt
today as we eat and meet here
another five-year review is on this time
with two new nuclear powers and no
progress toward abolition
and no one
is fasting
this year
in 1995 one result of the npt review was
considerable weight loss
for you
we fear the consequence of this year's
conference may be the design and testing
of a new generation of nuclear weapons
and the unraveling of the abm treaty the
bedrock of arms control agreements
bill you gave me my marching orders for
tonight
say a few nice words you said and then
lay out the agenda
how can i ever thank you for that crazy
idea in may of 1978
to bring
a jewish housewife from the bronx as
judge hoffman referred to me at the
chicago 7 trial
here in chicago
into the majesty of the riverside church
where years before james foreman had
called for the restitution for the poor
and dr king for an end to the war
against vietnam and you were occupying
the pulpit with your charismatic
brilliance you asked the trustees and
congregation to honor the centennial of
the birth of harry emerson fosdick which
coincided with the un special session on
disarmament by hiring me for one year to
organize convocations one year became 10
unforgettable productive moving and
shaking years of teamwork with you and a
gorgeous staff eric cobell is here
well it's not over bill
we don't call for the abolition of
nuclear weapons to make the world safe
for so-called conventional weapons and
war
we understand that abolishing nuclear
weapons is a building house a bill
excuse me a building block for the house
of peace
but it must accompany a call for the
abolition of war
the violence of the 20th century the
most war-filled century in history must
not become the legacy for the 21st it is
time to move from a culture of violence
to a culture of peace
to abolish war as humanity once
virtually abolished
slavery colonialism and apartheid all of
which were coveted paid for with taxes
and protected by law if we could
eliminate them why
not
war
that is our agenda we need everyone to
understand that it takes a holistic
approach to make this wonderful world
safe for our children and our children's
children and the only way it's going to
happen
is if each of us starts to starts and
continues wherever we are
talk
teach
preach
let's infuse the atmosphere with a call
for the rejection of anything nuclear
for the abolition of war and with a
demand that peace education be
integrated into all our schools
as the fourth are
reading writing arithmetic and
reconciliation
we ain't gonna study
war no more
[Music]
[Applause]
we ain't gonna study war no more
because as carl sandberg said
nothing happens unless first a dream
keep on they'll keep an on
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
repeatedly during crises in their
respective lives
and both have known
them bill and arthur miller have turned
to and comforted each other
arthur miller is one of our most
venerable and venerated playwrights
represented on broadway right now by a
new piece the ride down mount morgan
from death of a salesman
view from the bridge and the crucible
his plays indeed all of his work
have illumined our understanding of the
human condition
by repeatedly moving our hearts
past their breaking point
unable to be here in person tonight he's
recorded this message to bill and us all
arthur miller
i'm sorry i can't be with you but i'll
do my best to make up for it
i believe i met bill coffin during a
demonstration in new haven against the
vietnam war
he was a big surprise then a christian
minister
who seemed enormously enthusiastic about
living in this mostly evil world
it took a while to get used to stepping
out of the way of his order
he seemed utterly unafraid of anything
even including philosophical
contradictions
which would depress any ordinary
optimist
after many years it occurred to me that
coffin is a knight
knights were spiritual men they had to
be
wrapped in steel as they were in
freezing weather
or in terrible heat with rain leaking
down their backs and a fly or two biting
under their armpits where they couldn't
scratch
their minds must have been vaulting
beyond the physical
in fact their concentration was on
saving the innocent from the unjust
and that is what coffin has been doing
practically all his life
but with a difference of course
bill unlike old-time knights
knows that much cruelty is systemic and
springs from a blind unmitigated lust
for wealth and political advantage
man for coffin was not acquainted with
evil at birth
but is rather a fallen angel whose wings
at least in many cases
can be re-feathered by willing hands
and so he is partly a political knight
but one who has tried to see around
shibboleths and received ideological
convictions
so as to confront individuals in that
private suffering
but he's no philosopher
he's too impulsive
to sit quietly
unwinding the tangled
surmises of our age
there are too many suffering people to
try saving one at a time after all
bill is an activist and if each soul is
precious to him a crowd of them leaning
on a congressman is more likely to turn
the fellow toward righteousness
as it happens my wife and i have reason
to know his impulsiveness
years ago in a time of wandering
long before he had the incredible luck
to have met randy
bill showed up at our place for a
weekend
and when invited to stay for another day
or two
on impulse stayed six months
and wrote a book in the bargain
we came to enjoy bill's epic chromatic
writing which has a certain nightly
urgency
that of a man who can't help trying to
keep the world from rolling over the
cliff
coffin when the need is great
can drive a pulpit with a pedal to the
floor
even better in that six months were his
recitals bill is a wonderful pianist
as with everything else his love of
classical music is total his musical
learning profound
his singing is also terrific if you like
that sort of thing
i am probably alone in this
but bill's voice opens up vistas for me
of primeval forests
swamps in fact in which
moose
stand up to their knees in water
lifting their heads from their wet skunk
cabbage breakfast
to pleasurably vocalize toward the
waning moon
but enough praise
let it be simply said
that bill coffin has been the conscience
of his faith and his country
over these past many years
but he has the heart not so much of a
moralist as a poet
i've never known anyone more inspired by
language
or more susceptible to his charms
he can recite whole yards of verse or
prose from a memory that reaches back
unperturbed into his earliest years
worse yet he can do this in four
languages
english russian french and german
you have somebody like that walking
around on your place for six months and
you come out of it with either an eagle
strengthened by defense or none at all
i'm not sure that any civilization but
this
could have produced such a spirit
one so cleansed of misanthropy and
cynicism
is perhaps as important as his belief in
god that he believes in man
that he has preserved this in himself
takes on proportions of a talent a gift
beyond the reach of reason itself
and i think it is that stubborn and
solemn gift of belief in humanity that
has won in the esteem of so many even
sometimes of those who disagree with
them for it is a faith transcending word
or doctrine
and it has brought so many to sense and
bill coffin the moving reality of love
happy birthday chicago william and be
careful of the stairs
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
emerson said emerson said
i think emerson did say if we can get
this mic back on can we
is it can you hear
emerson said appreciate beauty
coffin revels in it particularly music
of which as a pianist most of you know
he is a highly accomplished performer
acclaimed by heifetz and milstein
zuckerman and acts his teachers and
peers archaeo del monte
now
performs in that inner circle of the
world's best
a critic recently wrote
here is a musician
who must possess an artistic soul
of exceptional beauty
his playing testifies to a winsome
musical personality
and verifies an impression of great
warmth and geniality
another of bill's friends and admirers
world-class violinist arturo del monte
has journeyed from new york just to play
tonight for bill and for us
i give you arturo del monte
[Music]
it is such an honor to be here when i
got a phone call
from alexander sharp inviting me to this
wonderful event
i thought
well
mozart because
bill and i have played
i think every mozart sonata that was
written plus a few others
but i realized that i was going to be
playing
a cappella tonight and i thought
no mozart won't do then i thought all
right what's for unaccompanied violin i
thought bach
but bach is so serious
a little bit uh not really quite
birthday music you know what i mean
so i thought all right paganini paganini
wrote stuff for solo violin but then i
thought you know that's that's kind of a
little bit glib it's show-offy for me
but it's not gonna
really pay tribute to bill and then with
all due respect to arthur miller whom i
admire tremendously i must say that when
i attended services at riverside church
i always always always tried to get an
aisle seat so that i could hear bill
when he was in the processional and then
in a recessional because i thought he
had a gorgeous voice
i used to love to hear him sing so
i thought okay i'm going to play
two songs forget the whole classical
routine no bach beethoven or brahms
tonight i'm going to play first
one of bill's favorite songs because i
found out by talking to randy on the
phone
and then i'm gonna play my very favorite
song of all and i really wish i were a
singer because these are songs indeed
but i think the violin comes about as
close as any instrument will come to
approximating the voice so bill two
songs for you
[Music]
easy
[Music]
[Music]
money
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
hey
[Music]
[Applause]
nice
[Music]
[Applause]
ready for this
[Music]
ah
[Music]
me
[Music]
hey
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
ah
[Music]
[Applause]
terrific
[Applause]
it just occurred to me that never has
coffin's career
been capsule so get a little drunk and
you land in jail there
bill coffin brother bell
prophet
preacher
leader pastor
catalyst crusader friend
i think ingersoll could have been
speaking of you bill
when he said of walt whitman
his arm was beneath the form of the sick
he sympathized with the imprisoned and
despised and even on the brow of crime
he was great enough to place
the kiss of human sympathy
as you know bill i once wrote of you and
it's even truer today than then
bill coffin is willing to expose the
truth of his soul in public
so that others of us less brave
may find the courage and inspiration to
dream
and perform our own actions
ladies and gentlemen
our 75th birthday boy bill coffin
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
preparatory remark
after last summer's stroke
i console myself
with mark twain's conclusion
about wagner's music
it's better than it sounds
[Applause]
but
[Music]
i have
no
i have no such illusions about my voice
so
please
be indulgent
another remark comes to mind
this one from golden mayor
an aide of hers
was given a tribute
dinner
and as the aide rose to respond
golden mayor suggested to the aide
don't be humble you're not that great
[Laughter]
[Applause]
so
rather than be humble
i will certainly be simply
grateful
beyond measure
dear friends
and
colleagues
and world wishes
for
a very special
evening
when the the rabbi
uh
stood up
i was sure he'd come
to bury me and not to praise me
of course coffins are used to that fate
but i'm glad he reminded
myself and all
that there is more mercy in god than in
sin and us
and thank you for leaving
a few rocks unturned
[Music]
i'm very glad
gene you mentioned
my family
uh
if you hadn't made them stand up
i
would because
without my family
i would be unthinkable
without my wife i
would be unbearable
[Applause]
no one when i transferred
to yale divinity school
it was rumored that i had
received the highest highest marks
in my class
but instead of crowding around
to congratulate me
my classmates all said
wait till john mcguire comes back from
his year abroad
and i did
and sure enough
i soon came to know
the anonymity
of the team that loses the super bowl
i've often think thought
that
sincerity stammers
but john never stumbles
and he's always sincere
[Laughter]
and he and billy are about as all the
friends
as i think i i have
um
arturo
o arturo boya i love you so
and after you
uh
andy
i'm like woman man river i just keep
rolling along
but arturo you were very good to come
he has been
tonic for my soul
on many an occasion
and
as the coral
there simply is no better peacenik
in this country and beyond
i have no better friend
in large part because i have learned
so much
uh for from coral
and it doesn't surprise me at all
to know that uh
korra as president
of the hague appeal for peace
have been nominated by a member of the
norwegian parliament
for this year's recipient of the nobel
nobel peace prize
let all other contenders
crowd into the shade
and as for dear marion
since she was
a slip of a kid from spelman college
and came to live with us
i had
a clear impression
that i probably
would never know anybody
who made more of god's gifts than miriam
has
was the things god gave her
and
it was a great pleasure to perform the
wedding for peter and marion
and when you thought stopped to think
about it every one of these people have
fantastic spouses
he'd be bummed without billy
and marion would be shaky without peter
and cora
uh would be all over the place without
uh another peter to give her direction
and uh
the other thing that i think
oh john heidi
that would simply demonstrate my mastery
of the obvious
to say without the good swiss girl like
heidi
joe would not be
the best seminarian president
in the country as john correctly
described him
i
often thought
i like to drink with one crowd and work
with another
but these around here
i could drink with them as well as to
work with them
and as uh i would confess
that i generally prefer
reform to reformers
but every one of these reformers are
really
very very good company
and i have saved uh
uh the last
for uh al sharp
and the board
and um
the staff of this organization
protestants for the common good
where the two rabbis are a matter of
fact not a wolf but we have saperstein
here
i am
reminded of the jewish woman who went to
sir to a rabbi
and complained
that her her husband
did not know how to play cards
and the rabbi said
and where is it written
that the man should know how to play
cards
and the woman said rebbe you don't
understand he does not know how to play
cards but he plays
well that describes quite a few
executive directors of
non-non-profit institution
[Applause]
but by contract
al
is absolutely phenomenal
and what your the staff
and the board has done in five years is
is simply
a occasion
for incredible gratitude and heart
warming uh
al
whoever said you had had the brilliant
career
and then gave it up for seminary had it
all wrong you wasted a lot of time at
the university of chicago
[Applause]
but now
you have come into
into europe
and at the al's request
i will take
a few minutes and talk about the work
of the
protestants for the common good
in order to wind up
i have i have long held
that
only those
who attempt to attempt the absurd
achieve the impossible
and i believe further
that christianity is a world of view
that undergirds progressive thought
and progressive action in fact i believe
the church
doesn't so much have
a social ethics
ethic
as it is
a social ethic
that view of both christianity and the
church
animated a lot of impressive movements
in the last century
in the
1910s
and twenties
religious socialism
in switzerland and germany
thrived
ads across the atlantic
did the social gospel enoch in the
united states
eloquently expounded by walter
rauschenbusch
shortly after world war ii
there appeared the workers priests
movement in france
than in the 60s and 70s the liberation
theologies of latin america and the
black theologies of the united states
and africa
slightly
later came feminists
and womanist theologies
followed by gay and lesbian ones
all these movements
proclaimed that while
justice does not exhaust the gospel it
is at the heart
of the gospel
not ancillary to it
that meant that justice
is not a political option
but a moral manta
divinely inspired
but as george huntica points out in his
fine new book on cardboard
while each movement made its mark
none
prevailed
quote
each in its own way
forced the church to choose between
progressive politics and traditional
faith
making it seem as though the two
were mutually exclusive
it failed to see that confronted with
the forced option
said
hanziger
the church will inevitably choose not to
abandon
traditional faith
well perhaps the primary goal
of protestants for the common good
is to persuade the churches
that the choice between progressive
politics and traditional faith
is a false one
it's not that come by combining the two
guarantees success
it's that separating the two
virtually virtually
guarantees failure
two weeks ago i was reminded of clarence
jordan's
contention
the proof of easter is not a rolled away
stone
but a carried away church
how can churches world over
not be carried away
how can they remain indifferent
or indecisive
faced by refugees
and displaced persons
now numbering millions
fleeing war
and famine
crowding into scissors cities
to escape poverty
only there to confront rampant
unemployment
environmental degradation
urban violence and
pockets of digitizing wealth and
privilege
we have heard may
mention of don benedict
and the brother lovell
i used to think
the united states was made up of old
turks and young fogies
but i'm beginning to think
that maybe there are a few young turks
in the next generation
and i thank god for the growing number
of
number of christians in this particular
organization
and in in others
want
the plight of the poor
to be at the top of the national agenda
who believe that the redistribution of
wealth should be at the top of the
agenda
of every church
thank god for every christian
who sees that the lack of material
well-being for the poor
reflects a lack of spiritual well-being
for the rich
second century
a second century manual on church
disciplines
addressed well-to-do christians in this
manner quote
if you are willing to share what is
everlasting
you should be that much more willing to
share things which do not last
[Music]
also at the top of the agenda of every
church
should be and i'm a hundred percent in
accord with cora
should be an ongoing
never-ending commitment
to to hawk the licensed savagery of
warfare
to see to it as corey said that war is
buried in history alongside
of slavery
colonialism and apartheid
[Music]
you know it is
it is estimated that since the first
century
149
million people have died in war
in the last century alone
100 million
died in war
and in the last
decade of the cert of the century
90 percent of the casualties were
civilians
like justice peace too is not a
political consideration but a moral
mandate
divinely
ordained
and while protestants for the common
good
properly
focuses its attention
on breaking the shackles of poverty in
other
in illinois
i'm sure all your members
know that without peace
there is no justice
just as without justice
there is no peace
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
as the new millennium begins the world
is at a critical turning point
our ability to affect destiny for good
or ill
is now so much greater than it was a
hundred years ago
there is no technological
excuse for a poverty in the world today
justice is now technologically possible
to end all life on the planet
how important
then it is for the churches
to realize that transitional faith i'm
talking about deep conservative
faith
uh isn't it in an incentive
not hindrance
to creating what the pope in his each of
the message called
a more just
and mutually supportive world
we are not called uh to mirror
but to challenge culture
not to sustain
but to upend
the status quo
and if that sounds a bit bold
to some of you
isn't true
that god is always beckoning
us
towards horizons we aren't sure we want
to reach
in almost every church
there there are gentle cowards
who think that their gentleness
offsets their cowardice
it doesn't
compassion frequently demands
confrontation
as
all those 20th century
movements i mentioned illustrate
the primary reason i suspect
that their views did not prevail
it's because churches
vastly prefer
charity
which in no way affects the status quo
to justice which immediately leads to
political confrontation
fellow pastors
be as pastoral
as
possible but do not surrender one iota
of ethical initiative
[Applause]
but finally how do we keep touching on
when we see the same old injustice here
there and everywhere
what to do in those moments
when you feel
not like that
kentucky derby winner pegasus
but rather russell dante
a tired heck of a horse
driven by a quick sonic idea
or when as grace paley said
everything you do is scream that but
what
by what you have not been doing
it seems to me you have to despair
you have to be realistic
the world has always been rife
with
wrongs and if you're
disillusioned
ask yourself
why
whoever gave you the right to have
illusions in the first place
walker percy
to quote another poet declares the best
despair
and the beginning of hope
is to be conscious of despair in the
very air we breathe and to look around
for something better
and in seeking and finding something
better
we have a lot of support
can't you hear
our ancestors
who cry out daily
finish our work
finish our work
in this time of year remember the talmud
which says
over every blade of grass
there hovers an angel whispering
grow grow
read the 136 psalm that begins oh give
thanks to the lord for he she is good
and then repeats 26 times before god's
set fast love
endures
forever
and finally
blessed be the ties that bind not only
your minds
but no less a heart
i personally feel heartbound
to millions of people
most of whom i will never know
the world's over
people
who in every land and persuasion
carry on a lover's quarrel with a nation
after
a reflection of god's eternal levels
quarrel with the whole world
these are the people who long for
spiritual depth
not self secular power
who dare to be in the right with two or
three
knowing that the immediate future will
not be kind
to our ideas and ideals
and people
who realize
that without resistance
you can't fly
certainly i feel hot bound to each and
every one of you
the world has no prizes
to offer
like that of friendship
together i'm sure
we can find
something better
if we attempt the ensures absurd
we'll achieve the impossible
so
let's hang together
all for one
and one for all
and for this memorable evening
i can no other answer make
but thanks
and thanks
and ever thanks
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
programs featuring non-fiction books
authors and the publishing industry
48 hours of non-fiction books
saturday through monday morning on book
tv
echoes down the corridor is a new book
by playwright arthur miller it's a
collection of his essays examining
events from throughout history
from the mccarthyism of the 50s to
president clinton's impeachment
recently mr miller sat down with victor
navasky of the nation magazine to talk
about his work and the state of politics
today including this year's presidential
race
it's about 50 minutes
good evening i'd like to welcome you all
to barnes noble on union square
we are honored to have arthur miller
with us this evening and to celebrate
the publication of his new book echoes
down the corridor collected essays 1944
to 2000.
introducing mr miller this evening and
leading our discussion tonight is victor
navaski mr navoski has been editor of
the nation since 1978
and became its publisher and editorial
director in january of 1995.
mr navaski has served as a guggenheim
fellow
a visiting scholar at the russell sage
foundation
and ferris visiting professor of
journalism at princeton university
in addition to his responsibilities at
the nation mr navoski is director of the
james t delacourt center of magazine
journalism at columbia university please
join me in welcoming our guests
so
uh you can all hear us he hasn't said
anything yet but i say it now you heard
me here okay so the mics are working
good all right arthur
and and all of you last week i got a
call from the op-ed page of the new york
times
uh gus hall the executive secretary of
the communist party had died they wanted
to know if i could do a brief uh op-ed
about him because they said it seemed
that his death marked the end of an era
so i had some questions about how people
today talked and thought about the old
communist party and i thought this would
give me a chance to work them out so i
said yes
and when i sat down to write i
remembered something that arthur miller
had once written and it seemed directly
on point so i wrote the following
sentence
as part of this piece
quote
arthur miller the great american
playwright once observed quote an era
may be said to end when it's basic
illusions are exhausted
the quotation by the way it seems to me
is typical of the
of miller's muscular prose and of of the
kind of pithy elegance and profundity uh
that he would within which he has when
he writes prose which makes one wonder
why this great playwright
didn't write more prose until i saw this
collection and i i recommend it uh to
all of you you'll see what i mean
anyway i sent the piece into the times
and the phone rang a couple of hours
later and it was the op editor op-ed
editor and she said the piece is fine
but there's one thing we have to
we have to worry about i said what's
that a few minor changes i said okay she
said you can't call miller the great
american playwright
because if you do i will get a note
in the margins from the assistant
managing editor for style at the times
saying
what do you think the new york times
readers are fools
they already know that so the bad news
is you can't call arthur miller the
great american playwright in the new
york times the good news is that's
because he is already famously known to
be that
on the evidence of these essays he's
also
the great american pro stylist so i'm
very privileged and glad to be here i'm
not going to waste your time by telling
you about all the great plays he's
written or his novel or
uh or his the essays in this book which
which i hope will come out in
our conversation but arthur since i
mentioned the communist party and since
a number of the essays
in your book
touch on communism
and what i think of as it's american
traveling companion as distinguished
from fellow traveler mccarthyism
let me begin with an observation and a
question
my observation is that the demonization
of the communist party and communists
during the domestic cold war
was understandable
if regrettable
but as ambiguous fragments from kgb
archives and
intercepted cables come on the market
today
it
there seems to be an unseemly rush
by a new generation of scholars
they want to seize on these ambiguous
documents to argue in effect that the
old coal warriors if not mccarthy
himself were right all along
and uh and that the the american
communist party was indeed
a nest of spies
at its center
so my question to you is
is that observation right if it is
what's going on here
well of course i wouldn't know
if they were they weren't uh
the people i knew who were
in the communist party were certainly
not spies they were
i mean my sampling is
minute so i can't
really make any definitive statement
about it
but they were people who were teachers
or writers or scholars or somebody
who
for them for their own
peace of mind wanted to oppose fascism
basically
uh
i think that without hitlerism there
would have been no
reaction to the left here of that
dimension
uh they were people who were
convinced that
uh the only real
opposition to hitler would have been the
soviet union
because the british were compromised the
french were totally corrupt
the italians were fascists
and
that
if
civilization was to be
maintained it would have to come from
the east
that was
what i understood to be the basic matrix
of the whole situation now
whether there were spies i'm sure there
must have been but i don't know anything
about that uh
to
assume that that whole social movement
was purely an espionage movement is
ridiculous because after all many of
those people helped to form the
cio
they helped to form some of the
best and most honest labor unions in
this country
they were the avant-garde
in that endeavor
and
that some of the leaders or some of the
money for it was coming from abroad
i wouldn't say it wasn't but i how would
i know
so assume that that's true what is it
that would be driving people today
to
to make this other case put the evidence
assume the evidence is exactly the way
you've described it
is there some dynamic going on today
well of course
there was
a
there and there is a
um
what you could call a movement i suppose
although that's too big a word for it a
former communists and former left people
who
were either disgusted finally by the
whole thing and turned against it
or
people who
simply see a way of uh of washing their
own women
who were
basically left people and didn't want to
be known as such anymore
but there's also an honest group of
people who were
who feel that uh anything that had any
left
socialist
uh
content in it was treasonous right
and uh
but to to to
douse the whole movement in that
as an espionage outfit it was it's
ridiculous okay
and do you think there is anything from
your
observation of what is now called
mccarthyism
the plays
that you've written
during that period about
the dynamic
that we now call mccarthyism
that uh can help us to understand
the impeachment proceedings against bill
clinton
you know uh
if you're talking about the crucible the
crucible
been
produced
i don't know they're probably 50
countries
and
it's been done under
a half dozen different kinds of systems
where a government
decides to throw overboard
civil liberty
guarantees
and simply destroy its enemies
the same procedures seem
to develop for example
right after the thinking this book i
have an essay about
a lady i met in my publisher's office
years ago
who
had was chinese
and had spent six years
in a chinese prison
bound with her hands behind her back so
she had to eat like a dog
uh
she when the they let her out when the
regime changed
uh another friend of mine who was a
chinese director brought her to see this
play which she'd never heard of
and she saw the crucible in chinese and
at the end of it
she would not believe that a non-chinese
had written it
and the reason for it was was as she
told me
the questions were literally the same
questions that were asked in salem
massachusetts
and in washington d.c
and in beijing
and i could go down the list and
practically every latin american country
and in russia
and from time to time
in revolutionary periods
france and england
once and the idea of a conspiracy is in
place
of a secret dark
combine
to overthrow decency
once that happens
there is a pattern of human reaction to
it
which does not differ from country to
country system to system
at all
and that's what i was trying to say in
the crucible right
and how if at all does that imply to
what
the what seemed to me to be the hysteria
that gripped this country
during the impeachment proceedings of
last year
in the impeachment proceeding well of
course what they what they lack there
see
the thing we had going for the mccarthy
people
was
china
when china went communist in 1949
it proved that
you see china and the united states have
had a very curious relationship we
poured in
more money to save the chinese soul
than any other country in the world
the christian churches were were
taking their little chinese brethren to
heaven
for the last 150 years
and that those people all by themselves
would elect to be communists were simply
not possible
so what it had to be it had to be
a foreign conspiracy run by the russians
to overthrow christianity and good
government and put in this vile
communist dictatorship once that had
happened in 49
the lid was off here
it was actually a broadcast by mccarthy
who
had a map of russia on the screen
and then they moved the map over these
were pretty primitive television days
they literally moved the map over and
then they added china
and uh he said now these two masses of
the earth's surface
are communists and edward r murrow is a
member of the american civil liberties
union
that's what he literally said right
there's a great essay on morrow in this
book that i urge you to read and
what did i have to do with anything
well nothing of course
but people
sitting out there in the darkness of the
middle west
would say
oh
china went communist and moro is a
member of the american civil liberties
union
there must be some connection
of course there is money
but if you try to say that in 1951 52 53
it could cost you your job
it could cost you your promotion in an
academic environment
it could do all sorts of terrible things
to your life because the idea of a
conspiracy got to be holy
to some people it is still holy
and once that sets in it is practically
impossible to blast it out
you cannot tell people that
this was not a conspiracy this was just
joe and sam and harry
independently coming to these
conclusions
uh the left does the same thing of
course
there's a right conspiracy to do god
knows what
now what they did with with clinton was
it was very curious to me
they began to dig around
in his sexual life
in a practically pornographic way
but
that originated in salem in 1692 of
course
in 1692
the
the the deans of christianity
examined girls
private parts as they said for signs of
molds or any kind of mark that would
indicate
that the devil had touched them
of course there was a hell of a
wonderful
occupation to have
and this
this these sexual examinations were very
important
uh they were
in many cases
quite decisive
uh
sex is not very far away from this sense
of
a pervasive
hidden evil
with which
good people are constantly
surrounded
and have to battle against at all costs
and at all times
uh so there's a religious dimension to
the whole business
you see the devil is the arch
conspirator in the christian religion
as well as in the muslim religion
and to some extent the jewish religion
but the devil is the arch conspirator
he uh
infiltrates
decent society by quietly
insinuating himself into the minds of
innocent people who are good people
and they don't know it but they are
being manipulated by him until finally
they begin to enjoy it once they begin
to enjoy it they become
open
agents
of the devil
and that is a religious
so-called concept
anybody who stands up and says
jesus i don't think so
is in danger
he's in danger because he's the enemy of
god they can't be god without the devil
there has to be a conspiracy to create
evil
and why because you need god
as the opposite
god is inconceivable without the devil
and so
uh this whole
political concept of a conspiracy has
very profound roots
and is all but impossible
to imagine disappearing
well also china hasn't disappeared as a
target
of uh the new whatever it is whatever is
going on now and the win holy case
in you know where this atomic scientist
was
put away for for a year without yeah
nine months is it would be another
example and uh
which uh so
let me uh
we'll come back to that but let me take
you through a couple of the other
dominant
themes in your book and then see where
they take us
you have an essay in in there called
making crowds
about mcgovern and the democratic
convention of 1972
in miami
and
you say a number of things there that
seem to have some resonance
for today or maybe they don't and maybe
that's too bad but
but could you say a word about what you
mean by this phenomenon of making crowds
because
you describe it as something that a real
political leader
who catches on does or has it's a
quality of his relationship to to his
audience and i look at today's race and
the only person i see making crowds is
ralph nader does this mean that we're
going to be stuck with george bush for
four years
that's an interesting question
i wonder sometimes whether uh
let's put it this way the present race
is very boring to most people
and
brought it up one of the reasons i think
is that
we find it hard to conceive that either
one of them
is a decisive player
in history
you see uh when you looked at kennedy
whether
i found it
when he first ran i was of two minds
about him but
i voted for him and i thought
at the time that
for reasons i couldn't put my finger on
he was a decisive person in this
in this race
a few of our leaders are decisive you
can't imagine
america without fdr
you can't imagine
america without uh kennedy
can't imagine america even without
truman
but it's easy to imagine america with
most without most american presidents
they could be replaced by any number of
other people
and you would hardly know the difference
and i get the feeling that these two
leaders
are of the kind
that don't make crowds
that is
they don't create devotion
and they don't create
that mysterious
quality
of belief
that may or may not have any good reason
for it but it exists or it doesn't exist
nader
who i am not going to vote for
is
probably the closest we've got at the
moment because he represents something
that is unique
at this moment that is it's an
anti-corporate image
and both of the other people are in bed
with the corporations we all know that
and
[Applause]
the differences between them
i think are important but they're not of
the kind
that
give you the feeling that the devil and
god are involved here
put it that way
uh
in important elections elections that
are decisive you do get the feeling
there's almost a religious
dimension to it that if this guy doesn't
get in
uh the washington dome will collapse
you don't get that feeling with either
of them
you get the feeling the washington dome
has already collapsed
and that they're they're really
administrators of some agenda that
will be of importance but it won't be
decisive it won't carry us over the way
it won't change
our souls and uh you're not worried
about the court and
i am very worried about the courts i
think it's uh unlike nader i think
that his viewpoint that
it doesn't matter whose election elected
is
if you were to carry that logically
backwards
well uh did it matter that kennedy beat
nixon
did it matter that roosevelt beat two or
three other
opponents
i think it did yes
i think that there are moments in
history when
the nature of a single individual
can change
life
and that in these two cases three cases
i've mentioned
they probably did right so it's not a
case of if this guy doesn't get elected
everything will collapse it's a case of
if that guy does get elected everything
that's good okay now you say elsewhere
in in one of your essays that
uh there's never been a new movement be
it abolition or the new deal or wilson's
new democracy which didn't first arrive
in the heads of intellectuals
do you is do you think nader uh
although you're not voting for him and
he's not going to get elected and he may
or may not be a spoiler do you think
that he is uh
has within ushering in he's probably
ushering in a populist
movement
my argument with him is you don't start
a third party three months before an
election
this is not serious
it just isn't serious it's simply going
to
possibly defeat gore
but it's not a serious movement
if you want to be serious about a third
party you start the day after the
election right okay
arthur what i want to do i want to go to
a few other of the dominant themes in
your book and take a few questions from
the audience we can
uh
you
uh
you talk about human rights and human
rights is obviously a deep concern of
yours and you've traveled around the
globe on behalf of dissident writers and
uh
folks whose rights have been violated
there is this
counter
movement that talks about cultural
relativity and argues that human rights
is a western imperial notion and do you
could you talk about that and say give
us your thoughts on that and female
circumcision
and other um
things that appear to us
to be abominations and
my small experience which is probably
larger than most people's
with various
human rights problems
in most of the east european countries
and in china
i
if you talk to the journalists
they begin to talk about cultural
relativity
if you talk to the victims there is no
such thing
uh nobody wants to go to jail
for what he's written i don't care
whether he's chinese or eskimo or
a resident of the upper bronx
uh this is nonsense
the
the desire to be free
is not a western invention
the idea that it's a western invention
is a western invention
i i don't agree with that at all i
i think there are
i work from my own experience which is a
limitation as well as a a way of
of liberating yourself from
from nonsense
and uh my plays are done literally all
over the world
they've done in many different languages
they're done by people who don't
who've never sat in an automobile
and i can only tell you that the
reaction is exactly the same
anywhere
as it is here
now how's that possible
if there is such a difference between
the western culture and the other
cultures
it isn't it's that there are different
degrees of
social
arrangements between people for example
in china
son doesn't call us
dad pop
or the equivalent
he's got a certain formulaic way of
saying his father's or his mother's or
his grandfather's name
but once he said that
that's that
the emotions that go on
are perfectly clear to them
they don't feel at all strange
i i think that uh
there's a lot of of uh
foolishness about written about these
subjects that i can't agree with from my
own
experience
your plays
they're done all over the world they're
done here
you uh a number of years ago were um a
leading
uh force for our having a national
theater why don't we have one
have you given up on that dream
what happened to lincoln center
well we don't have one probably won't
certainly in my lifetime or probably
anybody's lifetime here
national theater means a theater which
has some kind of a
[Music]
federal in our case federal or state
subsidy
which would uh help defray the costs of
doing
important or serious work
i think
there are good and bad reasons for it
one of the bad reasons is that we don't
think
that
anything deserve
our attitude is if the thing is valuable
people are going to want to pay to pay
to see it
if they don't want to pay to see it the
government shouldn't pay to help defray
the expenses
this is the bottom line philosophy
the fact that
we defray the expenses of symphony
orchestras ballets
art museums
all the rest of that
doesn't change the thing in relation to
the theater where indeed
some people make a lot of money
most people don't
so that isn't
the point of it all it's not a question
of making money it's question of
supporting
uh good stuff
because
theater production is terribly expensive
and as of
i don't know what 10 years ago
our great broadway
theater was unable any longer
to produce a new straight play
and it has not done so
in something like a decade
what they can do sometimes is import a
play from england or maybe from another
theater outside of new york city but
they cannot originate
a play anymore
now this is the end of the road for that
type of
of financing
in other words
private financing will not produce
straight plays
in this city on a professional level
uh
so what's the answer well
we go off-broadway that's fine
the problem with off-broadway is
supposing i presented the crucible to an
off-broadway theater which has 300 seats
or 200
and there's 18 characters in the play
and four sets
they can't do that play
it's impossible
so that play doesn't get done so the
nature of the
play and this is what
i
mainly concerns me
the nature of drama changes
it gets smaller and smaller and smaller
and smaller
its themes become
less and less
public
and more and more
elitist
and the old strength of our great
theaters in the greatest times of the
theater which is in greece and
elizabethan england
is foregone
these were public theaters
these were gigantic theaters
where a whole community
was in that theater there were 14 000
seats in some of them
we can't get 140 seats
now you you you've got 140 here tonight
i mean it's a
it finally
kills
what you
could call any kind of heroic
theater
and
we've got a whole generation now
or more than that
which have never experienced this kind
of theater
they don't know it exists
and that's too bad
it means a diminution
of the strength of this
great great form of art
well this is a man who is for the
federalization of the theater but for
the privatization of executions
and the privatization of the congress
now you want to say a word arthur about
there's a piece in this book about why
we don't privatize executions because
they're so popular
and uh we we could have executions that
chase ate him
and uh probably get two or three hundred
dollars a seat
uh to watch somebody getting killed
uh the other one is
the privatizing of congress which would
mean that we finish up
this nonsense of elections and of
the the parties
and simply have people who represent
general motors and another one
who openly represents uh the mining
industry and another one who openly
represents
whatever uh the
senator
the senator from boeing and uh
have them come right out and say they
were paid by these people to run and
hope that you would give vote for them
because incidentally they would take
care of your business
and uh
why we do that
well we've all but done it
accepting we don't admit we've done it
that's another piece in this
book
arthur uh i assume you did not want to
do a reading tonight which is why i'm
here
but okay
so so i'm not going to ask you to read
your piece on rain but i'm going to
invite all of you when you go and buy
your copies of the book to read this
piece on rain it's very short it's
brilliant piece on on
on red i want to read one little thing
and then i want to invite those of you
who would like to ask a question to come
to this microphone in the center
not to make a speech but to ask a
question
and if you're lucky we'll let you ask it
but first let me just tell you one of my
favorite pieces in this collection
arthur it's called on true identity
and it's about francis knight who at the
time was no laughing matter this was a
woman for
who for a generation
was in charge of deciding who was worthy
enough to receive the united states
passport she decided he wasn't for five
years i believe and so he had to stay
here and she and she had now conceived
of what what arthur miller calls an
awesome idea she proposes that every
american be required to carry a card of
identity then he goes on he says that a
person might really be identified by a
government-issued card is a breathtaking
thought whose clear simplicity brings to
naught the labors of philosophers and
poets from socrates to freud and and
back to shakespeare who aside from
eating spent their time doing nothing
but trying to identify people
personally it would end the waste of a
good half of my day during which it
seems to me i am in one way or another
trying to nail down who i am
okay
now
i have a
a final a final question
to nail down who you are arthur and then
you guys are invited or i'll keep going
but uh
could you tell us the meaning of your
the title of your essay i which i read
and i'm still struggling with the
meaning of it gardening as a moral
occupation
well
if you are a person who lives
with
who has enough ground to have a
garden
it's a source of great guilt
because when spring comes and you know
it's perfectly pointless to be
planting again since you can go to the
store and buy everything pretty fresh
uh you try to avoid planting
and then the good weather starts to come
and the sun comes out and
the earth begins to open up
and uh you begin to feel uh guilty
so you go out there like an idiot and
start digging up the place and planting
seeds and
hoping the weeds won't eat it all up
and this is a moral dilemma
that
people like me go through
every year
and succumb to planning again
wondering of course all the time why
we're doing this
and that's about it
okay does anyone here have a question
okay
uh why don't you give us your name ask
your question uh my name is ben and i
was wondering if you could say something
about the consolidation of mass media in
terms of what you were saying about the
tendency towards conspiracies
you know
in my lifetime the
media have always been consolidated it's
just that
uh
well i'll give you a quick
example
of what i mean
by media you don't just mean television
no i mean the whole thing the whole
thing
uh
i went to russia in uh whatever it was
gorbachev was still
there
in fact he had just come into power
and i was invited by other writers in
russia whom i knew
and there was some french and germans in
english and so on it was the first
meeting
of writers from abroad which was not
supervised by the communist party it was
the beginning of some free
exchange in russia and we went we spent
a week or so
a few days so kicking things around and
we got an invitation to come
to moscow and meet mr gorbachev which
was
at that time it was an amazing thing so
we all
went to moscow and went to this
central committee headquarters in a big
skyscraper and there he was
and uh to make a long story short he
talked about what he thought
and what he thought was that marxism was
no longer valid
in its 19th century form
that there had to be severe changes in
the philosophy
because marx knew nothing about atomic
energy or a lot of other stuff that we
take for granted now and that
change
profound change in the nature of the
philosophy had to be accepted
that's in brief anyway i thought it was
an astonishing statement by the head of
the communist party so it would be like
the pope saying
catholicism was not what it was supposed
to be
anyway i got back to new york and i had
taken notes which i never do
and
because i realized he was saying
something extraordinary
and i had a friend named harrison
salisbury who was once an editor of the
new york times
who lived down the road from me and i
told him this he said this is a major
scoop
this is incredible you've got to write
this so i wrote a quick resume of that
uh little meeting and uh
he sent it to the new york times
and they wouldn't print it
so he couldn't believe it
and so he sent it to the washington post
and they wouldn't print it
he couldn't believe that either
well what was the answer
there was a party line
there was a concrete belief that
anything like this could not really be
coming from the head
of the soviet union
the devil in short could not be speaking
like a rabbit
impossible
so i said but i was sitting there and
this is what the man was saying and
there were 11 other writers in the room
from 11 other countries
and they all heard the same goddamn
thing
the answer was
i
finally ended up writing all this for
who
forbes magazine
now
i think it's in the current edition the
answer was you should have sent it to
the nation
next question
but i want to ask speaking of
consolidation of
information right i want to ask a
follow-up of ben's question but then
we'll get the next that is that there
used to be
scores of major publishers in this
country and i was sitting with a former
editor-in-chief of one of them who said
right now there are three publishers
three major publishers left and two of
them are german
and you have written
uh a great deal in this book and
elsewhere about
germany the germans and your own
thoughts about thinking about the
germans and i wonder whether what you
think this means about the future of our
literary culture if anything we have to
learn how to speak german okay okay yeah
okay next
i have an a political question and
that's that i have the one children's
book that you've written and it's never
mentioned anywhere it's rarely listed on
your bibliography and i'm just curious
if you'd like to talk about it or talk
to it at all what it was what it meant
and why it just disappeared
well why does anything just be i suppose
when i wrote that book i wrote it on a
bet this is a children's book
which louie under meyer a poet and and
what would you call him
an anthology
uh
anthologizing yeah anthologist
uh said would you write a children's
book for a series we're going to put out
which
any i think he said you could use 220
words
and he gave me a list of the words that
they could use
i said if i can do that in an hour i'll
do it so i did it and uh they published
it
and when it got reviewed in the
new york times
it was the whole series was attacked
because none of these writers were
children's writers there was william
cerroyan at the time
there was a steinbeck that was i can't
remember who
and
the professional children's writers were
up in arms against this whole thing and
they managed to really kill it
so uh that's the only thing i can think
of
my name is john francis fox and i
consider you to be our greatest living
playwright um two two and a half years
ago i saw an excellent production of
death of a salesman at the paper mill
playhouse and i heard that you weren't
happy with that particular production um
can you explain why you were unhappy
with that production
i didn't see that oh
i didn't see it
i i was
i was just wondering what can
young theater goers and young theater
makers today do
to reopen the potential you were talking
about earlier that's being closed down
for the possibility of new theater
i wish
i could be
clear and optimistic about that
i mean a playwright
can't control the theater obviously
you have to deal with the theaters as
they exist
at the same time
you don't want to betray your own vision
by writing something which you don't
believe in
if you i suppose i could only ask you to
do what's in your heart to
do even if it seems quixotic
even if it seems crazy to attempt such a
thing
uh as i'm speaking i think back uh not
that i'm the example because a lot of
other people had to do the same thing
you know the old days there was no
off-broadway
uh there were broadway producers who
were as crass and commercial as they are
today
and uh
when your young guy came up with a play
he had to get it on broadway or it
didn't exist
and that was tough
because broadway always had a certain
kind of standard of entertainment
uh and uh
i wrote a play my first attempt in new
york because i'd written plays in
michigan where i went to school
which was about the conquest of mexico
no less
i think it must have had 30 characters
in them
on broadway at that time if you had six
characters they began to tremble that
this was overpopulated
it never occurred to me that this was uh
impractical it turned out to be totally
impractical
but
and i hesitate to advise anybody to
waste a year doing something which is
never going to get on stage
we did have in those days i should add
the federal theater
which went out of business shortly after
i
started writing plays but they would
have done it
probably
but they had these hordes of unemployed
actors
so they loved the idea of big
productions so you can't keep everybody
busy
uh
i don't know i think we're condemned for
a time anyway
to this closet drama
this
miniaturized theater
with its short breaths instead of big
inhales of
wind after all the one of the
one of the most innovative and
uh important works of our
era now was was
the play about aids you know
the big one angels in america well he
couldn't get that on here that was done
in england
that was done at the national theater in
england
nobody would do that play here i mean
that says something about the united
states doesn't
about our culture
you won't find it discussed in the new
york times i'm afraid but that is where
we are
that a big
deep breathing play like that
had to go
3000 miles across the ocean to get a
production
so uh you've asked a tough question i
don't know the answer to it
last question i have the last question
how are you tonight
that's not my question
um
i just started a master's program at a
local acting school in the city
uh for my thesis program i was planning
on writing my own play
now i have experience acting i have
experience directing i've never done
writing so i'm looking for one piece of
advice from you
stop right there
so
no
nobody ever gave a writer good advice
it doesn't exist
you've got to struggle with this thing
or
not uh it's got to obsess you or it
doesn't
and uh
nobody promised you a rose garden
what else can i tell you
but having said that the last question
let me just say that you also wrote
with that downbeat piece of observation
you also wrote in my case anyway
a return from abroad always yields a
faintly surprising experience of hope
and that's what you've given us tonight
and i really want to thank you
okay
thank you all for joining us this
evening
mr miller was gracious enough to sign
copies of echoes down the corridor
they're available on the table in the
back and from the cashiers on the first
floor again thank you for joining us
arthur miller was born in new york city
in 1915 and studied at the university of
michigan his plays include death of a
salesman the crucible and the price
he's twice won the new york drama critic
circle award and in 1949 the pulitzer
prize
his book echoes down the corridor is
published by viking press division of
penguin putnam
[Music]
author and playwright arthur miller died
on thursday at the age of 89.
in 2001 he sat down with harper's
editor-in-chief lewis lapham to discuss
his book on politics and the art of
acting
this is 45 minutes
good evening thank you for your patience
and welcome welcome all of you to barnes
noble union square it is my very great
privilege and pleasure this evening to
welcome one of america's greatest
playwrights and foremost public
intellectuals mr arthur miller who is
joined as you can see in conversation
this evening by mr lewis lapham essayist
broadcaster author and editor of
harper's magazine
in fact this book
on politics and the art of acting
originated as an essay in harper's
magazine
in 1949 mr miller won the pulitzer prize
for the death of a salesman
his many great dramas include the
crucible
and a view from the bridge
and a plethora of plays which are now
part of the american canon
he's also the author of two novels focus
and the misfits which was memorably
filmed
in 1960
mr miller will be awarded the national
book award medal
for distinguished contribution
to american arts and letters on november
14th
at the national book awards
mr miller is here this evening primarily
to discuss his latest book
on politics and the art of acting
please join me in welcoming mr arthur
miller and mr lewis
[Music]
[Applause]
all right i'm going to give you a chance
to say anything you want the the
essay
appeared
in the magazine it's a brilliant essay
and the
i gather from it that
louder i i'm supposed to have a
microphone
[Music]
so i think you have to talk to the
technician who maybe will
give it more life
that done
[Music]
the premise of the essay is for the book
is that we
live under a government of images
and that
the art of performance
is the art of politics and the
politician
either succeeds or fails
in his capacity as an actor
would you care to begin with that
[Music]
if you hear me now
you'll hear me now
well i can't talk that long
use the microphone
or maybe i'll be better
how's that
[Applause]
yeah i think that
it's not a particularly original idea
but uh it occurred to me many times
watching
television
uh during the last electoral campaign
the last presidential campaign
that what we were watching was a kind of
acting
and because
i couldn't detect any real conflict of
issues
which is what a debate is supposed to be
about
uh there rather than issues
both
men were trying to occupy it seem to me
the same
space
uh
gore
after all
tried to
find the proper costume
for quite a while
and apparently never succeeded in
fighting
uh bush
was dressed okay
but uh you couldn't detect
really what he was proposing
and indeed what he the few details that
he happened to mention in the course of
the debates in the campaign were
as soon as he was elected were
immediately contradicted by what he did
so that
more and more one begins to look at
these
as performances
and the nature of performance of course
is to
persuade an audience whether it's an
actor or a politician
he has to believe you have to believe
he's real
this goes for anybody who's
doing hamlet
or who's running for the presidency
you got to believe
that he believes what he's doing
and that it's really him
that's speaking
of course
bush never achieved that in my opinion
you always got the feeling
that it had all been programmed it had
been
completely scripted
and that at best he had mastered
his script
you could hear the points being made
gore was a little more
uh in command that way
but he was
terribly awkward obviously and i think
it's because he was trying to occupy
space
and to create a character
that probably wasn't his
uh interestingly
the one time
that he got real
gore
the press came down on him
it was during a so-called debate
when he uh
without any words the camera caught him
raising his eyebrows and throwing his
glance toward the ceiling
as
in reaction to some immanity that bush
had said
and uh
that's when he was real
that was really
him
and the press
came down on him like a ton of bricks
they thought he was being super serious
they thought he was being arrogant
but all he was being was himself
and uh
so that the political commentary now is
is really like theatrical criticism
they they criticize the performance
[Music]
of the politician
and the question of his positions or the
debate on the issues
is long since
gone by
it's not what it's about it's about
the persuasiveness of the performance no
matter what he's saying
and i found that very disturbing
i didn't mean to make a speech it's just
that i got up
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
if i ask another question can anybody
hear it or do i have to get up to them
i don't want to make a speech though
are you going to have to continue to get
up to make speeches
i don't know if they can hear me back
i mean can we hold the microphone
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
now
can we can you hear me now
what
like that
[Music]
hello
no good
does this one work
yes
this one works all right arthur you you
in
in the book you talk about the
star power
and you say that uh some actors have
star power and it is the
capacity to instill
fear that's how you would define a star
and that some
politicians
can achieve the same
feeling of dread in other words they
make the audience it isn't whether the
audience will love
the politician but will the politician
deign to love the audience
that's the way you define a star
well i i do think that
many of our
really leading
politicians such as
lbj or roosevelt or kennedy
uh there have been a number of others
nixon had it
uh there's a quality of
dangerousness
in him
he can't be a totally nice guy
he's the kind of a man who you
are happy to think that he likes you
and
there possibly is a good reason for that
because what we depend on in a political
leader
especially a president
is that he'll kill for us
when it's necessary
you don't want anybody up there who's
going to quail before the necessity of
murdering people
we need that
he's got to be a killer
and the great presidents
so-called have all been involved in war
i'm talking about washington
woodrow wilson
lbj
roosevelt
you name them
they're all
involved in war
and
truman was
if
he is not willing
to
shed blood
we're afraid of him
we don't feel protected
by him
and consequently he has to have that
element in his makeup
and uh even if he never goes to war or
he tries to avoid war
as certainly carter did
and uh
it's interesting about carter carter was
doing all right until he failed
in war
the unhappy and tragic accident where
the collision killed some flyers
did him in
he had not succeeded
in being aggressive enough
it failed as a war leader
this is terribly important now
because
bush
clearly
is behaving as he has to
as a war leader
uh it has changed
i think probably all the
the calculations about him
i
i personally think his
ineptitude remains but
he
[Music]
[Applause]
he has to make
really
world shaking decisions
so one leans toward the hope
that he's right
and that he's capable of doing this
i certainly feel that way i feel i i
pray that
he doesn't make too many blunders
because we're all involved in this
uh so it changes the nature of the
leadership and of the leader as actor
now he's
a different kind of an actor
he was rather comical before
and now there's a tragic cast
over everything he says and does
because it involves
death
i still find
bush unconvincing i still think of him
as the the candidate who was trying to
play in your words the part of bing
crosby i i can't
get past that
notion so
even though
he is moving carriers and sending planes
i still he does not instill in me the
feeling of dread
but
how much of the part
of the president it depends on the
office itself
in other words take
clinton
i can remember seeing clinton in the
white house and feeling
that he was a true president and then
seeing him
uh at a cocktail party in new york after
he was out of office and he had lost
in my
feeling
the entire
part the costume was gone
so how much of it is the
in the man himself and how much of it is
in the
the proscenium or the stage
well obviously the
the difference
is tremendous between
being a citizen and being the president
of the united states
the citizen can't kill that many people
the president of the united states has
the faith
whether he knows it or not of the world
in his hands
he commands our atomic
bombs
the army and the navy the submarines all
that stuff
he is the commander-in-chief
and once he's out of office he's simply
another guy
in a suit
and that's a big difference
it's a bit like the theater though when
you see uh somebody playing
whatever
king richard or
henry or whichever
and he's clothed in these wonderful
garments that
lend him
majesty and then he steps out of it
and he's got narrow shoulders and a
potbelly and
his complexion isn't all that good
it's different story
so what my point of the whole thing is
is that i'm wondering whether we will
ever get back to discussing issues
and we will ever get out of the theater
in the politics of this time
we've always been in a theater in my
opinion there's always been a theatrical
element
because where power is concerned
the theater enters
there's no there's no that's not a new
story
but
i keep thinking back of reading about
the
lincoln douglas debates
when for three or four hours these two
candidates were standing in a broiling
sun and
debating
what to do
about the country
and they had no microphones and they had
to have large gestures i'm sure because
they were talking to people spread out
across a wide pasture
and
the issues it seems you can read the
proceedings of the debates
the word paramount
i don't think the issues are paramount
anymore
they have these little sound bites
which indicate that uh
for example bush was not going to do any
nation
building well we're building nations now
uh
i i could go down a long list but i've
forgotten him
of things he was not going to do and
what he was going to do and if
as lawful and as not it has no relevance
to what he's had to do
they are now subsidizing
insurance companies when the government
was not supposed to get in mixed up in
business
it's all backwards
but this isn't new you know roosevelt
came into power as a conservative
he was calling for a balanced budget
and within six months he was spending
more money than any president in the
history of the world
because he had to
or the country would have collapsed
and this guy has to do what he has to do
so it all gets down to being fitter
and
we have to begin i think
to ask the old questions what does he
really
stand for
what are we voting for
perhaps i should tell that story this in
the book of the actor
who uh
i had an old friend who's
gone now bobby lewis who directed a lot
of wonderful broadway productions
and as a young actor in the 30s he was a
dresser for a great yiddish actor named
jacob benami
and benami was in a yiddish play
which attracted a lot of people who
never who
didn't know any yiddish
because of one scene
and in that scene
it was down on second avenue and it took
a lot to get people to go to second
avenue to see a yiddish play but the
place was mobbed because of one scene
he uh
stood on the edge of the stage
with a revolver at his head
trying to
shoot himself
and
he was so convincing that people really
thought he was about to shoot himself
and
audiences would simply come to see that
scene and then leave because they didn't
understand yuge
and
bobby who was an aspiring young actor
asked him how he did that how he managed
to make this
so real
and bonami said i'm not going to tell
you because if i do it'll get out and
it'll ruin the show but when the show is
over i'll tell you
well the show was over
and bobby said well now tell me
and benami said well
i had a problem with this scene
because i'm not suicidal i can't imagine
putting a bullet in my head
so i try to think of a parallel in my
life
that would where a situation where i
would be alone
standing up
and trying to do something that i simply
was horrified at having to do and
finally
i can't do it
and i
thought
what i'm really doing what i should
really do up there
is imagine that i'm trying to step into
a nice cold shower
[Music]
i said because i hate cold water
well who are we voting for
is it the guy who's standing there
putting a bulletin's head
or somebody who's trying to get into the
cold shower
you talk about the um
not the failure to discuss issues at any
length in sound bites
and that brings up the question of
television because now the
politicians are playing to the camera
they are by definition
forced to speak in sound bites i mean
the television can't really deal with
long issues or
complexity
and so
you also discuss in this essay the
the kind of a character that does well
on television which is a
bland or
cool
it's a
non-committal not too
dramatic so
the kind of person who doesn't
go into a passion
certainly doesn't write his own speeches
so what
what does that mean for
the acting i mean we're now talking
about a
a television actor
or actress who has to
be
a certain type and what is that type
uh i think in general that
the television
treats more
the television treats more kindly the
cooler
personality
uh
it exaggerates
any gesture
any facial movement
and consequently
the politician who wants to succeed
wants to be as cool as possible while
seeming absolutely sincere
in short we're getting further and
further away from any human being
it all gets to be
a
kind of mannerism if you look at the the
uh
tomboco or
any of the others
the idea behind their performances and
they are performances
is that they are unflinching
they're just unflinching
well ladies and gentlemen the world
ended yesterday at three o'clock in the
afternoon
that kind of thing
and uh
the those those of us who are left
have the responsibility of building it
all up again
uh
it seems to me we get further and
further away from reading what that man
is
and that really is what we're trying to
do in an election
we're trying to read what he is really
like
and i think the television
has made it
a little more difficult
to do that
it was never easy
but uh when
people are up in front of a crowd a real
crowd
and they have to react to the crowd
and not to
a cameraman and a director
it's a different situation
he's on his metal
he's got to a different part of his
brain is working
he's going to reveal himself a little
more it seems to me
i think that we're throwing a blanket
over
the people
in front of that camera rather than
revealing very much
about them
and that's i wonder about that
where that leaves the democracy
and whether
it uh
simply homogenizes everything so that
one guy can be
substituted for another because they're
all equally
equally cool i can't really say that i
prefer brokaw over somebody else
they're all reading the same news
and they're all one is as cool as the
next one
so it becomes uh a kind of
passion play or greek theater where they
wear masks and costumes and we're not
we're electing
uh instead of a president in a
democratic sense we're electing a
pontifex
maximus or we're
electing a priestly figure who will
carry out
ritual
uh observances who will make
the sounds that reassure us
and we know less and less about
who is behind the mask
and maybe
does that matter i mean we we get our
first
movie actor in reagan i mean
20 40 years ago the notion of a movie
actor becoming president of the united
states would have seemed to me
impossible
and now i expect to see
more and more actors and if somebody
asked me
i want to go into politics where should
i go should i go to the kennedy school
of government i would say no go to an
acting school
if it if we're not a democracy
then
what kind of
government did we become with
this sort of
uh pageant
we put on a
pageant called democracy land
and people play the assigned part
i think that what
one of the things that's got to be drawn
from all this discussion is that
first of all people become conscious
that they are watching acting
because they are
and secondly that they begin to demand
the issues
that they begin to demand where these
people really differ from one another if
indeed they do
uh
that was my worry when i started to
write this essay
that it had all been homogenized
and that we
couldn't possibly make a
an intelligent decision between one or
the other because neither one was really
willing
to enter a true debate about where he
stood
there were a few sound bites
uh interestingly they started talking
about a lock box
suddenly
some
speech writer had cooked up this idea
that they were going to put social
security in a lock box
and first gore started with the locks
box
and then pretty soon
the other guy started with the lock box
it was such a good idea that he couldn't
let it go because it was an image
we're going to put social security in a
lockbox
of course it's observed social security
is part of the whole budget and then
you're never going to be in a lockbox
it
is disgustingly
all
symbolic
it's full of symbolisms and
little painted pictures
and uh
as i say
in a way
bush became more like a democrat as this
administration has proceeded
he's spending more money on stuff
than he promised to do
if you listen to him when he first got
elected
we were going to have no foreign
relations at all
he simply had obliterated the rest of
the world the united nations the whole
shooting match
was all over you might as well just
recall all the ambassadors
and that lasted 20 minutes because
the world
needed the united states
and the united states needed the world
as
somebody must have known there
or maybe they didn't
i don't know
but all i'm trying to say is that
we never got
to the issues
gore never raised this problem
in the to the extent that it should have
he
confronted with the
bush saying he wasn't going to build
nations new nations
he should have
grappled with that
he should have taken that up as a
challenge
but the idea of the campaign was to not
take anything up as a challenge because
it might
awaken the audience
and so they slept through it and
you know the closeness of the election
simply testifies to the fact that no
choice was made
they simply fell into one box of the
other box
and i think it's due
basically to the fact that there was no
debate
there were no choices that could be made
since it was all acting
in the essay you referred to
clinton the unclean as being the most uh
clinton yeah the as the the candidate
most
closely allied with the
the american citizen the common man
taught and i think what you had to say
about clinton was um
illuminating so maybe if you could
remember
his
likeness to brer rabbit it would be
nice to know
i think uh
clinton was the most uh
authentic of them all
that is to say he came closest
to coming over
the way he is
that is he loves to perform
both bush and and uh and gore
were clearly uncomfortable in front of
the camera
he got the feeling they were awkward
because they didn't want to be
there clinton loves to be there
he likes acting
he said he likes acting
and one felt
connected with him because he was full
of joy standing there and telling his
stuff
i i thought he did the best performance
of all of them
in recent years
because he did seem
you could read him
and you could read him
i think the american people were very
wise they weren't panicked by all his
shenanigans they
loved him for his sins
because
they were real
they were real sins
and you could connect with that
gore never committed a sin
certainly bush never did
[Music]
clinton was the center and you you
really could say i think i know that guy
you know he's uh in the book i talk
about him being our
till oilings beetle
you know oil and spiegel
which strauss made a wonderful tone poem
about was a
i think it's the 9th or 8th century
german
uh mythological figure
oil and spiegel means
owl's mirror
and
he was a mythological figure in medial
germany
who
tricked
rulers
he could rep he could tell a ruler that
he lied he was the kind of a clown
and of course an oiling spiegel a an old
mirror an owl is blind in daytime
so when he looks into the mirror he
doesn't see anything
and clinton was like that
[Music]
he he lacked
a vision of his inner self
and uh
it's also we have an american version of
it a kind of in one sense prayer rabbit
a prayer rabbit
gets into your garden and eats all the
lettuce
but when you come
to capture him or shoot him
he starts telling you a hell of a story
and the story is so charming
that you are beguiled and before you
know it he's down a hole and he's gone
uh
i think that this last campaign was so
boring because nobody loved anybody
there was no real affection
for either of these candidates which is
interesting
the only one that really generated
affection was nader but he led his
troops right into the hole by
getting the enemy elected
bush
and i think that uh
this uh
lack of affection
made it very boring you
there is a shakespearean play where
which occurred to me
corey elena's
which is remarkable as a piece of
playwriting and as poetry but it's
rarely performed relatively because
there is no love in it
he is a true
it is a true picture of a certain kind
of a personality
who is simply driven by power
and his only
affection if you can call it that is for
his mother
he has no relation with anybody else
excepting to manipulate them
and as i say
he's really it's rarely performed
because people can't stand it
they can't bear watching this
monster
even though he's surrounded with the
most glorious poetry that shakespeare
wrote
because you don't really finally
care
and i think in this last time around
the acting
was so neutralized
that uh
we didn't care finally
and uh
it showed in the in the final tally we
just
dismissed both of them
in effect
before
this book
before the before the book there was an
essay and before the essay there was the
jefferson lecture this
before it became an essay arthur
delivered the jefferson lecture last
year at the national endowment for the
humanities which is the same
more or less text
and it was
attacked very
violently in the washington post by
george will do you remember the attack
on this
so you know you don't have a view as to
why it was attacked
no
well
george will
having heard
arthur deliver the lecture
wrote a column in which he
demanded that the chairman of the
national endowment man named william
ferris
resign
because ferris had allowed arthur miller
onto the stage of the national endowment
to utter
the nonsense you've just heard
and the
why
will would consider it nonsense i was
hoping arthur would tell me but i i
simply as assume that there are people
many of them in washington who do not
welcome the notion that
the politics that they take very
seriously indeed
is in fact
make-believe stagecraft
nursery school play i mean it's it's
insulting to their
self-esteem perhaps
well of course
they have to take
the thing
with dead seriousness because that's
the product of washington is politics i
mean other places produce steel and
sandwiches or something
they produce politics and they got to
take that seriously
but incidentally
uh just to finish that little picture
before i went on a stage i said to
mr ferris who was the chairman of the uh
humanities thing
well i suppose
after this you're going to get fired
and uh
he said no no he was a he had a deep
southern accent
he said no no he says uh
i'm from mississippi
and he said uh and uh what's that
mississippi politician senator
lot a lot he's a mississippi boy too
well of course he was fired about six
weeks later
last question arthur the uh
audience
with the television it seems to me the
act bush
whereas you take it back a hundred years
lincoln douglas they're talking in a
pasture in iowa illinois
and
now we have television and we used to be
a more or less domestic audience but now
you have bush having to
cast an image before the entire world i
mean he has to be persuasive in
pakistan as well as in paris as well as
in miami
does that make the act
harder does that make it even more
ritualistic
even less chance of knowing
what's in the man's mind
i would i would think so because uh
well we had a good example of what
happens when
somebody
a president
speaks
without acting
bush
was obviously very
moved
and very angry
at this attack on the two towers
and he said
we want him dead or alive
and uh
the other thing he said was this is a
crusade
and
anybody who's dealing with
the
east knows that the word crusade
means
the crusaders who came down here to
slaughter
muslims
this was a mistake but it came from his
gut
and uh so you have to ask yourself
and maybe we need better acting
it's a terribly
terribly complex
thing
the one politician that i in my lifetime
who could be authentic
and at the same time
say what was
to his interest and to the country's
interest was fdr
he was such a
nobleman
that
even when he made a mistake
you forgave it immediately because he
was so
grand and so such a star
when you're a star on that level
you can do all sorts of things
people forgive everything because
they love you
he was beloved
at his funeral
hardened correspondents were in tears
on the road
on pennsylvania avenue
and couldn't speak into the microphone
that doesn't happen very often
he was the big star
and i tend to judge everybody
by what i remember of him
not that i agreed with everything he did
but
you knew you were in
in good hands so to speak
there's no solution to this
dilemma
accepting again
i repeat
to try to
[Music]
make your way through this cloud of
performance
to what the man seems to want to do with
your country
it's terribly difficult
because they're on guard against
defending any part of the electorate
so they
keep shaving down what they want to
really do
but we must keep demanding that it seems
to me or else it's all
a kind of a show
which is uh
not very meaningful
well thank you all for coming i i can
tell you that this is a wonder i've read
this text now three times as a lecture
and uh as a magazine editor as saying as
a book and it gets better every time
it's almost as good as listening to
arthur talk
and i'm
delighted that we
had a chance to have a conversation
thank you very much
[Applause]
arthur miller won the pulitzer prize in
1949 for his play death of a salesman
his books include echoes down the carter
and focus
he died thursday night at his home in
roxbury connecticut
arthur miller was 89.
achievements in four genres
fiction nonfiction poetry and young
people's literature
it's about an hour 15 minutes
[Music]
[Applause]
good evening
[Applause]
good evening everyone
i have an apology to make to our master
of ceremonies steve martin
for the past two years
i've introduced him
in a perfunctory manner
i
have said that he was and i quote
uh the man who needs no introduction and
this is patently untrue
and actually kind of rude and i
apologize for doing that
steve has a multiplicity of talents as a
comedian as an actor
for stage tv and screen and his newest
movie novocaine in which he starts with
laura dern
and helena bonham carter opens on friday
however it is in his role as a writer
that we are most proud to welcome steve
martin here
his huge best seller shop girl
has just come out in paperback as a
matter of fact i i do happen to have a
copy here
bob miller did not ask me to hold this
book up i just doing this on my own
volition
steve wrote the play
picasso at the lap aggio
and he has adopted a 1911 german play by
carl sternheim called the underpants
which is coming to new york city eagerly
awaited next spring
and he is a work on his next novel the
pleasure of my company
we would like to thank you steve for
coming all this way especially at this
particular time especially at this
particular time
to run the show once again
in being so generous with your time and
with your obsessively creative energies
you are providing essential support for
the national book foundation
and thereby to the writing life
and to those of us like you who live
within that life
so let's give steve martin a very warm
welcome
thank you well
[Music]
[Applause]
well another perfunctory introduction
good evening and welcome to the annual
national book awards the most
prestigious and respected
acknowledgement the book can receive and
still be unknown
i'm so pleased to be standing in this
room tonight in the presence of so many
great writers so many legendary
publishers
editors agents
caterers
waiters bus boys
escort girls
neurotics
hypochondriacs whiners phone screamers
boy toys
and hotel guests who think this is a
restaurant
tonight we are here not only to present
the awards but to honor arthur miller
the great american man
[Music]
right there
the great american man of letters and
now emails
who wrote many of the greatest plays of
the 20th century death of a salesman
after the fall a view from the bridge
the crucible and of course all my
children
i i just love the episode where darla
falls in love with the dentist but he's
married to chet but the dentist is
currently seeing darla said you had to
watch every episode you just couldn't
miss one anyway
the
technical awards were given out earlier
today
and the winners will be announced later
this evening in the categories of
best spine glue
best page numbering
and best phony jacket blurb trade-off
from a friend
and by the way
[Music]
the nominees for best jacket blurb are
quote not only was it a page turner it
was a cover closer
and two if you like auto mechanics
you'll love these poems
and three this is a great summer read
thank god it's winter
now
there's been a lot of malicious
competitiveness in the book awards this
year which i just hate to see
uh the poetry category
was especially vicious
cornelius edie
was caught at the typesetters
trying to insert an extra iamb into one
of alan dugan's alexandrines
young people's literature was especially
brutal
it was reported
that marilyn nelson called kate
dicamillo a big brat
and kate responded i know you are but
what am i
but the unforgivable happened
when jonathan franzen
was caught at borders
trying to sneak an oprah sticker on look
at me
now
i got in the middle of this because i
know oprah
and i called her and asked her if i
could have jonathan's sticker for my
book
i offered to trade her two of my
stickers i have a montel and a jerry
springer
but this whole
to-do was actually
quite polite
mr franzen explained what he meant that
he wanted a more intellectual aura
around his book and oprah did not
rescind her book of the month pick
and mr franson did not appear on oprah's
show however uh next week he will be
appearing on martha stewart's good
morning wisconsin
now
i come from hollywood
where
writers are so respected that they're
sometimes referred to as
coffee
and earlier this year when i hosted the
academy awards i learned all the things
that we've been doing wrong here at the
national book awards so there will be
some changes
uh first i'd like to see a lot more
weeping
i don't read people very well and it's
the only way i can tell if you're
sincere
i think there should be more thinking of
hairdressers and stylists
and later in the evening i will be
dancing
excerpts from the nominated books all
right um
oh we made it through that now
every year at the national book awards
on behalf of the foundation's board of
directors
it is a tradition to present the medal
for distinguished contribution to
american letters
the award is given by the foundation to
an individual and i quote
who has enriched our literary heritage
during a life of service or through a
corpus of work
well thank you
this year's medal accompanied by a gift
of ten thousand dollars is underwritten
with the generosity of foundation board
member john ingram who i am inferring
must be loaded
and
ingram industries mr ingram would you
please stand
yes
tonight we gather to honor arthur miller
exemplary man of letters
fearless novelist and short story writer
outspoken topical essayist journalist
and literary critic
down to earth irreverent memoirist
versatile writer for radio tv and screen
and as if all of that were not
sufficient our greatest living
playwright
crossing the boundaries of these genres
is arthur miller's lifelong
preoccupation with the condition of men
and women joined together in common
society as he puts it
our membership in the ordinary human
race
we are trying to save ourselves
separately arthur miller has cautioned
and that is immoral
his belief in the responsibility and
obligation of the artist as a social
being he is well known for his
decades-long commitment to penn
is balanced by an unsparing commitment
to art as truth-telling equality as
eternal as the ancient greek tragedians
he has always admired yet especially
pertinent to these times
literature and art
miller says are not required to reassure
when in reality there is no assurance or
to serve up clean and wholesome stories
in all times and places
whatever he has written over seven
decades
arthur miller monitors the tempo of time
this vigilance makes his work so modern
and continuously vital
he never gives up attempting to capture
times mysterious passage whether it be
the dark history of racial and religious
repression
the dependable cycle of seasons allowing
him to plow and plant his beloved
connecticut garden
or the uneven memories of all two human
characters in his evocative magical
plays
the performer is his art miller writes
whereas the writer can step away and
leave it for the world to make of it
what he will
indeed this brief introductory praise
cannot possibly do justice to the
essence of arthur miller's dramatic
poetry so let's watch this excerpt
from the 1984 production of death of a
salesman starring dustin hoffman and
john malkovich courtesy of castle hill
productions
all the
the tape boys what's the report where'd
you go this time
we went on some phones so man
don't say tell your secret boys don't
bring it to us
someday i'll have my own business and
i'll never have to leave home anymore
like uncle charlie huh bigger than uncle
charlie because charlie is not like this
he's like but he's not well-liked
where'd you go this time well i got on
the road i went north to providence met
the man the mayor of france he was
sitting in a hotel room
he said good morning
and i said oh you gotta find city here
man they had coffee with me and then i
went to uh uh waterbury waterbury's a
fine city big clock city famous
waterbury clock sold a nice building and
in boston boston is the cradle of the
revolution flying city a couple other
towns mass now to portland bangor
straight home love to go with you
sometimes
you promise oh you're going to happen
i'll show you all the times because one
thing boys i have friends i can park my
car on any street in new england and the
cops protected like their own this
summer who brought you will take a
bathing suit they will carry a bag oh
what could be something coming to the
boston stores with you boys carrying my
bags what a sensation
nervous buff about the game not if
you're gonna beat them what do they say
about you in school now they made the
cap there's a crowd of girls around him
every time the classes change pop this
saturday just for you i'm gonna break
through for a touchdown ben if you want
supposed to take one play
pop you watch me when i take off my
helmet that means i'm breaking out and
you watch me cross through the line oh
we'd like to listen foster biff where
are you hey look at banana what are you
looking so anemic about bernard gotta
study uncle lily's got regents next week
come on let's box listen fifth i heard
mr birnbaum say that if you don't start
studying math he is gonna flunk you and
you won't graduate now i heard you
better study with it go ahead i heard
hop he didn't see my sneaker hey that's
a beautiful job of printing yeah well
just because he prints university of
virginia on his sneakers doesn't mean
they gotta graduate what are you talking
about with scholarships to three
universities they're gonna flunk him
yeah but i heard mr burns don't be a
past bernard
what an anemic
i'm waiting for you in my house
but none is not well liked is he pop
he's like but he's not wealthy that's
right i mean bernard can get the best
marks in school you want a sample when
he gets out for the business will you
understand you're gonna be five times
ahead of him
that's why i thank almighty god you both
felt like a dinosaurs because the man
who makes an appearance in the business
world a man who creates personal
interest is a man who gets ahead
be liked and you will never want
you take me for it i knew
ladies and gentlemen arthur miller
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
congratulations
that's a great battle congratulations
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you very much
uh
i'll go quick because i have 10 minutes
whenever i get up
to thank people for inviting me to speak
or accept some honor
i'm immediately assaulted by the memory
of the actress maureen stapleton
who stepped up to receive her oscar
some years back and instead of
submitting to hallowed custom by
thanking her agent her mother and father
her acting teacher a few cousins and the
doorman of her apartment house
she cleared her throat and said
i want to thank everybody i ever met
i feel something similar now probably
because when you come down to it
i'm known primarily as a playwright
and playwrights on the whole
are set slightly apart or below book
writers
i'm not sure why this is so unless it is
has something to do with how we are
described
one doesn't necess doesn't speak of book
rights
port rights
or prose rights
we alone are associated at least
nominally
with ship rights
mill rights
boat rights
this is very odd
i've written prose of course two novels
a lot of short stories several books of
repertage and so on but i'm primarily a
writer of plays and playwrights at least
in america are not generally thought of
as literary
the reason for this most probably is
that they usually aren't
we are regarded at best as hybrids
people who write to be sure but our
prose is basically functional
actors have to be
able to speak
uh words as
easily and it has to nail audiences to
their seats
perhaps it is the utilitarian
which
the utilitarian strain
upon our writing that sets it apart and
even helps denigrate it
there were for instance a number of
masterly european playwrights in the
last century
whose works have stayed alive through
the generations but were left
unconsidered for the nobel prize i'm
thinking of chekhov stringberg and ibsen
and i'll bet you can't name the novelist
anymore who did win
o'neal who was honored would probably
not have considered himself a literary
artist merely a truthful one it was more
than politeness that moved him to write
to ocasi about one of his plays
god i wish i could write like that
from one irishman to another this was a
hell of a confession
among american playwrights at least
before tennessee williams i can think of
only two in the 20th century
who manifestly try to write plays with
an eye toward literary style
one was maxwell anderson but to write
literary he had a slip on a
quasi-elizabethan disguise which to be
sure had its vogue for several years but
would probably not go down well with us
anymore because of its
artificiality
we can stand the artificial from the
british but not from locals
to most of us all british speech is
artificial so we can't tell the real
artificial from the artificial
artificial
in short we don't expect reality from
the british we expect style
for the english consciousness of
linguistic style springs from an
unshakable fascination with class
which governs speech from the top of the
social ladder down to the cockneys who
make a taunting point of artificiality
by refusing to speak like other
englishmen they are free
to invent outrageous new usages
that generally mock the proprieties of
their bettors
clifford odets was the american cockney
branding his language with his often
delightfully peculiar twists
which the critics thought came from the
bronx which were really his own
invention
nobody in the bronx ever said
i'm going out and get an eight-cylinder
sandwich
and anyway he came from philadelphia
odetsa's la dota odettes doted on
language and kept the card far with
lines he'd heard in the street
usages he would take home and do a
little carving on
when he started out odex odetz
cultivated a proletarian posture in tune
with the depression time
but he was really a literary man who
kept his recondite taste to himself lest
he frighten the critics and scare off
the broadway ticket buyers this
avoidance was more than his own
eccentric choice however american
theater distrusted the literary and in
fact until williams the american play in
effect pretended that it hadn't been
written at all but merely happened
indeed the highest complement of play
could have had was that it seemed to
have written itself
the situation has changed in recent
decades but i wonder if the basic
acknowledgement of a play author's
existence is basically as a constructor
and shaper of the action rather than
that of a word artist
it is almost but not quite the present
situation of the screenwriter
i have yet to meet anyone who went to
see a movie because it was written by
somebody
in effect playwriting was commonly
thought of as a form of engineering
engineering with laughs suspense or
tears
a play was built rather than written
this rubric i suppose is part of the
mythology
of authorial neutrality
or literary bricklaying
a bricklayer has no ulterior ideology
concerning the aesthetic or moral value
of his work
it is enough that it be plumb and level
and not fall down
if the europeans quite differently
assumed that a play of any moral or
aesthetic pretensions was inevitably
intended to mean something and was
unavoidably metaphorical the notion was
close to anathema here
if you have a message send it by western
union was the wisdom of the day
the austrians have a saying
when some calamity happens a train wreck
a collapsed bridge there's always
somebody to the remark well who knows
for who it's good
for american playwriting this aversion
to metaphorical significance exerted a
weighty pressure to suppress
speechifying about thematic significance
if any
relying upon the implications within the
action
to expand the play's general
significance a play that dared to
venture beyond this stricture was
suspect as unesthetic propaganda
that classical plays from the greeks to
shakespeare to check out were loaded
with generalizations about power society
and justice and so on
was a fact that did not interfere with
this aesthetic which itself god forbid
could not be called an aesthetic at all
but simply their only right and natural
way of regarding theater or any other
art
time magazine after all always referred
to the author of a successful play as a
crack playwright
quite as though he had peered through a
gun sight and hit the bull's eye
it was all very steely and mathematical
and of course menacing to any author
with more than pure entertainment in his
mind
the convention of the play as a species
of engineering was of course unannounced
and largely unconscious
american theater like the british had
never been other than a commercial
enterprise quite opposite to that of
europe which had developed out of a very
different circumstance
it took george bernard's shore nearly 10
years to get a british audience and
critics as so much as listened to an
ibsen play for more than a week's run
and then only by stuffing the parts with
great stars
there was always apparently an
anglo-saxon suspicion if not an aversion
to any play that parted too noticeably
from the theater of pure entertainment
in europe theater had traditionally been
subsidized by either individual
aristocrats remember lord strange's men
doing shakespeare much as music was or
by towns and cities and these sponsors
expected and indeed demanded some kind
of contemplation in at least some of the
works they were paying for
i recall a conversation i had with
thomas mann after he had seen death of a
salesman in new york
the play seemed to have somehow
distressed him but not for the obvious
reasons
he was indeed affected by it as he said
but it also apparently arose some sort
of resentment in it
they are like aborigines he said of the
characters
there is no idea coming from them
to me of course i may say so that was
precisely the triumph of the play whose
metaphor lay in its very design
in the arc of its story and the voyage
of its characters
put another way i had learned my
american theater lesson
if you have a message
send it either by western union or by
virtue of the play's inexorability
i think it was tennessee williams who
first successfully introduced our
theater to what could be called literary
writing
clearly the author of class glass
menagerie and streetcar was declaring
rather than camouflaging his writerly
presence on the stage
this stuff did not just happen nor had
it been overheard
it was a highly composed often sumptuous
language in whose writing one easily
sensed a certain authorial joy
but here i'm getting really interested
in the subject and i have to stop so
thanks again and next time it crosses
your minds to recite a playwright for
this honor please don't hesitate
it's like the great comedian fred allen
once said when one of the sponsors of
his radio show kept barging out of the
control room to excitedly suggest some
inept change in the script
after four or five such interruptions
alan his patience warm thin asked where
were you when the pages were blank
the answer of course is that the
executive may not have been aware of it
but he was waiting for a writer who god
knows may even have been a literary
fellow in disguise thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
why am i the lucky one who gets my
picture taken with them
anyway uh ladies and gentlemen before
dinner and dessert i have one more
important announcement on behalf of a
consortium of children's book publishers
led by brenda bowen of simon schuster
and paula wiseman of harcourt
well you have some fans uh brendan paul
would you please stand
[Applause]
what's interesting i guess
brenda and paula are one person
um
do we refer to you as brenda and paula
the national book foundation is
presenting in the lobby tonight a silent
auction of original children's book art
and all proceeds from this auction will
benefit the windows of hope family
relief fund providing immediate
emergency aid as well as future
scholarships and funds for the families
of the victims of the world trade center
tragedy who worked in the food services
professions so uh representing the fund
in the audience tonight are wendy malef
and darlene dwyer and i would like to
ask them to stand i think they're over
there
no
they
did i call you wendy i think i
think i called you wendy i'm sorry
um
but maybe it's a new nickname who knows
uh the silent auction will officially
close when dinner is over in about 30
minutes and now is the time to get out
there and make one more bid or increase
your bids this is a very worthy cause we
want to raise a lot of money
tonight for the windows of hope fund so
dinner is served and we will be back for
the national book awards ceremony
[Music]
could i have your attention please
okay we're ready to start
welcome back
i'm deborah wiley i'm chairman of the
national book foundation
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
i would like to officially notify
everyone that the silent auction for the
windows of hope family relief fund is
now closed to further bidding
tonight is the 52nd
national book awards ceremony before i
return to the turn sorry before i return
the podium to its rightful owner our
friend mr martin
there are some people that i would like
to thank at this time
without robust financial support
needless to say our not-for-profit
foundation cannot survive
we are in the midst of an unusually
tough economic situation right now and
so we are particularly grateful to the
extraordinary sponsorship gifts received
this year from barnes and noble
r.r donnelly
penguin putnam and random house
[Music]
and i would like to extend a very
special thank you to bloomberg for
underwriting the 2002 gold medal tour of
this year's winners
[Applause]
[Music]
the national book foundation was created
in 1989 is still a young institution
since then we have been blessed with
many loyal and hard-working board
members
i would like the many past and present
members of the board of directors in the
audience tonight to stand and be
applauded for their selfless
contributions to our mission
during the past decade and more
could you stand
[Applause]
[Music]
likewise since 1989 one art director and
one printing company have donated
endless hours of time money patience and
fortitude to producing the annual
program booklet for the awards dinner
for their perseverance and generosity we
must ask our artisan residents neil
stewart and frank capo chairman of curl
graphics to stand and accept our thanks
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
many of you in this room have worked
closely with the professional staff of
the national book foundation
these five people and yes there are only
five labor long and hard to keep our
educational programs going and to
maintain the great tradition of the
awards
please give a round of applause to
meredith andrews marianne jacobs meg
carney sherry young and neil baldwin
[Music]
[Applause]
we have our own writers on our staff
meg's first volume of poems and
unkindness of ravens was published last
month by boa editions
neil's new book henry ford and the jews
the mass production of hate was just
released yesterday by public affairs
[Music]
now it's time for the awards i must tell
you that we have four remarkably
interesting and distinguished chairmen
this year and i for one am eagerly
looking forward to what they have to
reveal to us
so let me reintroduce our master of
ceremonies
steve i speak for the entire board in
the foundation family and for everyone
in this room i'm sure
when i offer our heartfelt thanks to you
for being here with us tonight steve
martin
[Applause]
okay
and now it's time
for the presentation of the 52nd
national book awards
i wonder who's going to win best
supporting novel
all right here's how it's going to work
for each of the four awards i will name
the five finalists and they will stand
in place
is that is that a first this year that
they will stand in place wow
showbiz
and after i have announced all five you
can applaud them
anyone who applauds before the five
finalists are announced will be singled
out for ridicule
then i will ask the chairman of the
judging panel to step forward and he or
she
will announce the winner the
determination whether it's a he or she
will be determined at that moment
and my decision will be final
the first award of the evening is poetry
the five finalists are
again
excuse me rooms are never finished
w w norton and company
wanda coleman macura chrome black
sparrow press
[Applause]
alan dugan
poem 7 new and complete poetry seven
stories press
[Applause]
cornelius edie brutal imagination
wood book gp putnam sons
gail mazur they can't take that away
from me the university of chicago press
standing
[Music]
well you applauded before but what the
heck
it's my pleasure to introduce the
chairman of the poetry jury stanley
plumley who will present the national
book award for poetry stanley plumley
is a distinguished university professor
and professor of english at the
university of maryland and college park
his most recent book is now that my
father lies down beside me new and
selected pawns 1970-2000
published by the echo press
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
i too would like to thank neil baldwin
and
meg carney for
and the staff at the national book
foundation
for their guidance and support in this
selection process
choosing five finalists
let alone a winner in this year's
national book award category
for poetry was not easy
it is never easy i'm sure
there were many many remarkable volumes
of poetry published this year
the poetry committee could have
nominated a dozen of them
i would like to offer my special and
public thanks
to the other members of this year's
committee
for their clarity of opinion
good sense
fairness
and willingness to see all sides
those other members consisted of
and tom slay
the year 2001 has already joined history
as one of those turning point years
we all tonight in this greatest of all
cities
know why this is so
at such times the art of language
becomes even more compelling
communal
and valuable
the art of poetry especially
speaks to and from those values that
give us our language
and our connection to one another
and while the art of poetry may speak to
and from individuals
in their most secret hearts
it also elevates the discourse
of our dailiness
and our common purpose
poetry american poetry
suddenly now seems particularly
important to who we are and what we care
for
it is the common language made uncommon
in the hands of the poets
we celebrate tonight
and not simply those poets who have been
nominated for this great award
but for all those who this year
wrote the poems and committed them
into books
the five poetry finalists
represent a fair cross section
of the diversity
indeed plurality
of contemporary
american poetry
dali calls from an ancient world
an ancient culture
that writes his own and his birth
countries elegies
in a uniquely american grain
wanda coleman
writes in the brilliantly wicked tongue
of one who has come through
one of the most difficult periods
in american history and transformed its
racism
and gender bias into stunning and
original poetry
alan dugan all by himself
is the last half-century
of american poetry
self-contained
whose hard-won
wise
and uncompromising poems have never
wavered
from speaking truth to power
cornelius edie has recreated in his
brutal
but beautiful imagination
dramas of what it still means to be
black
young
[Music]
and male in our culture by the simple
genius of his empathy
and comprehension
gail mazur re-teaches us the oldest
terms
of lyric poetry
that real strength
lies in the understatement
and the small moment
and the quiet crisis
of how we arrive
at the utterance
of our inmost and mortal lives
i'd like to congratulate these five
finalists
and the winner of this year's national
book award in poetry
is the poet whose crucial honesty
as much as his resolute
art
are irresistible
poem 7 alan duvin
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
taking the award to mr dugan
neil is whispering something
he can't understand
asking him
taking a photo
are you sure you don't want a jokester
in there
congratulations
all right our second award tonight is
for young people's literature and the
five finalists are
kate dicamillo
the tiger rising candlewick press
[Applause]
i've rescinded my edict you can clap
anytime you want
you're liberated
philip hose we were there too young
people in u.s history ferrara strauss
and giroux
onna a step from heaven front street
press
[Applause]
marilyn nelson
marilyn nelson carver a life in poems
front street press
branding
virginia you are wolf true believer a
novel in the make lemonade trilogy
athenaeum
[Applause]
books for young readers
[Applause]
the chairman of the young people's
literature panel is beth kephart
beth kephart's first book a slant of sun
one child's courage was a finalist for
the national book award in 1998 and was
also named the best book of the year by
salon.com her new memoir still love and
strange places will be published in the
spring by w w norton and company
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you steve and thank you neil
sherry meg and meredith who so surprised
me with the call last spring and who
have served as
truest touchstones throughout the months
that followed
among the many questions i find myself
asking lately are what is genuine what
has real meaning
what must ultimately endure
these are questions that we always ask
ourselves of course
but in these fragile and confounding
times it seems essential to seize on
answers to locate truth and to defend it
this summer some 160 new books
biographies picture books novels poetry
plays science fantasy history memoir and
even one quasi cookbook were submitted
to the national book foundation for
consideration by the young people's
literature jury
what a daunting thing it was to watch
them pile up in the corner of my already
wheezing office
what a gift to know that i was not alone
that four wise women k castle ellen
howard lisa clayton robinson and jane
thomas we're being simultaneously
inundated too
together i trusted we would read and we
would talk
together we would find our way to books
both ingenious and genuine
because our commitment lay in
discovering the five best titles we were
given to consider our time was spent not
just reading but developing and debating
and settling on the measures that would
ultimately guide our process
for what is best when comparing bedtime
rhymes in studied history what is best
when teen angst and fairy tales are both
toppling off the piles
in the end our criteria were
multi-dimensional and if you consider
genres to be cultures as i do
multicultural
we concerned ourselves with matters of
framing form and voice
with credibility and characterization
with execution of plot or storyline
we studied the language was it rigorous
tantalizing fresh
we explored dynamics pertaining to
originality and mood meaning and soul
we thought out loud about each book's
innate capacity to alert embolden or
inspire
enduring books are the ones that enter
the bloodstreams of their readers that
stir and shape and finally transform
they are the ones that have passed on
parent to child friend to friend
the ones that jolt us toward insight
compassion idea hope politics or love
toward the answers to the questions we
must keep asking
the five books nominated for the 2001
young people's literature award answer
to every conceivable literary standard
we envision the books bundled tied
together throughout the coming gift
given season
anna's masterful a step from heaven will
remove the veil from the immigrant
experience and take you into a world you
owe it to yourself to know
marilyn nelson's carver a life in poems
will introduce you to a most remarkable
man with language that is indelible and
dignified
with its gorgeous prose and haunting
setting
kate de camilo's the tiger rising will
transport you to the death of a child's
aching soul
philippus toward a force we were there
too will hearten you with stories of
heroes who were too young most of the
time to recognize their own greatness
and finally virginia your wolf's true
believer will implicate you with its
audacious point of view
as a reader i am gratified by these
books
as a parent i am blessed
as a writer i am humbled
and as a human being i am rescued by
their endlessly discoverable graces
when we sat down to craft our guiding
criteria we knew that one day we'd have
to choose a single prize winning book
today as we met each other face to face
for the first time we did we chose the
book that was in our considered
estimations most fierce most unyielding
most original most unafraid to get
inside the heart of readers
we chose a tough and equally beautiful
book and tonight we honor its author
virginia you are wolf
thank you for writing true believer
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you for writing true believer and
congratulations on fully earning the
high honor of this year's national book
award
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
first of all
marilyn marlow
my literary agent who has always been
there
always
brenda bowen my editor
who makes me write better than i can
write is this happening
brenda bowen who makes me write better
than i can write
and at naom and simon and schuster
thank you so much
for welcoming this book
the national book foundation for what
you do for literacy
for people here and everywhere
and how you've
in some small way changed my life
tonight
thank you to the judges for your
generous
generous decision
to my son anthony wolf and my daughter
julia wolf
thank you
for your encouragement
to my brother eugene ewer who grows
pears in oregon
for his unstinting support
like most authors
i have wondered since september 11th
what i would ever write again if i would
ever write anything and if so
would it
matter and usually the answer has been
no for two months the answer has been no
you understand don't you of course
and today
my son anthony and i went to the world
trade center site
and we walked around
and what i saw
was
living proof of faulkner's six
faulkner said in 1949 in the nobel
speech
that if we are not writing about these
six things we are not doing our job
they are love
honor
pity
pride
compassion and sacrifice
and i think of them as faulkner's six i
used to have them on my wall till i
memorized them and now they're on this
wall in here
and i saw them today
at ground zero
the work that is going on and the awe
and the humility and the hush
and the consideration
love honor pity pride compassion and
sacrifice and that's what
you and i and all of us are supposed to
be writing about faulkner said it and he
was right thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
it's a beautiful speech
from shock to eloquence
[Music]
our third award is non-fiction
the finalists are marie arana american
chica
two worlds one childhood the dial press
nina bernstein the lost children of
wilder the epic struggle to change
foster care pantheon books
[Applause]
are they all standing or standing
are people standing okay good
just
it's just my thing
david james duncan
my story is told by water sierra club
books
[Applause]
john t gross neighbors the destruction
of the jewish community center in
yawabnee poland princeton university
press
andrew solomon the noonday demon an
atlas of depression scribner
[Music]
[Applause]
the chairman of the non-fiction jury is
terry tempest williams terry tempus
williams lives in the red rock desert of
southern utah and is the author of
refuge an unnatural history of family
and place
a classic of environmental literature
her new book red passion and patience in
the desert was recently published by
pantheon
[Applause]
[Music]
it's a pleasure and privilege to be here
this evening representing the genre of
creative non-fiction with my
distinguished colleagues and fellow
writers and i would like to introduce
them to you now
alex kotlowitz richard rodriguez
christine stensel
and andre ossiman who is not here will
you please stand
and i want them to know how much i
appreciate the shape of their minds the
play of their imagination and the
integrity of their words
we set about our task in the spirit of
democracy
we were interested in the range of human
experience
held within the reach of non-fiction
we were mindful of the representation of
structure and form
literary journalism history natural
history the lyrical essay memoir
biography not only of an individual but
of an idea
and we were struck by the passion and
presence of writers on the page the
force of their obsessions
chekhov was right
the two qualities a writer needs most
are faith and stamina
we found beautiful work novels of ideas
and we embraced five books of uncommon
grace that we believe will endure
through time that they have the capacity
to inspire and transform
a reader a community
and expand our understanding of culture
listen to the power and pleasure of
their
sentences
there is a flame hidden in water that
gives not heat but life
david james duncan my life is told by
water
two days after his sixth birthday
carrying assault suitcase and his photo
album lamont moved to his third home in
12 months
nina bernstein the lost children of
wilder
depression is the great flaw of love
andrew solomon
noonday demons
i a north south collision a new world
fusion an american chica a bridge
marie arana american chica
war is a myth creating experience in the
life of every society is it possible to
suffer and inflict suffering at the same
time
jan gross
neighbors
each of these books bears gifts and
wisdoms
the power to translate a vision
for living a life of greater intention
attention
reminding us we belong to a world worth
participating in
on a personal note and this is a story
for you neil and the staff of the
national book foundation and for all of
us who are in this beautiful culture of
literature
i live in a small rural community in the
american southwest of about 250 people
bordered on the south
by the lasalle mountains 12 000 feet
to the north by the colorado river
it's 25 miles to the nearest town of
moab
we have no services no gas station no
star stores
but we have mailboxes a little kiosk
where the world intersects with our own
a gathering place
little goes unnoticed in our town
especially 500 books arriving daily
and let me just say utah is known for
conspiracy theories
word got out national book award and
nominees people were curious especially
when they heard it was secret i struck a
deal with my neighbors
after the five finalists were chosen
we'd open up our garage
and the town could come browse take
whatever books they wanted and the rest
we'd donate to the local library
on october 11th the garage doors went up
and for two weeks we had a steady stream
of visitors
quickly richard and jolene williams
devout mormons
richard picked ho chi minh by william
duker he's a vietnam vet
he read it on his grave night graveyard
shift bagging
potash
jolene a mother of 12 home schools for
children had never traveled beyond the
borders of utah and arizona she picked
venice lion city by gary willis lara
kamali midwife picked misconceptions by
naomi wolf she now has feminist theory
to back up what she knows
intuitively ron drake who drives the
school bus
and writes the local newspaper column
castle valley comments and i have to
tell you many times he said nothing
happened this week but let me remind you
what happened ten years ago
devoured janet malcolm's reading chekhov
and he's doing that now
reading chekhov
savage beauty seabiscuit that was the
choice of marlene my colleen pendleton
who was raised in the uranian camps of
the 1950s
her mother read her renascence as a
child her parents horse
bet even seabiscuit
and lastly bill headen former county
commissioner one of the few democrats in
the state of utah at one of the last
town councils quoted john adams
we have been afraid to think
the true source of our suffering has
been our timidity let us dare to read
think speak and write this in the
context of advocating the public to
retire grazing permits in arid country
our neighbors are waiting to hear who
won the national book award for
non-fiction
what book they can read next why these
particular words matter
from the author's own text quote
i believe that words are strong that
they can overwhelm what we fear
in the maturity of the new millennium we
will i hope save this earth's rainforest
the ozone layer the rivers and streams
the oceans and we will also save i hope
the minds and hearts of the people who
live here then we will curb our
escalating fear of the demons at noon
over anxiety and depression andrew
solomon
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
i have to admit to not having recognized
my own words i was thinking who wrote
that
who said that
um
my book is about depression
it's about the difficulties of enduring
and living with depression and it's also
about
things that counteract depression
and i would now recommend to all of my
readers
winning the national book award
as an extremely efficacious
antidepressant
[Applause]
i think the standard form as i've
watched it for years on tv for other
kinds of awards is to do some thanks and
i of course thank my
wonderful editor nan graham
my
agent andrew wiley who took me on when i
had never published a word very early on
my publisher susan maldow the head of
publicity pat isaman
and also in particularly my father who
is here tonight who helped me through
the depression that became the subject
of this book
[Music]
and my very dear friend john hobbick who
has helped me through some of the
difficulties of
waiting to hear what was going to happen
um i
am extremely grateful to
all of these people and i will just take
a moment given the time that it is to
comment on
depression in september 11th i think
that we have just
been through a time when the mental
health of the entire nation
is challenged
it was one of the things that i joked
about with friends when i was working on
my book that we would make such
scientific leaps that by the time the
book was published there would be no
such thing as depression and there would
be no readers for what i had written
but this unfortunately was not to be
in fact we live in a time when the rates
of depression have escalated
when prescriptions for antidepressants
are up by between 20 and 25 percent
when the rates of anxiety have
skyrocketed and when also within america
we are seeing higher than ever rates
of child abuse and domestic violence
the things that we have been confronted
with over this recent period
are terrible terrible things and it is
not surprising that in response to those
terrible things we have descended into
some of the morass of depression and
anxiety
it is also not unnatural when you fall
off a ladder that you break your arm
but it's appropriate to do something
about it and it's appropriate to do
something about the depression and the
sadness which have so overwhelmed the
united states because if we genuinely
allow those things to triumph then in
fact we will have given way to the will
of the terrorists who wanted to destroy
not simply the buildings and the lives
of the people they eliminated but also
the morale and the courage of this
nation
it seems to me
that the depression we have now cries
out
for treatment and that when we talk
about the superior technologies that we
have in the current war we should
emphasize not only
our military capacities but also our
capacities through a variety of
therapies medications ways of
understanding each other and most
profoundly insights and forms of love to
triumph over the assault that has been
made on our understanding of ourselves
and so i hope that this is something
that will happen in the united states it
is my dream for this book
of course it's a dream that it be read
for many years and that it's how many
copies it's my real dream for this book
that it will become unnecessary and i
hope bit by bit we will move forward and
unnecessary is what it will become
i thank you all
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
wow
[Applause]
beautiful speech again
although mr solomon has ruined it for
the others please keep your hugging to a
minimum
our final award tonight is fiction
the finalists are
dan shawn among the missing valentine
books
[Applause]
jennifer egan look at me nan a talese
double day
louise erdrich the last report on the
miracles at little no horse harper
collins publishers
jonathan franzen the corrections for our
strauss and giroux
[Music]
susan strait high wire moon houghton
mifflin company
[Music]
the chairman of the fiction jury is
colin harrison collison harrison is the
author of four novels the most recent of
which is after burn published by ferrara
strauss and giroux he was an editor at
harper's magazine for 12 years
[Applause]
thank you
before announcing the winner
i'd like to thank my fellow judges
mary morris angela davis gardner
susan shreve and bill henderson
were all devoted in their labors and
thorough in their scrutiny
they read the books
they considered the books
they went page by page
they attended to the questions of story
and language and character
to the grandeur of the attempt
and to the success of the whole
each spoke with measure and distinction
i and we
owe them great gratitude
thank you judges
and thank you neil baldwin and the
national book foundation for the chance
to participate in tonight's celebration
when we give an award for fiction
we celebrate the toil of a singular
imagination
we say in effect
that this book
written in solitude
wrenched from one head
reaches for
and grasps
something profoundly human
something recognizable and shared
the book may have already reached
multitudes
or it may be yet to reach multitudes
but it offers something to the culture
that is new
it makes a space for itself
it removes its readers from the chatter
and hum of their lives and delivers them
to a deeper part of themselves
having read such a book
it becomes impossible to consider not
having read it
one has changed if only subtly
one has been reminded of the potential
greatness
of a singular imagination
the public recognition of a book of
fiction and of fiction in general
is thus a connective act of civilization
and during this particular fall
during this poignant american season
we have been reminded that our
civilization
however imperfect and worthy of
criticism
must at times have its principles
restated
and its people defended
when we honor books
we honor language and speech
and the freedom of the imagination
that writers and readers enjoy in
america
the five finalists for this year's
national book award for fiction
were each distinctive in voice and
vision
we commend each work and each writer
and hope that the reading public will
seek out these books
and discover what the judges found so
memorable
the book voted this year's winner of the
national book award
is a portrait of a troubled american
family
little of what touches this family does
not touch most of us too
and if the story is savage in moments
so too is it
if its characters pain and exasperate us
as do our own family members
so too do they become worthy of our
affection
if this book is satirical and dark
eager to itemize the absurdity and
excess of our culture
it is also willing to weigh its
complaint
against our fleeting opportunity to find
what we value most
it wishes to charm and to threaten
to make us laugh and to make us make us
anxious
written with a broken heart
this novel searches for a piece of
redemption
it seeks to be a great american novel
and it succeeds
the winner of the 2001 national book
award for fiction
is
the corrections by jonathan
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
hi
i haven't been nervous until this minute
um but now i am
i wanted to say it's been uh
uh
a bad couple of months here in new york
city
um
no i mean that seriously
uh
really bad
um a bit dark time
and
now on a lighter note i'd like to say
that i feel as if i was the person who
provided some
bloodsport entertainment
uh
to
divert the literary community in this
this time of trouble
um
[Music]
and i'd like to say that i was very
happy to perform this service for my
city and for my country
on the other hand the next time a public
emergency arises if anyone else would
like to step into the bull ring
they're more than welcome to take my
place
having said that
this is just i i'm not here i'm still
sitting in the chair
uh i'd like to thank some readers
uh first of all i'd like to thank the
fiction committee
which had the unenviable task of picking
one book from among a very strong field
of five finalists
i'd like to thank my agent susan gollum
who i think is the smartest and toughest
agent in new york city
i'd like to thank my extended family at
ferris strauss
especially jonathan glossy
for all the patients and support they've
shown me in the last 14 years
i'd also like to thank oprah winfrey for
her enthusiasm and advocacy on behalf of
the corrections
[Applause]
i'd like to thank the many many many
reviewers and editors and booksellers
all of them readers
who helped bring the book to national
attention
i'd like to thank my friends and family
most especially kathy chetkovic for
making life worth living along the way
i'd like to thank all readers everywhere
for keeping alive what i believe is the
most
lovely thing that human beings make
which is the book
finally i'd like to thank my parents
earl and irene franzen for a lifetime of
love i wish they were here tonight
thank you very much
[Music]
and that concludes the 2001 you can stay
it's all right you don't have to rush
all right
uh the 2001 national book awards
ceremony however there are still some
winners out there may i ask that those
of you in the audience who submitted
bids for the silent auction to benefit
the windows of hope fund please remain
at your tables for a few minutes so that
our volunteers can locate you and take
your money and you can receive your
artwork the results of the auction will
be posted tomorrow morning on the
national book foundation website
and on the evening of thursday january
17th the four national book award
winners will be speaking about their
works at the celeste bartos forum on the
new at the new york public library and
then in april may and june there's a lot
to go
uh they will be embarking upon the gold
medal tour sponsored by bloomberg in
princeton new jersey washington dc
boston chicago and san francisco
good night and thank you all for coming
and don't forget to take the centerpiece
books home and we'll see you again next
year
[Music]
you've been watching the 52nd annual
national book awards ceremony from the
marriott marquis talks about her
childhood and what led her to a
leadership role in government
american perspectives begins now
[Music]
a revival of arthur miller's 1953 play
the crucible opens on broadway this
month
the play is about the salem witch trials
as a metaphor for mccarthyism
in january mr miller discussed his play
and how his themes related to today's
politics and culture
new york times columnist frank rich
conducted the interview at the 92nd
street y in new york city it runs an
hour and 15 minutes
[Music]
thank you
good evening and thanks for coming
tonight
there's so much to talk about i i have a
bunch of questions i know you do
too so
i think we'll dive right in uh that's
okay with with you
um
this afternoon i was looking up um in
the best place edition of 1944 to 1945
uh an account of your first play
produced on broadway this was the season
uh for those of you don't remember it
was the season of the glass menagerie
carousel
may west and katzman was great the last
season of of world war ii this is what
burns mantle wrote
in the introduction to best plays
an unusually interesting and well-played
comedy called the man who had all the
luck written by arthur miller was
mistakenly withdrawn it seemed to this
writer after only four performances
it was at least worth a three-week
chance to find itself and its public
how has
that play first of all is coming back
this season i'd like you to talk a
little bit about that and
and why we haven't seen the play since
then
well you know when a play fails which
that did
uh
you rarely hear about it anymore
it's not like it's not like books
a book is printed and
and people pick it up and rediscover it
the play takes a lot of work and money
to produce
so if uh the curse is on it from the
beginning it just sort of dries up and
blows away
uh
there was a very lovely production of it
in bristol england
a couple of years back
and they brought it to london it was it
was a nicely successful production
but uh
i don't know it just uh never grabbed
enough people i think he was right
though i think that
uh the backer of the play was a perfume
manufacturer and he didn't like the way
it smelled anything
um
was but here was a play that obviously
some people did like and and got you
your first attention yanked off
immediately is that a different broadway
from the broadway we have today
well it was all together different
mind you that was a play by an unknown
writer
as you will see later in this year when
it's done again by the at the roundabout
uh
it is was then it still is a kind of
unusual
script
and yet it was done on broadway
now that that wouldn't happen now
you couldn't do that now
explain why
well i suspect it's partly because of
the disintegration of the audience
there was then
a coherent
theater going audience cohesive
people who felt that life wasn't really
complete without their going to the
theater once
twice a month or more than that
i'm not sure that exists anymore now we
go to see a star
uh we see you some extraordinary
uh blockbuster of some kind
and it's uh
i would say it's a period of uh
decay
in the theater
the theater usually is decaying when
its main attraction
are the stars
it's when the playwright is the middle
of it that you can say it's good
[Applause]
well you know
uh if you look back
through the
20th century in the 19th century
it was when uh
chekhov was writing
uh there were a lot of famous actors
then
uh i can't name one of them
except stanislavski
uh
when ibsen was writing
these were playwrights theaters
do you think it's changed because the
culture has changed or because of the
economics of the theater
the easy answer is that the economics
have killed it
it now costs
over a million dollars to put the
crucible on
and it cost about 35 000 originally when
it was originally done it was produced
by a single man right kermit bloom
garden one guy and a cigar
people
he was a a great producer who produced a
number of what we would regard as the
classics of the theater
he was not an intellectual though was he
oh no he was a
he was a producer
that term has become very lasting you
have
how many producer was somebody who put
together productions
all by
himself he didn't have enormous amounts
of money he had no money usually
but he had a few friends who would back
him
because you could get
what 8-10 friends and raise 35 000
well now you need 800 friends and
they've got to be pretty rich to put up
a million million and a half dollars
so it's that that i think is the central
thing the course have choked it today
how many producers are producing the
current production of the crucible there
are 20 producers
so that amounts to almost one per actor
on stage
if god forbid they should all have to
take a bow on the same night you better
not win the tony award i guess
[Music]
um
you you've often talked about how the
audience in the old days of the theater
and when you entered the theater was
demographically more diverse
is that do you feel that's changed too
is that part of the problem
i
all i know is
is that
there was a
kind of reverence
that is gone
people felt it was an art not a business
now of course it always was a business
but
a certain number a large enough number
of both producers and the audience
felt it was a
a place for art to take place
now i don't want to overemphasize that
because
the people i talk about let's say there
were 50 producers on broadway in those
days
maybe four of them had that attitude but
ford's a lot
and
you found one of those four and he might
go for it and knowing that his chances
of making any money
were very low
none of them felt that they they were
going to get rich on a play
like all my sons
or
death a salesman for that matter
uh in fact one great director read death
of a salesman after he had given
bloomgarden a thousand dollars
based upon the success of all my sons
and then he read the script and he took
back five hundred dollars
[Laughter]
and he was asked why he's done that and
he said i didn't think the audience
would understand it
he felt that they'd never follow
the time scheme
amazing yeah and he was a very
sophisticated and good director
and bloomgarden had a little trouble in
the beginning too i had to explain it to
him
but uh
with all his trouble he nevertheless did
it
now could you argue that the role of a
kermit bloom garden or
uh bob white had these great producers
who produced serious plays in that
period has just been taken over by the
artistic directors of off-broadway
companies new york shakespeare festival
manhattan theater company
roundabout
accepting they're not risking what these
guys risked
these guys rick's their rent
their shirts
they could be destroyed by a failure
many times
and if they failed if they picked the
wrong play twice
they could be out of business for a long
time
it was tough going
but my point is is that
uh without overemphasizing it there was
a certain degree of of
obligation
i remember
billy rose who was a little guy who
wrote songs and
occasionally produced some
fantastic
show like uh
i can't remember any of them
uh
jumbo jumbo
right
i think there were elephants in it yeah
well he
insist that i'm putting money into
clifford that's his last place which
anybody who read them knew
would probably never succeed on stage
and i asked him once i said why did you
do that
since he knew better than anybody else
he says because it was clifford odets
somebody had to put it on
well i can't find that guy anymore
and uh
i don't think
but you see he what he had to raise
i don't know what
twenty thousand dollars
he was a rich man
and i'm sure it didn't kill him to put
that up but now it is twenty thousand
dollars
is nothing
um
today a lot of young writers seem to
completely bypass the theater young
writers and dramatic
media
and would argue
that they should because a television
show like the sopranos or the best of
independent
movies offer
more lively creative opportunities would
would you agree with that
no but i can see where they
they have to eat and you can't eat in
the right place
it's a
they're too diametrically opposed
[Laughter]
uh
see the problem is is that when you
write
the sopranos or
whatever
the
the art of playwriting
consists mainly of the manipulation of
time
everything has to be squeezed
so that it becomes dramatic
these other forms are more narrative
than they are dramatic
even though they have dramatic scenes in
them
uh
that discipline is vanished
i think
and it's a hard discipline
it's monkish it is very difficult
and there aren't many people who want to
suffer through that
i think of course it involves suffering
it involves
working materials so that that stuff is
squeezed as far as it can be squeezed
and still tell a story that seems
perfectly natural
it is
in 1953 when the crucible was originally
done
you
i believe were not happy with the
original production of jed harris
directed and
the show
faltered financially early on and you
went back in
and
rewrote and
redirected the play can you talk a
little bit about that i didn't rewrite
anything i simply took all the scenery
off the stage
because
without the scenery we wouldn't have to
pay
the crew
uh anyway it struck me one day when i
was backstage they had a line of lights
white lights across the backstage which
when the scenery was there you didn't
see lights but you saw the glow of light
and
i put the actors behind those lights so
they all looked like
dead
and when their turns came to perform
they walked through the light and they
became alive
and then when they finished their
scene they'd go back and be dead again
and it worked beautifully
and it was the lights just stayed on all
the time there was no
no on and off
the critics went back and thought they
were seeing a whole other play though
right it was not uh
not a word had been changed
but uh
it was too late you couldn't get back a
big enough audience to run that
but it took about three or four years
for a young group of people who are in a
hotel the hotel mcalpin i think it may
have been the first
so-called off broadway production some
of these told me that
where they simply had a ballroom in a
mcalpin hotel where they
put them in the box office
and they did the play
there was no set and did he get a lot of
attention oh yeah it was a big hit
and all the critics said well he changed
it
i didn't change anything
when you see plays now when plays were
produced such as your very first play or
the crucible
um
do you ever want to go back and correct
that younger playwright and change a
word do you ever get that temptation
no i i don't feel that way about it i
feel
if that's the way it is that's where it
is i'm very fatalistic about plays i
think they
the play announces itself
uh it's like people you know people
finally
gravitate to the level at which they
were destined
it takes a long time but that's weird
do you
do you think that the crucible's later
popularity had to do
also with with people having a greater
realization of what went on during the
mccarthy period i tell you i think that
it ran up against the brick wall because
people when they caught on to what would
see nobody knew what a crucible was
uh
and i'm not sure anybody knows now but
they were scared
as the
the opening night i'll never forget it i
knew a number of people in the audience
and as
that
story developed i could feel the ice
forming over that audience
and it got thicker and thicker and by
the end of the play i was standing in
the lobby talking to somebody and people
i'd known went right past me
they went right past me as though i
wasn't standing there
and
in three years mccarthy was dead
the power of that fear was mitigated
and they put the play on and it became
popular
they
we you know there are two things that
are difficult to transmit one is love
and one is fear
to
feel loved
the way you feel it when it's happening
and telling about it the two different
things
and fear is similar you can say oh i was
scared of death was meaningless
unless you've been
well even people who have been afraid
the mind closes it down you can't stand
that kind of pressure too long
it's a wound that you want to heal
and the wound of the early 50s is one of
those wounds
i don't think that it's to this day
we really have confronted him
when the whole kazan flap happened out
in hollywood a few years ago
um
what was i'm curious know your reaction
to the way that
that sort of played out in in the 1990s
it seemed to me a lot of the discussion
about it was was ill-informed that
people had already forgotten what it all
what it all been about am i right about
that oh yeah
he uh as you know i opposed what he
he did but uh
i felt that they were laying everything
on
mr kazan
uh you couldn't
i don't think there were five people who
were condemning him who knew the name of
any member of the un-american activities
committee
some of whom were pretty dreadful people
one of whom landed in jail
as a crook
[Music]
they all blamed kazan for everything it
was ridiculous
and i i didn't want to be part of that
do you think mccarthyism so long ago
entered the language that it's one of
those words that now has lost its
meaning and people just use it
uh
you know
most things people either forgot
or they got it mixed up with something
else
it's it's
the fate of our experience that one of
the things i think that perhaps if you
want to say art has a purpose
art can
make a memory alive again
and uh more than
essays or anything else because it
reaches your emotional life
and
uh
interestingly for example i don't know
of another play
that was written about that
subject
there may have must have been some
i just don't know of any none of them
certainly has lasted
and why is that
because there was one hell of a drama
it was killing people people were
jumping off buildings
so there were a few suicides that i knew
about that i'd heard about
and uh
i think it was
the writers simply didn't feel that they
could
confront an audience and get people to
sympathize with the play
does it worry you now in in the new
century as as you prepare this new
production
that people are going to americans are
going to come into the theater and say
oh that's the salem witch trials it
never happened again it can't happen
here it's just a period piece
some of them might but i think by this
time a lot of people study the play in
high school there have been endless
essays written about it
and
so they sort of know what the thing is
about but this time
um what about in the countries it's
played
where the culture where people don't
know about the salem witch trials or
mccarthyism well i thought i started to
tell you earlier that i met a woman of
chinese lady
who wrote a
book published by my publisher that at
the time grove
and i happened to be in the office and i
met her and uh
she saw me and the tears came to her
eyes and uh why well she told me the
following story she'd been arrested
under the gang of four which was this
crazy
government they had there for
seven or eight years
and uh
my husband had been the head of standard
oil in china chinese
man who were they killed
and then they killed her daughter and
they put her away for six years
in solitary confinement
and incidentally she when she was
pardoned finally she refused to
leave the prison
unless they apologized
and it took about six months but they
apologized but she lived in the cell
which was open the door was open
anyway
uh
when she got out her friend was a
theater director and he was directing a
chinese production of the crucible
so she went to see it and
afterwards she said to me i asked him
who wrote this
and he said i did and
she said but he's not chinese
and i said
and he said
no she and then she i said what do you
mean by that she said every question in
that play
that the interrogators asked are exactly
the questions we were asked in china
so you see what i was trying to do in
play
one of the things was to tell them
this had all happened before
yeah and and this is an old story that
we're living through now
in that regard i want to talk a little
bit about another
historical event that looms um
so large in your work the stock market
crash and
the depression
we've now been through
two sort of booms and busts in the past
20 years we no longer really have many
traveling salesmen but
it seems a lot of the coordinates are
the same
we're now in at this moment
looking at one of the biggest busts in
american
business history are there similarities
how is it different how's it the same
in 1930
well what i don't know four or something
like that after the crash
of 1929
the government
jailed the head of the new york stock
market man named whitney
who ended up in sing-sing
along with a few of his buddies
who have been manipulating
people's money
not unlike the enron thing
telling lies every day about what was
happening
so i'm looking at this now and i'm sort
of smiling and thinking what did they
think
these guys were doing
how do you make
tens of millions of dollars
in a matter of two months or something
how does that happen
you got to be a crook
[Applause]
[Music]
so it all comes back accepting now of
course
it's a different economy the
economy has far more resilience because
of the reforms put in by that dreadful
man roosevelt
whom they all tried to
turn into a
demon
and he saved them a number of times
is it is it
here you've written these plays that
have
in some cases loomed over american
culture or the world's culture for half
a century
that
spell out these lessons and yet no one
seems to learn them is that is that
frustrating or does it make you feel uh
hopeless or
i was writing play
when was it i don't remember now a few
years ago
in which god is
a character
and
he says to
somebody in the play
somebody says to him the devil says to
him
but you can't possibly do that because
people will realize it once
from their past experience that this is
a disaster
and god says
people don't remember anything
that's the first law
of society
it all goes down that big sluice
and out to sea
and
i suppose it's up to the
scholars and the artists and so on
and a few old codgers to keep saying
look uh this happened before you know
and just let the chips fall where they
may because there's nothing you can do
about it what are you going to do
because people are too busy
you know trying to get on the subway
[Laughter]
last year you gave a a very powerful uh
lecture the so-called jefferson lecture
uh sponsored by
the humanities endowment i believe yeah
and it was it was called on politics and
the art of acting
and in it you this is one sentence from
what you you said when one is surrounded
by such a roiling mass of consciously
controlled performances it gets harder
and harder to locate reality anymore can
you talk about that in the political
context
well i i tell you it all that little uh
essay came out of my watching television
because it suddenly occurred to me that
uh
with the number of hours that people
watch television probably
most of their acquaintances are actors
[Laughter]
you include tv newsmen yeah and they're
all
the tv news people
the men and the women they're all they
are actors after all they're reading
they're reading scripts
and uh
you wonder what that does to the mind as
far as reality is concerned
and uh so i wrote this little essay
about
uh
[Music]
acting in the theater and uh in in
politics it reminded me
of a story you should know
one of the best that i've heard
bobby lewis was a an actor
and a director
and as a young actor he was the dresser
for an actor named jacob benami who was
a famous yiddish actor
and uh
bobby
the act was uh
he was doing a german play
in which
the character stands at the edge of the
stage with a gun to his head
and is about to shoot himself
and uh he tries and he's he's very tense
the tension is gets deeper and deeper
and finally he puts the gun down and
says he kanish
i can't do it
and the audience was simply mesmerized
by this
act
and people would come down to the
industry from
midtown
just to see that moment
and
after he was finished the theater would
they would leave
and
bobby was interested to know how this
man created that reality
and uh the man the jacob and amy said i
won't tell you now because it'll ruin it
and once it gets into the papers
i'll wait till the last performance and
i'll tell you the last performance came
and
he said well you're going to tell me
what what are you doing
he said well the problem with my doing
of suicide is that i'm very i would
never commit suicide
and i never had anything to do with guns
so i was trying to visualize a parallel
situation where i'm standing up
i'm alone
and i'm trying to do something
and i can't do it and i figured the only
thing that i can think of is i'm
standing in front of a cold shower
trying to step in there
[Laughter]
and uh when i watched
bush and
[ __ ] and the rest of them
i thought what are they really thinking
[Laughter]
what cold shower are they
are they remembering because
the stiffness of it all the bad acting
the morcus
was overwhelming you look at that and
you think
could you cast one of these guys in a
play
[Applause]
[Music]
it was it was it was inconceivable it
was so bad
and uh
i guess
maybe it was always that way accepting
uh
for
a few people kennedy could
do it good
and roosevelt was certainly great at it
harry truman now and then
but the sense of the
visceral conviction about something
i don't see it it just uh it's all
canned and controlled and contrived and
you're being manipulated is there a way
out of this or is this a i think the
television is sunk us
i think as soon as you put that camera
on somebody
including me i mean you feel
well i got to do something now
uh what do i do now
i'm
i mean nobody
you have to be a great performer to sit
there and
really think
about anything
that that lens absorbs the brain
it's terrible
do you think
nixon in this tv world i know he was tv
of course when he was around the first
time but it's become so much slicker do
you think someone is unslick as nixon
could get elected president today i
wonder whether he could
i mean he really was a stick you know
i'm just curious just from a performance
point of view not a political point of
view did you find that john mccain uh
he's the best he had some authenticity
well i think that occasionally he gets
really
genuinely
involved
he's not just calculating
this that you know
[Laughter]
you get the feeling they're all pushing
this button and that button
no he does get involved i think at least
if he doesn't he's a better actor than
[Laughter]
where were you on the morning of
september 11th in paris
you're in paris so how did you
hear the news
a friend of my wife's in germany called
us
and said have you seen the television i
said well i didn't come to paris to look
at television
and she said well turn it on because
it's awful and we turned it on and there
they were the buildings were then
collapsing
my first reaction was what a wonderful
job they're doing of
faking this
i thought it was a some kind of a
of a stunt
and it was i still haven't gotten over
that
i
uh that's simply
for
the reason that it makes the
civilization seem about
uh
thirty second of an inch thick
and when you panic panic is around the
corner at all times
because if we get hit again
it could be devastating did it affect
your ability to write in any
not really
i
i think it
it feeds in somewhere
god knows where but
i've always felt that we were lived on
the edge
of the abyss
anyway
but this went over
and uh
i you know i i'm so old i don't worry
about myself anymore but you know i have
children grandchildren and all that
and uh
you just don't want to think about all
that
what if as have you thought a lot about
this kind of um
sort of errant
religious fundamentalism that
is and and you see any similarities in
in other cultures besides that of uh i
would point out that the people in the
crucible are fundamentalists
the ones that did this that hung 21
people
in this tiny town
that was a fundamentalist cult
it happened to be the majority cult of
his colony but that's what it was and uh
[Music]
i i don't want to sound any
religious altogether because i am partly
wondering if god is up there
very doubtful
but uh
you know every
one of these movements has a
priest
a rabbi
a
[Music]
a
[ __ ]
priest at the head of it
including northern ireland
there isn't one of them that is not led
by religions
what makes you think
yes um
[Music]
before september 11th again in the same
lecture that you gave last year
you wrote something that seems very
relevant right now or potentially
relevant you said the ultimate
foundation of political power has never
changed it's the leader's willingness to
resort to violence should the need arise
an american leader may deliver the
sunday lesson provided his sword is
never out of reach the two best examples
being fdr and john kennedy
but this type which doesn't come along
every day
is an aristocratic populist in some ways
do you feel that
since september 11th george bush has
shown the signs of becoming a a
an aristocratic populace with the sword
ever ready or we're not
a half of what you say may be true that
is he's a populist but i can't see the
aristocratic side of it
[Music]
[Applause]
uh i it's not his fault it's the way he
was brought up
[Applause]
but uh
look i you have to uh we are in
i think we are really in a war
although we don't we can't hear it
there is a war going on
uh
there are those millions of people out
there who really wouldn't mind seeing
this country go down
and a certain number of them would like
to participate
that is i think true
and
therefore whatever help one can be you
ought to be
i'm going to go to the audience's
questions in a couple of minutes i just
want to ask a couple a few questions
about you as well as
now we've talked a bit about the world
in the theater
um
you have a new play that's opening this
summer in minneapolis can you tell us
about it
i can't tell you much about it because i
i don't know how to summarize it yet
it's called a resurrection blues
and it's a satiric
comedy
uh
takes place in a latin american country
what can i tell you about it i guess i
better shut up it just it was just
it's just wonderful
[Laughter]
[Applause]
how many producers will be needed to put
it on broadcast oh
this one will take about 30.
um
are you is are you still writing the
play are you still working on it
no i think i finished it there's famous
last words but
i think it's pretty well done
what's your life like on a day-to-day
basis how do you find time to work to
be in eminence
well i don't spend much time being
eminent but i
you have to do things like this for
instance
well
i'm doing this so that we all know that
the crucible is going to be on
well i live in the country
and uh
95 of the time but i have done that for
many years
and i get up in the morning and there's
nothing to do
so i write
and uh sometimes it works and
sometimes it doesn't
and uh
it's the usual
private uh
agony a writer spends most of his time
alone
and i'm not alone i have a family but uh
in your head you're alone
with that piece of paper
and
you know the scene in check chekhov in
the first play of his
the seagull where the girl says to the
writer how wonderful it must be to be a
writer
and
be thinking in terms of
great ideas and so on and he says well
i'll tell you
right now i'm looking at that cloud up
there and thinking it looks like a grand
piano
that's all it is
that's what
i'm really thinking
and uh
it's just the process of finding out
what you really think
which is not easy
is it less agonizing now than it was
when you started your career same job
same time
no different
except now you know that
it's pointless
[Applause]
well here are some pointed questions
from the audience
can you describe the differences in your
experiences writing for the film and for
the
stage well briefly the film as i
mentioned earlier is is to my mind is
more of a narrative than it is drama
and
it takes a different attitude takes a
more novelistic attitude
very
it's much more difficult to make a film
out of a play than it is out of a novel
put it that way
uh but there's another element involved
and that is that a film you know you
will lose control of
and there's no way around that
unless you're directing the thing
yourself and even so
you have to fight to control that but
the writer in the theater
at least in my experience has far more
control over his work
uh and consequently there's that
satisfaction that uh you're
you're not going to
lose lose sight of it you know when
you're writing when you used to write in
hollywood
the paper belonged to the producer of
the studio
and that idea is horrifying but it's the
case
you're an employee no matter how you cut
it
and it's a different relation
is it easier to have one of your plays
produced in london and if so why
it's further away
uh
it's no easier it's the same job
basically
in my experience i worked a lot in the
national theater which was
very wonderful experience
you didn't have that pressure of are we
going to lose a hundred thousand dollars
or aren't we
money to the writer to the artists to
the actors and directors did not seem
to be on the agenda
that's not what we were doing
we were really making a work on stage
and that was it there was nobody coming
by
worrying about uh
you know what the new york times was
going to say
they first there's another factor
what do they know
there's another factor involved that is
that there are so many newspapers
in london
so you get panned by one you might make
it with another
and that that does happen very
frequently do you think it also helps in
london that there isn't
such a television culture i mean there's
certainly a lot of television in england
but i think that they still have
uh
a theater culture
which i really
doubt we've got anymore there are people
there's a lot of people there
who
really don't feel alive unless they see
a play every week or two
could that ever be brought back here
would you find a way to i doubt it at
the price you have to pay for a ticket
i hate to be so mercenary all the time
but i don't think
i i
you know it's absurd
books are expensive but you can buy a
lot of books for 20 bucks
you can't buy a theater ticket for 20
dollars
that's true it's uh
nobody wants to confront these boring
economic
elements it's terribly boring because
we're in the squirrel cage and it keeps
going around and around the room
but i think this fundamental problem
with the theater is economic right now
and
is everybody greedy i mean the theaters
themselves haven't changed they're still
you know the theater the crucible is
opening up was there 50 years ago you
know
speaking of 50 years ago i was on the
board of the dominus guild and the
chairman of the the president of john's
gildan was oscar hammerstein and one day
i said don't you think
we should try to keep the price of the
ticket from flying away
because uh
you're gonna laugh but the price went
from 440 to 660 to 880 in about
a month
clearly the cost couldn't have gone up
double in that period of time
so he agreed and we called a meeting of
the producers the unions and us
and i made my pitch and i ended them and
i said um
let's
discuss how each side of each element in
the theater can take a little less
just to keep that price within maybe we
can find some
terrific accountant who
can figure out how much less i have to
take and how much less
my producer has to take etc
and i waited and nobody said anything
and i'm still waiting and nobody said
that
it's interesting that the prices they
haven't come down to a low level but
because of september 11th basically
this is the biggest the broadest cutting
of prices i've ever seen in my lifetime
in the theater i don't know
where it probably leads to nothing
they'll just bounce right back up again
the male protagonists in some of your
works for example ride down mount morgan
and death of a salesman are distinctly
unsympathetic characters what is your
motivation in challenging audiences to
care about such harsh and selfish
characters
because they're very much like the
audience
[Laughter]
people wouldn't watch it if they
couldn't find themselves in
it and
drama is always about
people on the edge
uh who likes oedipus
you know he's not very likable
or king leah or hamlet for that matter
he's a real pain
so i don't think of it in those terms
um
lee jay cobb dustin hoffman brian
dennehy these these uh
giant actors not necessarily all
physically who have played
this great role
how do you
see them i don't even mean necessarily
one better than the other obviously but
their interpretations of really i
because uh
various circumstances i always refer
back to lee cobb
as the one
who probably personified that character
most completely and that probably the
reason is subjective because
he discovered the role
he made it happen for the first time
and
he taught us what the role was in a
sense as an actor
uh
the other people were just as fine
actors one or two of them possibly you
didn't think were better
but
you know there's an element of discovery
you can't discover america twice
it's you you know where it is
and uh that takes a certain sting of
discovery away from the thing i remember
one day
for 10 days lee cobb
was mumbling all over the stage we were
in despair in fact kazan thought at one
point that we may have to replace him
you couldn't hear what he was saying and
he seemed to be off in cloud nine
somewhere
and uh suddenly one afternoon
uh
he came to a familiar line
and he belted that line out
and we were all astonished
by this
and he stood up and he performed
and he had it all in his hand there were
four or five people in the theater
and we were all weeping
we were weeping about the play
it was the magnificence of that
imagination
that a human being could do that
and it was unforgettable now
that can only happen once
see everybody else who gets up there
they know that that's
what's possible
we didn't know what was really possible
what about in the last production last
broadway production a lot of people felt
elizabeth franz really did
create
recreate linda do you agree with that
absolutely she uh
see i had not written a passive adoring
wife
she knows from the time the curtain goes
up that he's on the edge of suicide
she knows this because
she has the evidence
it's down the basement that pipe that
he's attached to the water heater
therefore she's got to maneuver
everybody into a position where they
will prevent this from happening
so she's in action all the time
now what elizabeth did was
she made it clear that that was
happening
it was just a question of emphasis not
too much
at that
the other
we had some marvelous
actresses playing that part and but what
they did was they maneuvered their anger
so they wouldn't seem too angry
and alienate
the sons
she didn't give it to him
she was furious
and of course it was marvelous so was it
sort of a revelation to see that well it
was it threw me back to the original
idea which i'd long since forgotten
huh
i
completely obliterated it because i'd
seen these other
terrific performances but on a different
attack
did you ever feel that all my sons was
overshadowed by salesmen
if so why and what is the relationship
between the two plays
uh
you know all my sons was just uh done in
england in a
really great production
at the national theater and in fact they
were going to bring it over here but it
all got tangled up in equity in the rest
of it
uh
and i must say i saw it again after many
years
and i was very impressed
that thing was really a
big piece of work
and i think that it did get
it did get overshadowed by a
salesman but everything did
um
it's interesting though all my sons have
been a number of fairly substantial
revivals of in new york just in the past
20 years well they wanted to bring it
over but one of the reasons they didn't
was that it was so recently revived
the roundabout one yeah but there may be
next year
um
an audience member says i've read that
you've written several of your plays in
blank verse during the original drafts
how is this helpful to you as a writer
well
i wouldn't write a whole play in bank
verse but i write sections of it
uh
it's purely a craft thing it was to
you know verse tends to
compact language
and uh
in order to eliminate every possible
syllable that doesn't belong there
i would write some speeches
especially more lengthy speeches in
verse
which would give me a
formal reason for
drawing it all together
it was purely for my own
purposes
has there been a play of yours where you
felt there's never been a production
that lived up to your vision of the play
there have been several one-act plays
which uh i still think
we should have done better
and been done better
uh
but there's no point mentioning them
anymore
some days somebody's going to do them
that's the great thing about thetis he's
lying there and somebody says why didn't
we do this
this is what happened with all my sons
recently in england
are there any current writers
works that you particularly enjoy
reading or were seeing in the theater
novelists playwrights poets
uh well there's a lot of novelists
around one of them just died suddenly
but not an american
got a sea bald
who was a great writer
uh who died suddenly of a heart attack
uh there's too many for me to even start
to mention
um
we have a lot of writers but we don't
have a lot of producers
we have
i mean that but i don't
i have a wonderful producer now who's
done doing this
he's here tonight so i better be nice
but he is he's terrific
he's crazy
to attempt to work in this environment
in this economic environment
but
i i think the whole thing got out of
hand you mentioned greed before
that's what set me off on that other
story about
it is greed
it is great it's because says
what's his name anderson said
you can make a killing in the theater
but you can't make a living right i
should say robert anderson not arthur
anderson
arthur anderson makes a living and a
killing
[Laughter]
but
he was of course he said that years and
years ago and uh so it's always been
thus and and is the greed just from the
business side or is it also everybody
everybody
because you feel that
it's now or never
it's not what happened see we have no
continuing
core of production
uh i mentioned the british national
theater before and i don't know what
condition it is in at the present moment
but
you got the feeling there at least i did
that once the man was established to
some degree
he had a theater
it's kind of theater
he had a home something
it might not be the british nation it
could be the other ones
that were subsidized by the government
we don't have that we are
it's what o'neill called the show shop
right
and it's it's shop
there's a window and you put your goods
out there
and people pass by and if somebody
sees it and seems to like it
go buy it
and if that
doesn't move them they'll just pass by
which
is adam smith economics but
uh some great great art came out of
theaters that were not there just for
the money
true but what's what i find paradoxical
is that sometimes
great art and your plays or examples of
that have come out of the theater
that were just for the money yeah it's a
dilemma
i mean some of the worst
productions i've seen have been in
middle european
subsidized subsidized that is where
everybody's half asleep
and
uh you wonder why they go on doing it
is that too
but but if you take uh swedes for
example uh what's his name the great
swedish director
movie director ingmar bergman
see
he decides he wants to play again
a pagan is basically a poem more than a
play
it's not going to knock out
800 000 people
it's just going to be something
extraordinary
for those who appreciate that
and that's a national theater and they
say well yes go ahead you only how many
actors you need 90.
oh fine do 90.
can you cut it down to 82.
and they're all complaining that they're
going broke
but some marvelous stuff
ends up there see we can't
in our theater you couldn't produce the
crucible today
i doubt you'd even produce a salesman
because it's too big too dim
crucible's got about 18 or 20 people in
it
you've got to multiply you add to that
the understudies
i don't know that
what the payroll must be 30 35 people
well you can't do that in a little
theater
there aren't enough seats to pay the
salaries for that
and in the big theater
it's too dangerous you've got to lose
your money you might not run for a year
and a half
you as as
a playwright kazan is a director and and
roger stevens is a great producer we're
all present at the creation of
the lincoln center theater which
ultimately would be the vivian beaumont
you didn't stay there long although you
had
two plays after the fall an incident
vichy produced there were there are
lessons in that embryonic experience of
trying to start sort of a national
theater nonprofit theater sure were but
nobody's ever
you want to write anything about it
it's a lot to be learned there
one number one is
see it was backed by big banks
and very rich people because they're the
ones with the money
and what they
expected was that
they
bob whitehead is a probably the most
experienced producer
in the 20th century in
america and he was the head of
production and he said you're never
going to make any money on this you know
that oh yes we know
uh if you're going to lose money
oh why why do we have to lose money well
you do have to lose money because it is
too expensive
well of course he started to produce
plays
uh after the fall did 92
of the seating was taken up they were
very successful and they were losing
more and more money
the more people that came in
nobody can understand this
they're great bankers they're all
financial wizards
and they couldn't add it up
and they
the thing was they were ready to
put their names on a building
and on seats
but not on an actor
and the result was
they wanted to open the theater with rex
harrison in a british
farce
the great the great american
theater was going to open with rex
harrison because people would buy
tickets for rex harrison
isn't it amazing it is amazing well
that's
one lesson
the other lesson is is that you probably
olivier told me he said we were
seven years in chichester
seven years
putting the company together for the
national theater to open
he said we did some buttes that we
failed so many times before they finally
got it
where they wanted it
and he couldn't believe that they
expected
one hit after another usually
even though they've been indoctrinated
presumably in the fact that they they
thought he was kidding
we were talking earlier before we came
on stage there are some
communities that do understand
that kind of subsidization you were
talking about the guthrie in minneapolis
for instance yeah there's tremendous
economic support by the community the
bankers the businesses for
money losing theater
i think that they have a devoted
audience there
uh
as i say that i wonder how long that's
going to go but it is it does exist
they're building a new theater there and
my experience there
that the audience is is really in with
it they really want to see good stuff
however i don't know what the ticket
price is there i suspect it's much lower
than here
sure but it's not i don't think it's
low i mean i still think it's probably
like an off you know an up upper
off-broadway company here probably
i
i could be uh
prejudiced in that direction i i think
that the price is
very important
the price of the ticket
here's a
question
i'm going to alter slightly the question
is in in the writing of your plays how
do you prevent the polemic
uh
the the anti-mccarthyism of the crucible
the salesman
lament and
in death of a salesman from becoming too
heavy-handed
and i'd say a subsidiary question is not
so much how you wrote them but what
happens when productions
want to hammer that in with a
sledgehammer you must see that all the
time
and
well uh
it's when they lose the focus on the
people the reason i wrote
uh one of the reasons that i wrote the
crucible the way i wrote it was that
it was fascinating to me what happened
to the people in that community
and uh if you lose track of the focus on
the people then you're in the polemic
which is not interesting
uh or so a different kind of an interest
it's a journalistic interest
i
i think that the central focus is on the
psychology of the people and their
reactions to real things
once that is lost then you've lost
everything i mean the same thing in
well in any classical work certainly in
shakespeare if you've got if the man is
just saying lines
as then god knows that poetry is un
unmatched
it puts you to sleep
does it worry you that you know as you
were saying before the crucible is is
indeed taught in virtually every school
does it worry you that this sort of
this kind of uh
that often not always but sometimes
didactic teaching
can kind of kill the spark for this
theater
if that's all they're interested in then
they should read a history book
um
um a couple of more here uh
you made a distinction between
narrative and and drama and talking
about the difference between movies and
and
the stage could you elaborate a little
bit more on what that difference is
uh well briefly i think it has to do
with time
uh
you know
the play you probably know best is
salesman but you know salesman takes
place in 24 hours
but you feel you've gone through many
years
with him
right
but uh he arrives at night and he dies
the next night
and all of that happens
between one sunset and the next
well to get that to happen in 24 hours
you got to do a lot of squeezing
and a lot of selectivity goes on well in
the novel
uh you've got an infinite number of
pages
and the tendency is to spread that story
out
and
reach out in all directions as you
please to draw in
ancillary characters and ideas and so on
uh it's a totally different
form a lot of novelists have tried
unsuccessfully to be playwrights
but
it was unsuccessful because they think
their dialogue is dramatic dialogue
and i can't define dramatic dialogue i
don't know what it is accepting i know
when i see it
but there's a difference different music
is simply a different kind of music
and the
narrative music is of a different order
completely even though similar stories
can seem to be tolerable
um we'll end with a
somewhat philosophical question from
from the audience um
if you were starting over your
career your life
is there something you would do
differently that something conspicuous
you would do differently
i
it's hard to answer that but i suppose i
would be tempted to become
a movie
writer and director
for the simple reason that
to enter this theater now in this
condition that it's in
is rather foolhardy
it's it's so uh
unresponsive
to the ideals that i thought i came in
with
and the people around me had it wasn't
it wasn't just me
we thought we were
in a tradition that began with the
greeks
that was serious business
we of course were up to our next show
business we wanted to succeed we wanted
to do all the things that theater people
want to do
but in the backs of our minds there were
standards that were as old as
man
i'm not sure that that's disappeared
i i'm not in enough with young people to
tell you whether it
exists or doesn't exist
i don't smell it from the stage i think
what we've got now a little
it's because possibly
you can't do a play anymore there's more
than four people or something
everything got squeezed down down down
down
and uh the amplitude of the theater
uh
i mean if shakespeare were live today
how could he get his plays produced
i mean there isn't one of them that is
less than what
yeah 15
people right and and and long besides
they've passed the 11 o'clock union cut
off right um
then let me just ask one last question
why is it then because it's this i know
to be true
um and i'm sure you do too there are
young people
who every year come to new york
not to be in television not to be in the
fashion business not to be in the movie
business but who want to go in
in into the theater what is that
essential spark that keeps it happening
with all the obstacles that are in the
way of it happening you know sandberg
wrote a wonderful line say the line as
simple as
always the young strangers
they are uh crazed by this idea of
of
uh
becoming somebody else perhaps of
interpreting their lives so on
i don't think this art is going to die
i don't think it'll ever die because
fundamentally it's too simple
all we need is these boards
and a couple of lights and somebody
telling you
something interesting he couldn't get
simpler than that
but uh
we're making it
extraordinarily difficult
for that art to show its head i mean a
play is a very delicate mechanism
as anybody knows has been near it
uh one speech badly said can throw off
ten minutes of reality
and think of that as having to support
an investment of millions of dollars
that little frail thing
it's like dancing on an egg
and yes that's what we're alleged
to have to do
i
i'm just appalled by it i i think it's a
kind of decay that
since everybody's so greedy
it got to this crazy
dimension
where
the thing really is out of control
it's gone
west
but
it will be here even if it's done in a
stable
but i hate to think of that see i
my argument with it is not economic it's
that it has changed playwriting
it really has changed the nature of
playwriting
if you are told or if you know that you
can't really employ more than a handful
of actors
then what about the stories and the
dramas that require more
well they don't get written or they
become movies
see and the movie has taken over
the grand theme
the movies are about the presidency the
movies are about
crime the movies are about all kinds of
interesting subjects
because they can put the camera up there
and you see uh 200 people
we got
eight people
tough
this
well thank you and thank you for being
our audience tonight
[Music]
you